Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, du bist ja gar nicht in Uniform.
Nein, ich bin im Kortanzug hier.
Sehr gut, der Chord-Anzug. Meiner ist übrigens noch in der Mache. Ich hab den am 24.12. bestellt. Nur online. Ich hab ihn noch nie gesehen. Freu mich drauf. Aber noch ist er nicht bei mir angekommen.
Mal gucken.
Sehr gut. Ich hoffe nicht olivgrün.
Nein, meiner ist dunkelgrün, aber nicht deiner gülden. Wir müssen das sagen.
Ja, ja, ist gülden. Wenn gleich Kamouflage jetzt auch wieder bei den Fashion Weeks vertreten ist, das ist besorgniserregend. Wir werden ja über den Krieg, über die Panzerlieferung und vor allem auch die mediale Repräsentation sprechen. Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, es gab dieses Buch von Precht und Wälzer, dann gab es die Reaktion der Journalisten darauf, nein, das ist alles falsch, Melanie Amann, wir haben das alles noch im Ohr. Dann konnte man nach der Lektüre sagen, ja, manche Thesen sind vielleicht ein bisschen überspitzt. Bei manchen muss man differenzieren. Das war ja auch ein Resultat unseres Gesprächs im Salon. Aber jetzt habe ich den Eindruck, jetzt möchte man wirklich jede einzelne These, eigentlich jeden Satz aus diesem Buch bestätigen, medial.
Genau, ich habe das auch gestern noch mal im Kopf so überschlagen. Das Buch kam im Oktober, hat eine Riesenwelle verursacht, ist komplett vergessen und alle sind gefangen in ihrem Corona-Modus, sozusagen. Follow the signs, diesmal follow the military, also was das Militär sagt.
Aber nur bestimmte Experten, also es sind ja auch da wieder nur ein paar Glauben, und die anderen dürfen ja, sollen nicht oder werden nicht wahrgenommen. Also wir hatten ja Mark Millie hier schon im Podcast, der sagte, da müssen wir aufpassen, dass es nicht wie ein erster Weltkrieg wird, dass man dort endlose Stellungskriege hat und Millionen Tote. Dann wird das vielleicht von hier einem Militär aufgegriffen. Dann heißt es, ja, das sind Kreml-News, die hier verbreitet werden. Ich fand auch sehr interessant, dass es ja viele gab, die sagten, na ja, wenn jetzt diese Panzer genehmigt werden, dann haben wir so eine neue Eskalationsspirale. Was kommt dann als nächstes? Das wurde dann bis zur Panzerlieferung hin auch noch als ja fast Verschwörungstheorie abgetan. Ich will diese Namen da gar nicht nennen. Die sagen, ja, das ist ja schlimm. Ich hab Mitleid mit den Leuten, las ich bei Twitter bei einem reichweiten starken Profil, Mitleid mit den Leuten, die immer so an Domino-Effekte glauben. Und es war ja gerade heraus, wir liefern diese Panzer im Verbund mit den Amerikanern. Und schon gab es ja Forderungen danach, naja, dann brauchen wir aber jetzt auch mal was für die Luft und wir brauchen Jets und so weiter.
Und niemand hat es richtig ausgeschlossen, ne? Wieder die Amerikaner.
Ja, Scholz.
Scholz sehr hart, aber der Deutschlandfunk ist auch schon wieder der Meinung, da gibt es so Einflugscheneisen für Meinungsänderungen. Und Pistorius hat ja im Tagesthemengespräch nur gesagt, ich hoffe, dass wir nicht über Flugzeuge reden müssen, als bald.
Genau.
Also eine Hoffnung markiert.
Eine Hoffnung. Und wie gesagt, wir haben ja mal angefangen mit Helmen und haben uns entsprechend gesteigert, ihr zu tun, als sei das völlig aus der Luft gegriffen, zeigt eigentlich, dass wir es da mit so Goldfischgehirn zu tun haben, die diese 15 Minuten Präsenz haben, aber dann nicht wissen, wie die vergangenen Monate verlaufen sind. Denn es war ja auch mal ein ganz starker Diskurs, also Leopards auf keinen Fall. Also das machen wir wirklich nicht.
Keine westliche Bauart bei den Panzern und so, oder?
Ja, da war auch noch von denen, die schon damals sehr, sagen wir, beläzistisch unterwegs waren, immer die Aussage, naja, es geht ja hier gar nicht um Leopards. Es geht ja um anderes Gerät, das man braucht. Also man hat auch da immer so getan, als sei das erst mal völlig abwegig.
Wir hatten ja ganz lange die Unterscheidung von schwerer und leichter Waffen. Und die war ja total gesetzt. Wir liefern ja nur leichter Waffen als unsere Erklärung, warum wir uns da gar nicht so sehr involvieren. Und dann hatte Marietta Slomka Mützenich im Gespräch und hat ihn so ganz dispektierlich gefragt, ja, aber gibt's denn, also glauben Sie denn, ein Unterschied zwischen Verteidigungs- und Angriffswaffen? Jetzt ist doch alles Verteidigung. Also wir sind aus, wir schießen nur mit Panzerfäusten, die man noch mobil und so weiter, nichts mit Rädern und so weiter, haben wir schon so Räder mitgeliefert dann, dass die Amerikaner die Reichweiten begrenzt haben, von 350 auf 70 Kilometer wurde gar nicht groß thematisiert, hätte man ja auch unter Verräter und so die Bande laufen lassen können. Und jetzt mittlerweile ist alles eine Defensivwaffe und der Neitzel, Sönke Neitzel, der einzige Militärkriegs-Professor oder wie auch immer, er sich genau bezeichnet, den wir in Deutschland haben, sitzt dann bei Anne Will und sagt, ja, also unsere Herangehensweise ist, wir fragen die Militärs, was sie für sinnvoll erachten, was wir liefern sollten. Und dann sollte die Politik entscheiden, das zu liefern und es der Öffentlichkeit erklären. Und dann gibt es nur noch, sagt er, nur noch logistische Fragen. Da packt man sich so ein bisschen, das ist doch keine Debatte. Also dafür braucht man ja keine Diskurssendung, sondern das kann man dann noch einfach verkünden. So, ich bin der Meinung, die Militärs fordern, die Politik entscheidet zu deren Gründen, was sie brauchen. Und der Rest ist nur noch Erklärungsarbeit. Und so dann auch die Deitelhoff und so. Es kommen jetzt so einige, die dann meinten, ja, wenn man den Krieg nur ordentlich erklärt, sind die Leute auch dafür. Der Afghanistan-Einsatz ist daran gescheitert, dass er den Leuten nicht erklärt wurde.
Ja, aber das ist diese...
Aber wir müssen noch zehn Jahre mehr gemacht.
Vorherrschende Ideologie. Wir müssen nun mal die Narrative ändern. Und wenn wir ein schönes Narrativ oder ein Framing oder was man gerade sagt, dafür gefunden hat, dann müsste das doch weiter laufen. Und da finde ich dann doch eine Umfrage sehr interessant. Es gab ja diese Umfrage, sind sie für Panzerlieferungen. Spiegel hat die veröffentlicht. Und da heißt es dann 47 Prozent Stimmen für Ja und 43 für Nein. Und das ist doch eine sehr, sehr erstaunliche Zahl, wenn man bedenkt, dass es wirklich medial fast nur die eine Richtung gibt, bis auf wenige Ausnahmen. Und auch nicht alle diese Ausnahmen sind alle seriös. Aber es gibt sie natürlich. Und in der Phoenix-Runde oder so findet man sie. Man findet sie auch bisweilen in Zeitungsbeiträgen. Aber wir haben tatsächlich die Bestätigung von Welses und Prechtsthese jetzt par excellence hier. Und trotzdem hat man offenbar auch noch viel eigenständiges Denken in der Bevölkerung, dass dieses Narrativ nicht einfach so aufgreift und fortspinnend, was aber wiederum sehr bemerkenswert ist. 85 Prozent der Grünen-Wähler sind für Panzerlieferung. Vielleicht erklärt sich deshalb dann auch, warum doch einige Spitzenpolitiker der Grünen völlig durchgeknallt sind, als es dann um diese Panzerlieferung ging und sie auch dann gestattet wurden.
Ja, die bespielen ihr Wählerpotenzial. Das hat mit der Ukraine dann sekundär zu tun. Die Grünen kommen ja auch zum Teil aus der Friedensbewegung. Die liegt natürlich lange zurück, mehr als zwei grüne Politiker-Generationen. Aber manche sind ja doch noch da. Das ist vielleicht eine der ganz großen Fragen, die jetzt noch offen ist. Ansonsten würde ich auch sagen, sehr viele sehr interessante Parallelen. Es verlockt fast zu dieser Pointe, dass wir, ähnlich wie bei Corona, eher auch wieder ein Handlungsvermögen zurück haben wollen. Bei Corona hieß es ja Ende, Waschenmaske auf und so. Wie wir das jetzt bei dem Thema machen. Habeck hat es ja versucht mit Energiesparen, also dass wir darüber Solidarität und Vernunft zeigen und die Welt ein bisschen mitgestalten können. Aber was wäre, wenn wir bei den Materiallieferungen auch sagen würden, wir haben eine Eskalation außenpolitisch, wir schicken Zeug in die Ukraine. Aber wie steht es eigentlich um unsere Verteidigungsfähigkeit? Also der Anfangsgag zum Thema, bist du schon in Uniform. Müssen wir uns jetzt Gasmasken und Helme anschaffen schon, damit wir für den Ernstfall gerüstet sind? Und Corona plötzlich blank dastehen und sagen, ich habe gar keine Maske und die kostet 8, 50 Euro und jemand bereichert sich eine Apotheke. Also jetzt schon mal Stahlhelme kaufen oder nicht. Es gab gestern eine Straßenumfrage in Leipzig, wo ein junger Mann unser Alter meinte, jedenfalls unsicher so ein bisschen, dass er nicht genau weiß, was in einem Jahr ist, ob er dann ein Einberufungsbescheid nach Polen bekommt, um dort für die Bundeswehr zu arbeiten. Und er hat das so als für die Bundeswehr arbeiten, aber wir wissen ja ungefähr, was gemeint ist. Und wenn man dann wirklich noch mal rekapituliert, wie das Jahr gelaufen ist, also Russland greift an, der Konvau ist 70, 60 Kilometer lang, alle haben Angst, Kiew soll fallen und dann fällt Kiew doch nicht. Man kriegt das irgendwie verteidigt, vielleicht spielt auch das Wetter eine Rolle und so. Precht sagt, die Ukraine hat gar keine Chance, sie soll sich ergeben, so wird wenigstens Zerstörung und Tod vermieden. Und jetzt ein Jahr später schicken wir plötzlich unsere Panzer und so weiter. Wer will wirklich ernsthaft behaupten, dass er weiß, was in einem Jahr ist? Ende 2023, Anfang 2024, man kann ja nichts ausschließen.
Da kann man auch gar nichts modellieren. Also wir haben ja schon bei Modellierungen bei Corona mitunter gesehen, naja, das hat nicht alles immer so ganz am Ende gestimmt, aber es war doch in der Tendenz richtig, sagen wir. Das kann man aber bei einem Krieg überhaupt nicht sagen. Da haben wir irgendwelche Kontingenzen, irgendwelche Eskalationen, die loslaufen und dann sind sie nicht mehr aufzuhalten. Und das merkt man, glaube ich, doch sehr stark, wenn man in den sozialen Medien unterwegs ist und sieht, wie dort Grüne reagiert haben. Also zwei Wochen, bevor dann diese Panzer geliefert wurden oder zehn Tage vorher, hat Ralf Füchse von diesem eigenartigen Institut Liberale Moderne, der ja bei den Grünen ist, wo ja die Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung ein wichtiges Amt hatte, der hat dieses berühmte Foto, dieses Chinesische vom Tianmenplatz gepostet.
Wo der Mann den Panzer aufhält.
Wo ein einsamer Mann sich gegen diese Aufrüstung, gegen diesen Militarismus, gegen diese Härte des chinesischen Regimes stellt, sich einsam hinstellt gegen diese Panzer. Und was macht Füchse? Er macht ein Meme draus und nimmt dieses Foto und schreibt Scholz drauf. Also Scholz ist jetzt der Einsame, der sich aufhält gegen die Panzer. Also das ist derart geschmacklos, dass man so etwas macht und dass das einfach durchgeht. Also dass es auch keine Entschuldigung eingefordert wird. Dann werden die Leoparden geliefert. Und ich sage jetzt auch schon Leoparden, man sollte immer sagen Leopardpanzer. Ja, genau. Kathrin Göring-Eckardt, sie ein hohes Tier bei der evangelischen Kirche gewesen. Eigentlich schon damals wäre das ein Grund gewesen, auszutreten. Jedenfalls bei den Grünen ja auch, Vizepräsidentin im Bundestag schreibt The Leopard's Freed. Jetzt kann er hoffentlich schnell der Ukraine bei ihrem Kampf gegen den russischen Angriff und für die Freiheit der Ukraine und Europas helfen. The Leopard's Freed, als sei das jetzt so ein Tierchen, das man aus dem Käfig lässt. Den Vogel abschießt, ja dann Johannes Wagner, auch von den Grünen, schreibt Let's free the Leopard Emoji. Let's free the Leopard now. Also man muss sich doch mal vergegenwärtigen, es handelt sich hier um eine Waffe zum Töten von Menschen. Meines Wissens sind Russen auch Menschen. Und dass man dann noch argumentieren kann mit irgendwelchen Sachzwängen. Oder ja, das wäre aber eine sinnvolle Lieferung. Und das sind ja alles auch militäre strategische Erwägungen, über die kann man dieser und jeder Meinung sein. Darum geht es ja überhaupt nicht. Aber dass man wirklich jetzt dabei angekommen ist, dass man eigentlich so eine richtige Freude daraus sprechen lässt aus den Tweets und Posts, dass man jetzt Waffen liefert, die dazu da sind, Menschen zu töten, das ist für mich unerträglich. Also ich finde auch, wir haben es ja mit einer Partei zu tun, die so viele Werte drauflegt, dass wir uns korrekt ausdrücken. Also Stichwort Sprachpolizei. Ich finde, wir sollten jetzt einfach mal diese Leute canceln.
Ich habe ihn übrigens gecancelt.
Du hast ihn gecancelt?
Johannes Wagner hat mich eingeladen. Er hat sich vorgestellt als bayerischer Bundestagsabgeordneter für die Grünen aus dem ältesten, also bevölkerungsmäßig ältesten Wahlkreis Bayerns. Da habe ich gesagt, ich mache sehr gerne so eine Veranstaltung. Ich habe sowieso recht wenig politische Veranstaltungen, wo ich eingeladen werde. Es sind dann mehr so, keine Ahnung, so Firmen, die sich für sowas interessieren, was ist mit meiner Belegschaft oder was ist mit diesen ganzen Investmentkramen. Und ich habe ihm zugesagt, er hat einen Termin rausgesucht mit Ricarda Lange, also seiner Parteichefin. Und dann stellt er sich aber raus, es ist ein Online-Termin. Und da weiß er, wie ich es habe. Ich muss dann leider absagen, weil Online-Termine, keine Ahnung, also ein Podcast für 15 Leute, die da live zuschauen und dann nochmal sieben, die sich aus Versehen darauf verirren, mache ich ja nicht. Aber ich habe ihn dann eingeladen, er kann ja gerne in einen meiner Podcasts kommen. Da haben wir auch Publikum und sehr viel junges Publikum usw. Und da kann man dann auch thematisch ein bisschen offener nochmal über alle Themen reden und nicht nur über den ältesten Wahlkreis Bayerns. Ich habe aber noch keine Antwort bekommen.
Ja, wir wollen sehen. Ich finde aber, das Wort canceln ist eigentlich genau richtig. Also wir haben ein hyperventilierendes Twitter, wenn Christian Lindner auf offener Bühne einen Herrenwitz erzählt. Heute Morgen bin ich mit Frau Sohn so aufgewacht. Haha, natürlich nicht im Bett, sondern wir haben telefoniert. So, und dann geht das vier Wochen los, wie kann dieser Showman ist nur. Und hier haben wir es mit Leuten zu tun, die Tötungsmaschinen verherrlichen, was dann so weit geht, dass Sahra Nani, auch für die Krön im Bundestag, sich in einem Leoparden-T-Shirt fotografiert, schreibt free the Leopards, just do it, und Dr. Eva Högl, das ist die Werbeauftragte der Grünen, schreibt drunter sehr cool mit einem Herzchen-Emoji. Das ist doch nicht mehr auszuhalten, dass wir eine solche Verrohung erleben.
Wir müssen das auch noch mal im Detail beschreiben. Wie heißt sie noch mal, die Grüne?
Sie heißt Sahra Nani. Ich hab sie sogar ausgedruckt, damit du das hier noch mal vor Augen hast.
Genau, ausgedruckt ist ja nur die halbe Wahrheit, denn das ist ja nicht nur ein Foto, es ist ja ein Gift.
Es ist ein Gift, genau.
Sie blinzelt also die ganze Zeit so ganz schmachtend irgendwie in die Kamera. Und sie hat ja nicht nur ein leopardengeflecktes Hemd an, sondern es hat ja noch ein Nike-Symbol sehr sichtbar drauf, sodass ihr Just Do It eigentlich auch noch mal da...
Ach, das ist der Slogan von Nike?
Ja, das ist der Slogan von Just Do It, Nike.
Ah, ja, das wusste ich nicht. Das ist sonst nicht so meine Marke.
Genau, und Eva Högl macht ja nicht nur diese Smiley mit den Herzchenaugen, dass sehr cool schreibt, sondern das sehr hat ja eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Es. Also es ist ja eine wirklich liebkosende Kommunikation, die für Twitter gar nicht geeignet ist, sondern mehr so in Messenger stattfinden sollte. Und das, sagen wir mal so, 17 Minuten nachdem Eva Högl fast Verteidigungsministerin geworden wäre.
Ja, ganz richtig.
Und sie noch mal 200 Milliarden gefordert hat und so weiter. Und das ist unglaublich. Aber hast du auch Anna-Lena Baerbock, bzw. in ihrem Namen, auf dem englischen Account diesen Tweet mit?
Den habe ich, glaube ich, auch mit. Und zwar das Auswärtige Amt.
Ja, genau.
Hat sich auch noch hingerissen, was zu twittern. Und das ist ja das Problem, man will ja lustig sein. Man will lustig sein, auch wenn man den offiziellen Account betreibt vom German Foreign Office. Und dann hat man dort geschrieben The Russian Foreign Minister Lavrov is in Africa. Not to see, dann Leopard Emoji, Leopard, but to plainly claim that Ukraine's partners want to destroy everything Russian. Here is a threat with all this evidence. Und dann geht es weiter, there is none. Und dann wird ein Leopard in der Wüste gezeigt. Daraufhin hat sich ja dann eine hohe Diplomatin eingemischt.
Sag genau, wer es ist.
Ja, Moment.
Sie ist die Sprecherin des Vorsitzenden der Afrikanischen Union. Man kann es also nicht höher ansiedeln, wo diese Reaktion her kam.
Und sie sagt, man sollte vielleicht mal in Deutschland darüber nachdenken, die kolonistische Perspektive zu verlassen, kolonialistische und was dann überhaupt dieser Unsinn soll und auch als so die Unterstellung so, ja und wenn Deutschland nach Afrika kommt, dann wollen die ja nur Gutes tun oder so, ne?
Ja, also sie hat sich ja auf allen Ebenen darüber aufgeregt.
Ja, auf allen Ebenen.
Erstens, Lavrov kommt nicht nach Afrika, sondern er besucht ein spezifisches Land, so wie auch die Ministerin, die Deutsche, nicht nach Afrika ging, sondern halt Länder besucht hat. Dann mit der Frage, war denn Baerbock da, um sich Tiere anzuschauen? Sind wir Afrika überhaupt nur einfach The Big Five, die Lieferanten für eine kleine Safari-Tour? Und abschließend mit der Frage, ist es alles nur ein Joke für das deutsche Außenministerium? Also es war die größtmögliche Plamage. Plus, habe ich gestern gesehen, diesen Tweet hat die Sprecherin auch noch auf ihrem Account oben angepinnt. Tatsächlich. Damit er immer da ist. Damit man nicht gleich sieht, was jetzt die... Alles in allem muss man in dem Falle mal sagen, afrikanische Meinung, die afrikanische politische Meinung, zur deutschland ist. Also wir haben uns hier, und das müssen wir für nachher im Hinterkopf behalten, wenn wir uns darüber verständigen, auf welchen Ebenen fühlen wir denn eigentlich Krieg? Wir haben ja schon Weltkrieg, Charakter, bei der ein oder anderen Dimension ausgemacht. Das ist wirklich hochdramatisch, was hier gerade abläuft, auf Twitter und so weiter. Also nicht nur die Spielerei in Deutschland, wie das einfach politisch verlichtet wird.
Also diplomatisch eine totale Katastrophe. Bis hin dann dazu, dass das Baerbock sagt, wir kämpfen gemeinsam einen Krieg gegen Russland, wo man auch denkt, meine Güte. Also wenn man ja jetzt im Freien sprechen, da manchmal vielleicht seine Schwierigkeiten oder so hat, da muss man es mit Kaiser Franz Joseph I von Österreich machen. Du weißt, der hatte immer wieder Probleme in Fettnäpfchen bei Kulturveranstaltungen zu treten. Der hat dann irgendwas gesagt und das hat mitunter auch schon Künstlerkriegern ruiniert. Ich glaube, einen hat der auch in den Suizid getrieben. Jedenfalls hat sich daraufhin Kaiser Franz Joseph gesagt, ich mach jetzt da nichts mehr riskantes. Ich sage einfach nur noch, es war sehr schön, es hat mich sehr gefreut. Das würde ich jetzt sowieso mal allen Politikern empfehlen, wenn man nicht weiter weiß, immer Kaiser Franz Joseph, es war sehr schön, es hat mich sehr gefreut.
Also Annalena Baerbock sprach im Europarat auf so eine Nachfrage, antwortend, also gar nicht in ihrem Redebeitrag, sondern nur so ganz spontan, abschließend mit dieser Pointe, wir sind in einem Krieg gegen Russland und nicht untereinander, war, ich habe jetzt echt ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, eigentlich der größte politische Fehler, der mir so in den letzten Jahren unterkam. Die CDU hat viel Scheiße gemacht und so, aber bei denen ist das halt Agenda und die haben dann Interesse und das ist halt einfach deren Programm.
Kommen wir heute noch zu, machen wir Schönes dabei.
Annalena Baerbock hat ja einfach einen krassen Fehler gemacht. Und zwar aus so einer Laune heraus, weil sie eine Pointe in einer Gesprächssituation setzen wollte, völlig vergessend, in welcher Rolle sie da ist.
Sie hätte nur sagen müssen, wir ziehen doch gemeinsam an einem Strang oder es muss uns doch um Solidarität in Europa gehen. Irgendso was, hätte sie sagen können.
Genau und ich frag mich auch so ein bisschen, Olaf Scholz ist Bundeskanzler. Mützenich hat für ihn schon die Außenpolitik als Kanzleramts Chefsache deklariert. Da gab es schon einen großen Streit mit dem Außenministerium. Und jetzt hat sie diesen Spruch gemacht, drei Tage nachdem Boris Pistorius Verteidigungsminister wurde, der, das muss man eben auch sagen, vor so einem rentenrepublikanischen Publikum wie in Deutschland einen sehr guten Job macht, medial. Der einfach da steht und so wie Stefan Weil versprochen hat, Autorität und Sicherheit vermittelt, das vermittelt er halt. Ist ja egal, was im Hintergrund stattfindet, aber vor der Kamera funktioniert er eins a. Und ich glaube, Annalena Baerbocks Zeit ist einfach zu Ende. Solange der Krieg läuft, ist Außenpolitik Ukraine Politik und die wird jetzt im Verteidigungsministerium bei Olaf Scholz gemacht. Annalena Baerbocks hat sich richtig aus dem Spiel genommen. Das wird auch in einem halben Jahr nicht vergessen. Weil die Russen, solange der Krieg so läuft und solange Putin regiert, die ganze Zeit läuft dieser Clip überall auf der Welt. Weil die vergessen das ja nicht.
Da kann man auch nicht sagen, da machen die Russen ihre Propaganda draus. Na ja, das hat sie gesagt. Wie sollen sie darauf reagieren?
Klar machen die da ihre Propaganda draus.
Aber man kann es ja auch nicht sagen. Wenn man es sagt, genau das ist ja das, was Scholz mit aller Gewalt vermeiden will. Es gab ja zwei interessante Artikel im Spiegel ein und einen in der Zeit. Und zwar, Scholz, erleben wir, steht da beim Spiegel, so als ein Mann, der konstant heruntergekühlt durch die politische Szenerie geleitet wird, so wie am Mittwoch ab ins Auto, rein in den Bundestag reden, raus aus dem Bundestag, hier ein Lächeln, da ein Lächeln. Aber man fragt sich, was ist eigentlich hinter den Kulissen los? Das ist nämlich nur der öffentliche Olaf Scholz. Hinter verschlossenen Türen sieht das anders aus. Also bei kleineren Abstellungen, Tiefonaten, Treffen, vertraulichen Sitzungen. Deswegen kann ja auch nicht explizit zitiert werden. Er knöpft sich dann mal die Medien vor, heißt es. Mal politische Analysten, mal Kritiker in der eigenen Koalition. All jene, die aus seiner Sicht den Verstand verloren haben und vom Kriegsfieber ergriffen sind, die, so Scholz, jedes Waffensystem zu durchdringen glauben, die erst Haubitzen für die Ukraine forderten, dann Panzer, jetzt Flugzeuge und irgendwann ganz sicher auch Truppen. Diese Bellizisten soll er diese Woche intern geschimpft haben. Diese Kriegsbegeisterten. Und er findet das also durchweg schrecklich. Die Zeit schreibt Ähnliches. Da heißt es, Olaf Scholz hingegen sieht sich, also da wurde auch dann beschrieben, wie eigentlich so die Stimmung ist, Olaf Scholz hingegen sieht sich mit beiden als herausragenden Experten in der Staatskunst des Cooking the Frog. Also man erhitzt das Ganze, ohne dass der Frosch, damit ist dann natürlich Putin gemeint, es merkt. Aber man versucht nicht zu eskalieren. Scholz sieht seine Strategie so gut beschrieben. Wie weit kann man gehen, ohne einen Weltkrieg auszulösen? Nicht weniger steht aus seiner Sicht auf dem Spiel. Für alle, die fordern, es müssen mehr, schneller, entschlossener gehandelt werden, hat er nur Verachtung übrig. Man darf nicht wirklich zitieren, was der Kanzler über solche Leute sagt. Aber es fallen dann ziemlich heftige Worte, die in Richtung Feigheit, Dummheit, Kriegsgeilheit gehen. Und wir sind tatsächlich medial an einem Punkt angekommen, wo man, wenn man sagt, ich glaube, Scholz macht das ziemlich gut gerade mit seinen Mitte, wenngleich ich gegen diese Panzerlieferung bin. Aber dass man an sich sagen kann, wir haben hier einen Kanzler, der sich der Gefahr sehr bewusst ist, dass man damit schon fast jetzt eine widerständige Position bezieht, wenn man den Kanzler gut findet.
Wir können nur wieder hoffen, dass er durchhält. Aber er sieht ja auch so aus, als würde er durchhalten.
Da bin ich ja dann noch auch froh. Wir haben ja auch über die Skandale, die er hatte und sowas gesprochen. Wahrscheinlich braucht es dann doch so jemanden, der mit allen Wassern gewaschen ist und nicht nervös wird.
Ja, ich habe gestern auch mit Mick noch mal diesen kleinen Witz gemacht. Und der gilt wahrscheinlich grundsätzlich. Medial ist ja alles möglich. Aber sehr viele Leute, die gerade sich medial äußern, allen voran Agnes Strack-Zimmermann, die sind ja sozusagen ein Schritt vor der echten Macht. Also wo sie nicht nur die Tagesordnung im Ausschuss für Verteidigung und so, sondern wo sie auch die Tagesordnungspunkte final entscheidend abschließen und sagen, ich habe entschieden, ich bin in der Verantwortung. Und ich glaube, selbst Agnes Strack-Zimmermann würde als Verteidigungsministerin, wenn es hieße, herzlichen Glückwunsch, Sie sind der Minister, in 15 Minuten beginnt Ihr Treffen mit dem amerikanischen Außenminister oder sowas. Also ist ja bei Pistoros mit dem Ostenleut, dem Verteidigungsminister passiert, dass dann auch anders darüber gedacht wird. Und wir haben ja viel über Mark Milley gesprochen. Mark Milley war jetzt das erste Mal in Polen, um sich mit seinem ukrainischen Counterpart zu treffen. Also die Bande wird da immer fester geknüpft. Es läuft sozusagen eine direkte 1 zu 1 auf Augenhöhe. Wir unterstützen euch da, wo ihr es braucht. Und Biden und Scholz machen jetzt das massimediale Theater. Also es war ja auch fast hinreißend zu sehen, wie Scholz über Boris Pistorios nach diesem Rammstein treffen, an dem Scholz ja nicht selbst teilnahm, sondern Pistorios. Aber dann sich die Kommunikation so ergab, dass der Leut Osten zurückgeflogen ist nach Amerika. Dort neben Blinken, also der Verteidigungsminister, der Außenminister und beiden vorne am Rednerpult, namentlich Olaf Scholz gedankt haben für die Politik, die in Europa macht. Und das haben ja die deutschen Journalisten nicht einordnen können, weil sie ja alle auf den Track waren. Da gab es einen Megastreit und der Wolfgang Schmidt, also der Stabschef im Bundeskanzleramt, hat sich ja laut gestritten mit Osten, als er da war usw. Und ich glaube mittlerweile, ob liegen da allen Fehlkommunikation. Irgendwer erklärt irgendwas und dann schaukelt sich das hoch als Flurgespräche und dann schreiben alle auf, dass es da Megastreit gab. Und wenn man genau durchdenkt, ich versuchte das gestern, also bis gestern im Podcast mit Mick auch, man käme überhaupt nicht dahinter. Worüber sollten die sich denn lautstark streiten? Also das findet auch auf ganz anderen Ebenen statt.
Selbst Carlo Massalla hat ja bei Anne Will gestern Abend sehr gut erklärt, dass das mit diesem NATO Artikel 5, das ist so eine Sache. Also wann ist das wirklich ein Beistand im Sinne von ein militärischer Beistand? Er sagt, der Beistand kann auch bedeuten, man schreibt eine Beileitskarte. Also das ist ziemlich offen, dieser Beistandsparagraf. Und deshalb ist es von Scholz taktisch sehr klug zu sagen, ja, wir agieren da gemeinsam mit den Amerikanern. So sind die auch immer mit dabei. Das heißt, es wird nicht erst gefragt nach Beistand oder so, sondern man ist schon immer beieinander in dem, was man tut. Wenn man einzelne Wege geht, alleine solitäre Maßnahmen ergreift, dann könnte man im Zweifelsfall vielleicht von den hören, ja, aber das wollten wir ja nicht, haben wir ja gar nicht mitgemacht, habt ihr ja allein gemacht. Das heißt also, dass man das immer als konstatierte Aktion macht, ist genau das Richtige jetzt, wenn man in dieser NATO-Logik denkt. Und das tut Scholz ja ganz offenbar. Und dass man dieses journalistische Narrativ daraus bastelt, ja, die Deutschen sind zögerlich. Ich meine, es gibt sowieso so eine Tradition in Deutschland, wir laden uns unglaublich gerne aus dem Ausland Thinktanker ein, die uns dann beschimpfen und dann sagen wir, ja, so ist es aber auch wirklich. Und man hört aber dann ungern, wenn vom Ausland Lob kommt und dann ein beiden sagt, ja, das hat so wunderbar geklaut, dass wir das hier reinigen konnten.
Wir haben da gestern auch so ein bisschen spekuliert. Es ist ja total absurd dann zu unterstellen, dass Scholz ihn gerade erpresst oder so, sondern dass dieses Statement einfach stattfand, ist für die Journalisten unerklärlich. Und alle Erklärungen, die es dann dazu gibt, gehen schon echt so ins Verschwörungstheoretische. Also da ist man echt bei Panfiction angekommen.
Du sagst es, ich hab auch hier den Tweet. Jan Böhmermann hatte zwei Tweets abgesendet. Der eine war, was weiß Russland über Scholz, was wir nicht wissen, so sinngemäß. Also nach dem Motto, es gibt da Leichen im Keller, von denen vielleicht die Russen wissen könnten. Und deswegen kann Scholz nicht entsprechend progressiv auftreten, was Panzerlieferung anbelangt. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, dass hier so etwas gestrickt wird. Also wir kennen rechte Verschwörungstheorien, die sagen, ja, wird eh alles von Washington aus gesteuert. Wir werden vom Pentagon regiert und von Biden und seiner Administration. Wir sind ja gar kein souveränes Land. Wir sind ja besetzt. Und jetzt wird hier gesagt, der Kanzler, also wird natürlich als Frage formuliert, gemutmaßt, der Kanzler könne gar nicht souverän handeln. Und dann bömer man nochmal später Twitter dann, man sollte stets vorsichtig sein, wenn etwas auf vermeintlich pragmatische Motive der SPD hindeutet, in allem, was mit Russland zu tun hat. So als sei also die SPD generell irgendwie unter der Knute Moskaus und würde entsprechend agieren. Ich finde das unerträglich, dass so etwas einfach gesendet wird, also da über den Älter geschickt wird bei Twitter und es dann außer vielleicht von Mürzenich oder Ralf Stegner so keinen Widerspruch gibt. Also auch da muss man einfach sehen, dass Jan Böhmer mit einer solchen Reichweite ja eigentlich eine Verantwortung hätte und kann da nicht einfach, nur weil er jetzt gerade auf diesem Trip ist, wir müssen alle waffen, alle alles machen, um diesen Krieg da zu führen. Also das ist wirklich schlimmster Billizismus.
Ja, der Legende nach gibt es ja in Russland, in Moskau ein Hotelzimmer mit einem großen Spiegel und jeder, der an der SPD eine große Nummer wird, wird erstmal da eingeladen zu irgendeiner Veranstaltung und dann warten da so Frauen und dann werden so Videos angefertigt, die dann später als Kompromat, und das soll der Twitter-Legende nach eine seit 20 Jahren laufende, also seit Puntin da die Geschäfte führt, schon mal vorbereitend Kompromatlieferungen und so. Aber ja, damit ist man so weit in so einer Denklogik, die man vor anderthalb Jahren noch als den anderen unterschiebend, die irgendwie kommen mit so einer Idee, wie das Coronavirus kommt ja aus einem Labor und so. Also da ist man echt da angekommen. Das ist wirklich Fanfiction-Produktion, die auf Twitter da stattfindet. Und Sachen, die man sich da nicht mehr erklären kann, selbst öffentliche große Kommunikationsakte des amerikanischen Präsidenten, werden dann über drei Ecken da irgendwie eingewoben. Und man liegt siebenmal falsch ab.
Ja, und dass das wirklich von den Bessermenschen kommt, von den ganzen Linkssiberalen, ist ja vielleicht dann doch sehr logisch, weil die natürlich immer mit ihrem Moralismus glauben, dass sie die absolut Guten sind. Und deswegen kann, wenn sie sagen, wir liefern, wir befreien Leoparden, wir schicken unsere Leos, dann kann das nur gut sein, weil sie ja die Guten sind. Wenn das andere machen würden, dann ist das vielleicht Pragmatismus oder so. Aber das ist diese Sache, die Basel und Brockmann so schön beschrieben hat. Wenn zwei dasselbe tun, dann ist es doch nicht das gleiche. In dieser Logik. Und hier ist man dann moralisch ganz hochstehend, wenn man Leo-Emojis oder so was postet. Oder auch, wenn wir über journalistische Distanz sprechen. Kathrin Eigendorf, Journalistin des Jahres. Journalistin des Jahres, genau. Mit Paul Ronzheimer wollen wir noch nicht vergessen.
Vier Euro Ukraine-Berichterstattung.
Schreibt dann auch an Twitter, die guten Nachrichten aus Berlin kommen zu einem guten Zeitpunkt. Heute ist Zelenskis Geburtstag. Der ukrainische Präsident wird 45 Jahre alt. Da muss ich auch sagen, warum muss so ein Tweet sein? Kann sie nicht über etwas informieren, was sie da herausgefunden hat oder sonst was? Aber dass man jetzt auch nochmal in dieser Weise eine Nähe herstellt. Ja gut, dann gibt es ja keine journalistische Distanz mehr.
Ja, es ist, man ist während Corona, hat man die Grenze zum Aktivismus verwischt. Was ich nicht so schlimm finde, aber es ist ja deren Logik immer gewesen, dass es da eine mega Grenze gibt. Man will ja bloß nicht aktivistisch sein, so als gäbe es einen Journalismus, nur dann in korrekter Form, wenn der Journalist, der dann zu Themen arbeitet, sagt, aber ich habe mit dem Thema nichts zu tun, was ich absurd finde. Und während Corona, als es um Leben und Tod ging und man sich für das Leben entschieden hat, sind alle zu Aktivisten geworden. Und jetzt haben sie es einfach beibehalten. Es geht ja wieder um Leben und Tod und man will auf der Seite des Lebens sein. Welcher große Fehler da drin steckt, hören wir nachher. Es ging ja so ein Clip rum des Bundesheeres. Die sind ja so ein bisschen neutraler, weil sie nicht mehr Landtagmitglied sind und so. Die haben also so mal so öffentliche Analysen gemacht, die ein Militär gemacht hat. Also es ist nicht ein Meinungsbekundungsvideo, weil man irgendwas im Fernsehen sah, sondern das sind Leute vom Fach. Da gucken wir nachher mal rein.
Ja, also noch eine Sache. Ich habe mich ja während meines Studiums und dann auch während meiner Promotionsphase, die ich ja abgebrochen habe, mit Ernst Jünger beschäftigt. Und ich fand es doch ganz interessant, dass man dann dort schon, weil ich mich ja in Germanistenkreisen bewegte, sehr stark so eine, sagen wir es ruhig, Voke-Blickweise auf die Dinge hatte. Und dann musste man auch immer wortreich erst mal selbst erklären, warum man sich mit Ernst Jünger beschäftigt. Und ja, ich weiß schon, dass mit dem Krieg und die Materialschlacht und alles. Und diese Leute habe ich aber bisweilen bei Twitter wiedergefunden. Die sind jetzt, du kannst dir denken, auf welcher Position, die sind nämlich auch bei den Leo Emojis angekommen. Und da würde ich nochmal sagen, lese doch ruhig mal Stahlgewitter und seh da zum Beispiel, ja, es gibt so eine heroische Verehrung von Männlichkeit, von dem Einzelnen. Aber es wird hier schon deutlich gezeigt, der Einzelne verliert durch die Materialschlacht seine Souveränität. Vor allem aber zeichnet dieses Werk und zeichnet sich alle Erste-Welt-Kriegsschriften von Jünger darin aus, dass sie den Feind nicht diskriminieren. In Frankreich hat man deshalb viel früher Ernst Jünger geehrt als in Deutschland. Man hat nämlich in Frankreich gesagt, das ist eine sehr gute Schilderung dieses Krieges. Das ist existenziell wahr in gewisser Weise. Aber es geht nicht darum, darüber zu spotten. Ernst Jünger hätte niemals irgendwie in die Hände geklatscht, weil da Leos geliefert werden oder sonst etwas. Sowas hätte es da nicht gegeben. Insofern dann nochmal ganz klar den Lektüre-Tipp. Ernst Jünger macht einen vielleicht nicht zum Pazifisten. Aber Ernst Jünger hat schon einen Anstand bewiesen, den man momentan leider nicht sehen kann. Und das finde ich doch sehr bedenklich, dass wir in diesen Diskurs hereinschlittern. Bevor wir zu den Panzern jetzt nochmal im Speziellen kommen, will ich aber noch auf eine andere Entgleisung eingehen, die nicht von den Grünen ist, sondern von Friedrich Merz, der ja dauerhaft liefert.
Wir machen eine kleine Zäsur, bevor wir wieder zurückkommen und sagen für alle, die zu faul sind, Ernst Jünger zu lesen. Es gibt ja auch noch 25 Jahre weiter nach vorne gerückt. Im Westen nichts Neues zu sehen. Es wird ja gerade wieder plakatiert auch wegen der Oscar-Nominierung und so weiter. Aber wir wollen den ersten Clip heute Friedrich Merz schenken.
Die Silvesternacht haben wir hier gar nicht besprochen im Podcast.
Weil sie ja auch nicht so stattfand, wie es wird ja alles schon wieder revidiert.
Genau, es wird alles schon wieder revidiert. Aber wir kennen diese Pascha-Äußerung von Merz, die CDU in besonderem Maß hat sich ja überboten mit rechten Tönen, zum Teil rassistischen Äußerungen. Es war für mich auch doch nochmal erschreckend zu sehen, wie schnell das dann hochkochte. Also von einem Punkt, dass man sagte, das geht aber so nicht, bis hin dann, jetzt führen wir aber nochmal ganz grundsätzlich eine Einwanderungs-Migrations-Debatte und wie man dann rassistische Stereotypen aufgegriffen hat. Ich will dazu jetzt nichts vorspielen. Wir haben das alles erlebt.
Lass mich trotzdem eine Frage stellen, bevor wir jetzt Merz zu einem Thema hören, wo es auch kritisch ist, dass es im Bundestag passiert, aber im Vorfeld hatten wir ja häufiger Merz in Fernsichtstudios. Also jetzt bei BildTV sagt irgendwie Quatsch, dabei Lanz mit seinen Paschas und so weiter. Und es ist ja immer die Frage, ist das jetzt einfach so passiert? Hat er sich in Rage geredet? War das so ein Skript von 2002, das in seinem Kopf noch ablief, weil er ja 20 Jahre ausgeblendet hat und wir merken halt, das passt nicht, aber für ihn ist das immer noch so, wird halt Politik gemacht. Oder ist es kalkuliert im Sinne von, dass er wirklich glaubt, er generiert damit Wählerstimmen? Und ich kann es für mich gar nicht entscheiden. Entweder hat er irgendwelche Landestin-Umfragen gemacht in seinem Konrad-Adenauer-Haus und weiß, ich verspreche mir davon was. Oder es ist halt wirklich einfach ein Fehler, weil die Art und Weise, wie er dann auf Twitter durchgenudelt wird, ist ja schon erstaunlich. Also die Leute sind ja doch irgendwie dann, man generalisiert ja über den konkreten Spruch hinaus und sagt, das ist nicht ein Mann unserer Zeit und der eignet sich nicht und davon auch nicht reden.
Das ist nicht so, wenn du nur Regionalzeitungen aufschlägst und darüber berichtet wird, dann steht da im letzten Absatz des Artikels, es gab aber auch Kritik an Friedrich Merz, Äußerungen und dann wird irgendjemand zitiert.
Also es könnte durchaus kein Kühl sein irgendwie.
Durchaus und wenn wir sehen, dass es ja doch solche Radikalisierungsprozesse gibt, nehmen wir Julian Reichelt TV oder so, das ist jetzt auch nicht übermäßig erfolgreich ist, aber es gibt schon eine Bevölkerung, wo das ankommt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das hier im Podcast mal Zettaps war, vor zwei Monaten, dass ich bei Twitter sah, dass Julian Reichelt so ein Porträt macht über Bäcker, wie schlecht es denen jetzt gerade geht. Boris Bäcker? Nein, über Bäcker, also wie schlecht Bäcker ist während der Inflation gerade. Also die, die dir die Brötchen backen.
Ach so, das Backgewerbe.
Und dann ist er da zu so einem Bäckermeister und so was. Und das wird natürlich als so eine soziale Blickweise verkauft, ist aber natürlich eigentlich wieder Agenda für seine Sache. Und dann dachte ich, gut, wer fällt darauf rein? Und ich steige an dem Abend ins Taxi und sage, und haben sie auch schwer unter der Inflation zu sein? Ja, ja, aber ich habe gerade eben so einen interessanten Fernsehbericht gesehen. Sie sagten doch gar nicht Julian Reicheltief, sondern es war Fernsehen und erzählte davon. Insofern glaube ich schon, dass da ein Publikum für da ist. Ich will nur eine Anmerkung noch gerne aber zu dieser Silvesterdebatte machen. Und zwar gab es ja dann sehr bald diese Diskussion, ja, waren das wirklich Deutsche? Die haben zwar einen deutschen Pass, aber jetzt wollen wir, das fingen ja dann die Rechten an, jetzt hätten wir gern mal die Vornamen. Also wo man dann sagen wollte, naja, wenn die nicht Stefan und Wolfgang heißen, dann sind das ja vielleicht keine richtigen Deutschen. Und das ist natürlich rassistisch, das ist für uns völlig klar. Ich will nur darauf hinweisen, vielleicht sollten wir generell, und da spreche ich vor allem die Leute von links an, mal aufhören, jeden Konflikt zu kulturalisieren. Denn der Dezember auf Twitter sah so aus, dass reichweitenstarke Comedians und Klimaaktivisten, und weiß ich nicht was, getwittert haben, Freiheit ist, wenn Uwe und Helga an Sylvester bollern können. Das heißt, es wurden die ganze Zeit so Takes gemacht, die dummen Deutschen bollern. Und die Kartoffeln haben die ganze Zeit diese Nahrung waren. Ich habe mit einem Bekannten aus England gesprochen, und er hat mir gesagt, wieso macht ihr da so ein komisches Ding, bei uns wird ja auch gebollert, es wird doch fast überall gebollert. Bei uns kann man sogar die Böller das ganze Jahr über kaufen. Also wenn man jetzt so tut, als sei das eine biodeutsche Irrsinnstradition zu bollern, dann ist man da schon schief gewickelt. Und an Sylvester in Deutschland bollern auch nicht nur Leute, die Uwe und Helga heißen. Also wir müssen da wirklich mal aufhören. Man kann ja eine Debatte darüber führen, soll es weiter Böller geben? Was sollte man vielleicht einschränken in Innenstädten? Gibt es ja auch schon, dass es auf manchen Plätzen nicht möglich ist. All diese Debatten kann man führen. Nur wenn ich anfange, diese Debatte, die eigentlich sehr funktional zu führen ist, wenn ich anfange, diese zu kulturalisieren, dann ist ja klar, dass die von rechts auch dann irgendwann sagen, ja, dann fangen wir jetzt auch mal mit Vornamen an. Dann wollen wir jetzt auch mal wissen, ob das wirklich der Uwe war oder der Attila.
Ich bin da eh schwer beeindruckt, immer noch vor ewig lange. Ich war noch Student, war Rainer Schützeichel, ein von mir wirklich sehr geschätzter Soziologe, der eine Dissertation zum Thema Sinnbegriff bei Luhmann, also tiefer kann man gar nicht einsteigen in die Theorie, in das Thema überhaupt und so und sich eine Prüfungssituation aussetzen, die eigentlich, wahrscheinlich haben das Buch drei Leute gelesen und niemand hat es verstanden, außer der Autor selbst oder so. Und er meinte damals, als er Vertretungsweise Professor war in Bielefeld, jetzt ist er mittlerweile ein richtiger Professor für Soziologie, zum Glück, hat er uns so, ja, Funktionale Differenzierung, wir wissen alle Bescheid, aber kann die abgelöst werden? Und es gibt ja in der Systemtheorie so dieses Jahr, man hat so die stratifizierte und segmentierte Gesellschaft und dann kommen halt die Funktionale Differenzierung und dann hat Luhmann sein ganzes Werk 40 Bücher darüber geschrieben, wie raffiniert die Realität einfach ist und so. Und dann meinte Rainer Schütze als Fragestellung, könnte die abgelöst werden? Was wäre denn so die nächste Differenzierungsform? Und meinte dann, ja, vielleicht die ethnische. Und wir alle so, hey, die ethnische, da sind wir doch voll wieder auf so einem Themenlevel.
Back to blood.
Und so weiter, ja genau, sowas irgendwie. Also, man ging ja doch davon aus, dass die Gesellschaft, wenn sie sich weiter differenziert, irgendwie raffinierter differenziert wird und nicht wieder zurückfällt. Dann habe ich aber 15 Jahre später selber einen Redaktionsschluss über diese norwegischen Literaturwissenschaftler geschrieben, die in Harvard einfach die Idee vorstellen, dass wir halt jetzt nach der Schrift wieder zurückfallen in so einer Art Mittelalter, wo wir einfach total spontan, also wo einfach dieser Satz von dir, für die ist immer Tag eins, einfach für alle gilt. Wir haben kein historisches Verständnis mehr, weil wir haben auch keine Bilderarchive mehr. Bilder sind nur noch so eine Kommunikation, die man so dahinsendet. Fotos haben gar keine Bedeutung mehr. Wir halten was fest, wir erinnern uns an, sondern das ist halt so eine kleine spontane Kommunikation, weil wir haben ja alle Fotos immer dabei und wir quatschen uns auch einfach so an. Wir machen gar keine Planung mehr, sondern wenn wir jetzt irgendwo losziehen wollen, fragen wir halt so rum in der Facebook-Gruppe, wer kommt denn mit? Aber man verabredet sich gar nicht für übermorgen oder so, weil man weiß ja noch nicht, was übermorgen ist. Und ja, es droht jetzt wirklich wahr zu werden, dass wir so ganz banale Kommunikationsformen wieder nach ganz oben rücken in der Gesellschaft. Und dass plötzlich so eine ethnische oder wie du es eben genannt hast, so eine kulturelle Differenzierung, also dass wir alle den Fehler wie Friedrich Merz machen und Realität gar nicht mehr wahrnehmen, sondern nur noch auf so einer semantischen, gefühligen Ebene. Und da fällt ja auch dieses Landstatement, das wollte er noch gar nicht, also klar, er hat diesen Paschersatz gemacht, aber er hat ja diesen Paschersatz eingeleitet mit, reden sie mal mit einer Grundschullehrerin, was die ihnen sagt. Und ich rede sehr viel mit Grundschullehrerinnen und ich weiß, in einer Grundschule wie in Frankfurt hast du 80% Migrationshintergrund. In diesem Alltag ist es total egal, ob jetzt jemand einen Migrationshintergrund hat oder nicht, weil das schon völlig ausgeblört ist, es spielt keine Rolle mehr. Alle haben Migrationshintergrund.
Friedrich Neer zieht die Klasse vor sich, 30 Schüler und zwei davon haben Migrationshintergrund.
Genau, das ist so sein Ding. Da gibt es halt so drei Assis, die Migrationshintergrund haben und so.
Das ist eine, ja, wir haben das in Anführungszeichen natürlich gesetzt. Ja, kann man nicht sehen. Aber das ist genau das. Und dieses Gefühl aber, ja, da gibt es irgendwie so zwei, drei Ausreißer, die müssen wir uns mal kümmern. Das ist glaube ich schon ein...
Ja, aber diese Art der Lüge, die da drin steckt, die haben wir eben alle.
Und die kann man aber noch gut adressieren.
Genau, Friedrich Merz redet nicht mit Grundschullehrerinnen, sagt aber im Fernsehen einfach, reden sie mal mit denen, so als hätte er es getan. So wie wir auch sehr häufig auf Twitter dieses, ich bin nicht wirklich betroffen, ich hab auch nie mit dem Betroffenen geredet, aber ich möchte trotzdem Anwalt in der Sache sein. So, und dann denkt man sich irgendein Problem aus, argumentiert dann so in kreuzverschiedene Richtungen, weiß gar nicht, habe ich eigentlich noch Kontakt zu denen, für die ich die Anwaltschaft übernehme und so. Man stellt das fest, ne, irgendwie nicht. Also das ist einfach nur noch ausgedachte, semantische Spielerei, die auf Twitter so im Safe Space des eigenen Schreibtisches, ja, man ist ja nicht draußen auf der Straße, man twittert ja so in deinen Bildschirm hinein, so und das ist alles total verquer, aber sehr viel Kommunikation, die so stattfindet gerade und die so politisch ist und eben so einen kulturellen, ethnischen Einschlag, wie auch immer, erhält, obliegt demselben operationalen Fehler wie Friedrich Merz. Sie hat einfach keine Anbindung mehr an Realität. Es gibt einfach kein Substrat mehr, sozusagen. So eine materielle Anbindung an irgendwas. Das ist alles nur noch geredet. Bei den Panzern, bei der Silvester-Thematisierung usw. kommt dann einfach eine Woche später, nachdem dann Giffey schon ihr Migrationsgipfel gemacht hat, weil sie ja im Wahlkampf ist usw. stellt sich heraus, gab gar kein Problem. Ich würde dann einfach mal nachgehen als Journalist und fragen, was haben die denn dann besprochen bei dieser Konferenz, wenn sie später rausstellt, es gab da gar kein Problem. 40% der Leute, die da rumgeböllert haben, haben ja ein Migrationshintergrund, aber in Neukölln haben eigentlich 60% Migrationshintergrund. Eigentlich müssten ja, ist ja komisch, da haben ja eigentlich mehr Deutsche verhältnismäßig rumgeböllert und Sachbeschädigungen usw. als jetzt Migrationshintergrund. Es fällt so aus dem Rahmen und es ist so erstaunlich, wie die Journalisten an, auch dem nicht nachgehen, obwohl so viele Fragen einfach von alleine entstehen.
Man kann jetzt ja nicht mal auf eigene Faust nach Kiew fahren oder nach Teheran oder so.
Da hat man es ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber da könnte man ja wirklich mal hingehen. Und zwar nicht nur, wenn die Pressekonferenz mit dem Spitzenpolitiker stattfindet, sondern generell könnte man dort sein. Und da würden bestimmt auch viele andere interessante Geschichten abfallen. Aber das ist ja so was, dass der Lokaljournalismus von denen, die den Meinungsjournalismus betreiben, völlig ignoriert wird. Und dann ist das alles so auf der Basis des Hörensagens. Nun hat Friedrich Merz natürlich auch die Gelegenheit ergriffen, in diesen Fail-State Neukölln zu gehen, um dort Wahlkampf zu machen. Denn wir wissen, da wird hier wieder gewählt. Und er dachte, das ist doch jetzt eine tolle Idee, wenn er sich als einer zeigt, der nah bei den Leuten ist. Und er tut das an dem Tag, also vergangenen Freitag, als man zuvor im Bundestag der Befreiung von Auschwitz gedacht. Und wir hören uns jetzt diesen Auftritt, also der Auftritt an sich dauert 40 Minuten. Aber wir hören uns diesen gesamten Part an, um den es geht, der auch einen kleinen Skandal ausgelöst haben. Zuschauer haben dort empört den Saal verlassen. Es gab Berichte darüber. Aber wir wollen es wirklich ganz langsam angehen. Und ich will Friedrich Merz in gewisser Weise entschuldigen. Also was er da macht, nicht in dem Sinne, also das, was er da sagt, hat er sicherlich nicht so gemeint. Aber wie er es gemeint hat, ist auch hochproblematisch. Das will ich hier aufzeigen. Und wir hören jetzt uns erstmal an, wie das beginnt.
Heute am 27. Januar ist ein Gedenktag. Wir haben heute Morgen im Deutschen Bundestag gedacht an den Tag vor 78 Jahren, als von der russischen Armee das Konzentrationslager Auschwitz befreit wurde. Diesen Tag, den 27. Januar hat Bundespräsident Herzog im Jahr 1996 als einen Gedenktag bestimmt, an dem wir jedes Jahr im Deutschen Bundestag mit einer Gedenkstunde an dieses Ereignis erinnern.
Wir sind hier bei einem Wahlkampfauftritt, aber er versucht diese Gedenktagsatmosphäre mit dort zu diesem Auftritt zu bringen. Da kann man sich schon fragen, ob das an sich eine gute Idee ist. Hätte man das einfach nur mit diesen drei Dürrenzeilen bewenden lassen können? Es gab da diesen Gedenktag, jetzt bin ich hier bei Ihnen, jetzt sprechen wir über Tagespolitik.
Wo war er da genau?
Er war dort bei der CDU Neukölln, in so einer Mehrzweckhalle wird das gewesen sein. Und jetzt erzählt er dann, was er dort gehört hat.
Wenn Sie das heute Abend in den Nachrichten sehen, dann werden Sie vielleicht nachvollziehen, dass das heute Morgen ein außerordentlich bewegender Augenblick war. Wo wir vor einer Frau, die als kleines Kind von ihren Eltern an holländische Gasteltern abgegeben wurde, erfahren haben, wie ihr Leben verlaufen ist. Wo sie dann mit sechs Jahren erfahren hat, dass sie gar nicht das Kind dieser holländischen Eltern war, sondern von ihren Eltern, kurz bevor sie in das Konzentrationslager Ravensbrück kamen, abgegeben worden sind an diese Gasteltern.
Nach diesem Bericht kommt jetzt eine Schlussfolgerung. Das war dann Stein des Anstoßes. Wir hören genau, was er sagt.
Dann haben wir bewegende Worte gehört über ihr Leben. Und darüber, wie sie dann ja auch Frieden gemacht hat mit diesen Eltern, mit dieser Erkenntnis, mit Selbsthilfegruppen in den Niederlanden, die dasselbe Schicksal hatten. Und wenn sie dann da sitzen im Deutschen Bundestag und so etwas hören, so geht es mir jedenfalls, dann ist man ein Stück stolz auf die Geschichte dieses Landes.
Dieses Landes.
Ja, ganz genau. Man kann sich natürlich kaum dümmer ausdrücken. Was er natürlich hier nicht sagen will, ist, dass er stolz auf die Geschichte des Holocaust ist. Das ist nicht das, was dieses Land meint, sondern mit dieses Land meint er selbstverständlich das Land nach 45.
Es wurde erst 49 gegründet, dieses Land.
Ja, 49 im Prinzip dann sogar. Das heißt, dieses Land meinte aber, die Zuschauer haben es folgendermaßen verstanden.
Und was wir auch in großer Gemeinsamkeit und meistens, nicht immer, aber meistens, in großer Übereinstimmung der demokratischen Parteien in Deutschland gemeinsam erreicht haben. Und wenn Sie der Meinung sind, dass das rassistischer Scheiß ist, was ich hier gerade sage, meine Damen und Herren, dann haben wir genau an der Stelle erkannt, welches Problem wir bei einer ganz, ganz kleinen Minderheit in diesem Land immer noch haben.
Missverständliche Kommunikation. Er meint jetzt, dass sein irgendwelche Leute, die antisemitisch sind oder ich weiß überhaupt gar nicht, worauf er sich jetzt da bezieht mit dieser kleinen Minderheit, die damit ein Problem hat. Also dieses Publikum dort, zwei Dutzend verlassen ja dann auch den Saal, empört sich darüber, dass er diese Conclusio zieht, weil er mal wieder rhetorisch nicht in der Lage war, das eine vom anderen abzusetzen. Das ist ja was, was wir schon häufig bei Merz auch gesehen haben. Es gibt Kalkül, aber es gibt zum Teil auch Trotteligkeit in der Formulierung, dass man denkt, das kann doch alles gar nicht sein, dass man das in einer Rede so sagt. Und dann auch, wenn die Leute sich empören, auch nicht in der Lage ist, nachzufragen, da er ja fehlerfrei ist wie ein Papst, kann er natürlich sich auch gar nicht korrigieren. Es geht dann weiter.
Dann ist es gut, wenn solche Leute diesen Zahl hier heute Abend auch verlassen. Dann ist es gut, dass sie gehen.
Diskussion zu Ende. Es wird noch ein bisschen applaudiert. Und Merz bleibt bei seiner Rede, macht dann folgendermaßen weiter. Also wir haben jetzt gehört, er kommt von dieser Gedenkstunde, er berichtet davon, sagt, er sei stolz auf dieses Land, stolz wohl darauf, dass jetzt gedacht wird der Befreiung von Auschwitz. Und er setzt dann die Erzählung vor.
Denn ich möchte mit dem betonen, was ich hier sage, dass wir uns heute hier sehen, dass wir in Berlin sind, als deutscher Bundestag, dass wir die deutsche Einheit erreicht haben, dass wir die Teilung Berlins überwunden haben, dass wir die Teilung Europas überwunden haben. Das ist doch ein sensationeller Erfolg deutscher Politik, auch deutscher Friedenspolitik, dass wir heute sagen können, wir leben in einem der freiheitlichsten und schönsten Länder der Welt. Und das sind politische Entscheidungen gewesen, die das ermöglicht haben.
Also hier steigert er sich schon wieder rein in so eine Situation, die auf seinem Zettel nicht steht, weil er irgendwas gesehen hat im Publikum. Wahrscheinlich hat er im Nachhinein dann auch die Aufklärung bekommen und meinte, so haben die das gedacht. Blöd, dann sind ja genau die rausgegangen, die meiner Meinung sind sozusagen. Aber das ist ja wirklich...
Was ich aber hier auch schwierig finde, ist, er nimmt diesen Gedenktag. Und ich kann natürlich sagen, man kann froh sein darüber, dass es eine solche Form des Gedenkens in Deutschland gibt. Und gerade auch, wir haben ja im letzten Jahr über diesen Gedenktag, du hattest Clips dabei, ausführlich berichtet. Es ist sehr, sehr gut, wie das auch gemacht wird, was dort erzählt wird, welche Geschichten dort präsent sind. Aber was er natürlich hier tut, ist, dass er eigentlich dieses Gedenken an Auschwitz als Fundament nimmt für seinen Nationalstolz. Dass er sagt, das leite ich jetzt davon ab. Wir haben hier unsere Stunde Null gehabt und jetzt leite ich davon meine nationale Politik ab. Und das finde ich einen unsäglichen Missbrauch dieser Sache. Statt das einfach mal so stehen zu lassen, zu sagen, das habe ich heute gehört, aber jetzt reden wir darüber, sondern er versucht, diese Erfolgssatzung zu machen. Und wenn ich das richtig im Video gedeutet habe, ist das auch keine spontane Reaktion jetzt mit Berlin und allem, sondern dass er jetzt tatsächlich so weitergeht. Also es ist so diese, die neue Nationalerstellung, die dann mit diesem Land beginnt. Auf das können wir stolz sein. Und wir sind so reflektiert, dass wir auch sogar diesen Gedenktag ja noch mit inkorporieren können in unseren Nationalstolz. Und das ist ja nicht von mir jetzt hier zusammengeschnitten, sondern es geht dann auch gleich so weiter.
Und das war doch gar nicht mal nur die Union allein. Das war Monate, zum Teil jahrelanges Ringen. Und in dieser Stadt ist mal ein Mann wie Willy Brandt regierender Bürgermeister gewesen. Was würde der denn heute zu den Zuständen sagen, wenn er noch leben würde? Wie würde der sich denn äußern? Der würde doch etwas anderes sagen als Frau Giffey heute zu dieser Veranstaltung hier gesagt hat.
Und dann wird am Ende, wenn man sich diese Rede ansieht, das Gedenken an die Befreiung von Auschwitz genommen, um ein nationales Narrativ zu stricken, das am Ende dazu führt. Und deswegen sollen die mit dem nichtdeutschen Vornamen sich hier in Neukölln mal zusammenreißen. Und das ist so furchtbar. Da merkt man, der hat dann doch von dieser Gedenkstuhe nicht so viel kapiert.
Ja, insbesondere dieser Verweis auf Willy Brandt. Wir hatten ja in Bayern diesen Wahlkampf, dass die Alternative für Deutschland plötzlich mit Strauß plakatierte und die CSU gar nichts dagegen machen konnte, dass man jetzt ihn quasi entführt. Aber genauso wenig, wie man der AfD zugestehen kann, dass man sich in dem voller Antlitz, aber auch den Erinnerungen und dem Ansehen einer längst gestorbenen Person bedient, wäre das auch für die CSU, finde ich, unmöglich, wenn sie jetzt plötzlich damit kommt, an Strauß anzuknüpfen. Dass Merz hier sogar über Parteigrenzen hinweg plötzlich meint, er spricht jetzt einfach mal im Sinne von Willy Brandt, finde ich, das geht einfach nicht. Das ist so ein ganz großer Fehler.
Übrigens, auch in Neukölln hat das Tradition, ich habe gerade diese grandiose Dokumentation gesehen, Goldhammer auf dem Max-O-Füß-Festival über Marseille Goldhammer, der von den beiden Regisseuren porträtiert wird. Und zwar bricht er auf mit 15 Jahren, geht nach Berlin, wird Schauspieler, arbeitet dann als schwuler Escort, konvertiert zum Judentum, wird dann Israeli, nimmt sich dann einen chinesischen Sugar Daddy, um dann 2020 in die AfD einzutreten und für Neukölln der Spitzenkandidat zu sein. Nur mal kurzumrissen diesen Lebenslauf. Und all das ist in diesem Film drin, was natürlich auch die Regisseure vor Herausforderungen gestellt hat, wenn plötzlich der Film ein anderer wird, wenn der Protagonist plötzlich entschließt bei der AfD mit seinem Mann. Und der ist da in diesem Film zu sehen und hält dann eine Rede vor seinesgleichen dort bei der AfD und sagt, wenn ich es recht erinnere, Franz Josef Strauß, Willy Brandt und Atta Türk würden die AfD wählen. Also man versucht ja immer so diesen Gegner, also den eigentlich nicht zur Partei gehörenden, mit zu inkludieren, um natürlich damit eine Wählerschicht, die ja, wir liefern das doch damals auch gut, dann bist du doch hier richtig aufgehoben. Also versucht das in dieser Weise starkzumachen.
Man spricht nicht für andere, insbesondere nicht solche Leute. Das ist doch völlig Banane. Was macht denn der Merz da? Gut, also damit haben wir eine Kulisse gelegt. Der Holocaust.
Wir wollen aber ganz kurz unterbrechen und noch auf den Salon hinweisen. Wir hatten es schon angekündigt im letzten Salon oder angedroht. Ich war mir nicht sicher, ob du zustimmen wirst, aber du hast dich ergeben. Wir werden tatsächlich im nächsten Salon über das Buch von Prinz Harry sprechen. Das soll aber jetzt nicht Leute heute präsent RTL-exklusiv werden, nicht nur Klatsch und Tratsch, sondern wir wollen versuchen, dieses Buch zu lesen mit der Brille des Zeitgeistes, mit dem, was sind die Neuen Zwanziger für ein Jahrzehnt und was finden wir dazu in diesem Buch. Ich glaube, dass das sehr, sehr erhellend sein wird. Ich glaube, manches wird auch lustig sein.
Das habe ich auch gehört.
Es gibt ja schon ein paar Passagen, und man denkt, du lieber Gott. Aber wir werden darüber sprechen im Salon, das würde ich aber jetzt mal so sagen. Manche lesen ja gerne das Buch vorab, wenn wir es dann im Salon besprechen. Wartet vielleicht doch mal ab, bis wir im Salon drüber gesprochen haben. Ich würde jetzt erst mal so den Tipp geben, es könnte nicht die lohnendste Lektüre der Welt sein, wenn man es nicht unter diesem Blickpunkt sich anseht.
Genau, wir lesen es nicht einfach nur, weil Harry es geschrieben hat. Hinzu kommt, vielleicht als kleiner Pluspunkt, der Autor soll ja sehr gut sein, dieser Ghostwriter, der wird ja auch überall erwähnt. In der Hinsicht erwarte ich, also ich werde es hören, Harry liest ja selbst, ich erwarte schon einen gewissen Unterhaltungsaspekt, auch was Konzeption des Buches angeht. Aber wie gesagt, das Buch ist sozusagen Kulisse für eine Diskussion über, ist ja auch viel Medienkritik drin und so weiter. Und für mich schwingt er immer noch im Hintergrund. Und ich will nochmal ausdrücklich sagen, es war deine Entscheidung, es vorzuschlagen, ich habe mich nur drangehangen. Wir lesen also Harry. Aber ich hatte bei den Sozialtheoristen vor ewig langer Zeit mal so ein Text mit der Frage, was kann der König, bezogen auf die Königin in England, ob man wirklich immer dabei bleiben kann zu sagen, sie hat ja eigentlich keine Macht. Sie wird halt nur von 8 Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt gesehen. Aber sie hat ja eigentlich keine wirkliche Macht. Während wir jetzt im Influencer-Zeitalter sind, wo eh nur noch bestimmt was semantisch bei Twitter passiert und so, also für voll genommen wird und Realität keine Rolle spielt, ist das nicht eigentlich die ultimative Macht, wenn jemand so viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommt. Und Stefan Niggermeier hat ja zumindest für das deutschsprachige Publikum schon mal so ein bisschen mitreflektiert, wie viel Medienkritik ist denn da drin und so. Und unter dieser Maßkappe gucken wir uns nochmal diese sehr geschätzte Unterscheidung Semantik und Sozialstruktur an, inwieweit das Buch etwas ist.
Aber wir werden bestimmt nicht, wie das in manchen Kreisen üblich ist, jetzt die große Opfergeschichte nochmal duplizieren, wie Harry und Meghan sich da gebastelt haben. Das können die ja bei Oprah Winfrey aushandeln.
Wir lesen das ganz problemzentriert, nehmen aber so manches Thema dann gerne auf.
Wir greifen das gerne auf. Ich glaube, es wird eine lustige Diskussion.
Aber mein Vorschlag ist, wir haben ja schon mal zwei Bücher gelesen. Ich werde nämlich auch Corrie Dr. Roff's neues Buch über die Kulturindustrie mitbringen. Es handelt also, wir haben ja schon über Ticketmaster und so weiter gesprochen. Und da hatten wir ja so eine Masterclass, oder wie er das genannt hat, von dieser Union, die er da gegründet hat, wo er noch mal am Ende die Pointe setzte. Es betrifft ja nicht nur die Tickets, sondern diese Art der Konzentrierung und Monopolisierung haben wir ja im ganzen Kulturbereich. Und jetzt liegt plötzlich so ein Buch mal wieder von ihm vor, wahrscheinlich das 57. Buch und so, was er in den letzten drei Monaten geschrieben hat. Und das können wir aber auch noch zusammen lesen.
Ja, soll ich mir das mal noch anschaffen?
Ja, weil ich glaube, das lohnt sich, das im Diskurs zu klären, was da drin steht.
Prima.
Und dann haben wir sozusagen zwei Bücher.
Und ich habe auch noch Bücher, aber dazu kommen wir dann am Ende noch. Im vergangenen Teaser wollen wir noch sagen, sind die Termine angekündigt für die Live-Shows in Frankfurt? Die ersten beiden dürften völlig weg sein, aber die dritte, vierte, da sind vielleicht noch Plätze da. Ich habe jetzt gar nicht nachgeschaut, möglicherweise aber auch nicht mehr sehr viel. Dann ist also quasi das Jahr ausverkauft. Und noch der Hinweis, wir hatten das vor Weihnachten mal gesagt, man kann den Salon auch verschenken. Das war nicht nur eine Weihnachtsaktion, wie ich dachte, sondern das geht nach wie vor. Also das heißt, man kann auch zu anderen festen Valentinstag, das sind doch noch Geschenke, zum Beispiel kann man... Was auch immer, kann man den Salon verschenken. Gut, dann machen wir weiter im Programm.
Yes, also wir haben mit Merz die Kulisse so ein bisschen gelegt. Alles, was wir, insbesondere in Deutschland, aber auch weltweit zum Thema Krieg, Verderben, Tod, Elend sagen, läuft unter der Kulisse. Es ist geschehen und es kann wieder geschehen. Also die Maßstäbe wollen wir hier mal klar benennen. Und unter der Hinsicht, auch wenn jetzt manche in Deutschland immer wieder abwinken, ach, diese Atomwaffen, der Putin, das ist ja alles nur und so. Ich will mal nur kurz sozusagen illustrieren, wie der Deutschlandfunk in so einem Politikpodcast, es ist im Grunde der Anspruch, das Flurgespräch nochmal für die Hörer zur Verfügung zu stellen. Also wo so ein bisschen Salopper gesprochen wird. Und man diskutiert ja darüber, ob jetzt die Drohungen mit Atomwaffen von Putin ernst zu nehmen sind oder nicht. Sie sind ja recht häufig und bislang ist aber noch keine Atombombe geflogen. Und das nochmal gekoppelt mit so einer Frage, kann man Putin überhaupt irgendetwas abnehmen? Und wenn nicht, wenn alles nur Lüge und Propaganda ist, woran liegt denn das eigentlich? Und da fand ich das hier innerhalb von einer Minute als zu scharfen Kontrast. Also es ist ja wirklich absurd.
Man darf ja glaube ich auch nicht vergessen, dass man ja regelrecht die Uhr danach stellen kann. Also mindestens einmal alle 14 Tage kommt zu einer Erinnerung, eine Drohung mit den Atomwaffen. Und das ist natürlich gerade an das ausländische Publikum auch sehr, sehr in Richtung Deutschland gerichtet, weil man eben da weiß, dass die Angst vor Atom jeglicher Art einfach riesengroß ist. Und ich will das ja auch nicht gering schätzen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das keine große Gefahr wäre. Aber es wird gar nichts gelöst und es hilft uns überhaupt nicht, uns davon ins Boxhorn jagen zu lassen.
Aber wie kalkulierbar ist Putin wirklich?
Gar nicht. Das haben wir doch gesehen, dass er nicht kalkulierbar ist. Aber wir wissen es eben auch in der umgekehrten Weise nicht. Man muss überlegen, was gewinnt er? Was würde er gewinnen, wenn er tatsächlich Atomwaffen einsetzen würde? Er würde sofort wahrscheinlich die Unterstützung der Chinesen verlieren. Das war relativ deutlich.
Also ich würde es gerne mal strapazieren. In dem Moment, wo Putin sich entscheidet, ich setze jetzt Atomwaffen ein, weiß er, er wird diesen Tag wahrscheinlich nicht überleben. Und die Frage ist, kommt er in eine Situation, wo er es vielleicht trotzdem macht? Wir haben ja sehr viele Staatschefs in der Geschichte, die manchmal einem Schicksal entgegengehen, wo man weiß, hätte ich mich mal lieber selbst getötet. Gaddafi zum Beispiel.
Fidel Castro wollte, dass die Atombombe geworfen wird. Er hat gesagt, nur damit die Souveränität Kubers nicht angegriffen wird, kann man es machen. Hochschrift und Kennedy haben es dann nicht getan. Die haben sich auf eine andere Weise verständigt. Gerade wenn man sagt, da ist jemand nicht kalkulierbar. Das ist ja im Übrigen die Wiederholung des Deutschlandfunk-Interviews mit Katharina Balifon vor sieben Monaten, das wir hier hatten. Wo dann auch gefragt wurde, ist das nicht möglich? Der ist so irrational, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Wir überstrapazieren das nicht, wenn ich jetzt auch sage, Adolf Hitler hat sich in seinem Bunker getötet. Welche Möglichkeiten hätte er alle genutzt, wenn sie ihm zur Verfügung gestanden hätten?
Ganz richtig.
Das ist einfach die Frage, die im Raum steht.
Man kann auch nicht die ganze Zeit Putin mit Hitler vergleichen, wie die das tun. Aber wenn man dann sagt, dann müsste man das ja gerade recht, ich bin gegen diesen Vergleich. Aber diese Leute, die das laufend tun, die nicht mehr Putin, sondern Puttler bei Twitter schreiben, wenn die angesprochen werden auf die nukleare Eskalation, dann sagen die, ne, ne, ne, das ist ja Quatsch. Und ich sage, ja, aber ein Hitler hätte sehr wahrscheinlich nuklear eskaliert, wenn er es gekonnt hätte. Ich war auch erstaunt über Litauens Außenminister Gabrielius Landsbergis, der hat auch zu mehr Engagement aufgerufen und und und wurde dann auch aber zum Atomkrieg befragt. Und seine Antwort ist, er fürchtet keinen, wenn wir uns nicht darauf vorbereiten, dass Russland den Krieg verliert, dann meinen wir es nicht ernst damit, der Ukraine beim Sieg zu helfen. Das war seine Antwort. Und das ist aber keine Antwort.
Ne, das ist alles kreuz und quer. Und nur, bevor wir auf das Bundesheer zu sprechen kommen, zu illustrieren, wo dieser Krieg so alles stattfindet. Wir kriegen ja gleich weitreichende Angebote, welche Ebenen mit zu betrachten sind. Wir haben ja auch schon viele besprochen. Elon Musk spielt eine ganz maßgebliche Rolle im Ukrainekrieg.
Hier muss man ganz klar feststellen, dass vor allem durch den Einsatz des Starlings-Systems die Ukraine bis heute in der Lage ist, in einer Art und Weise zu kommunizieren, die es für die russische Seite sehr schwer macht, diese zu stören. Und dass der Einsatz dieser kleinen Einheiten, die im Sinne des Auftages denken, dazu geführt hat, dass viele der Offensiven sehr erfolgreich durchgeführt werden konnten.
Das mal ausgeklammert aus dieser Besprechung. Das finde ich super interessant, weil wir, also derzeit bestimmen ja irgendwie so zwei Themen, zumindest meine Bubbles. Das eine ist Jet-GPT, weil doch sehr viele jetzt mal so ein bisschen in die Zukunft gucken und jetzt wo Microsoft da auch mit Milliarden und Milliarden reingeht, obwohl es dem Silicon Valley gerade nicht allzu gut geht, da gesehen wird, ja, das ist so der Weg, in den wir gehen wollen. Wir haben ja eine Office Suite für die Büroarbeitsplätze. Da bauen wir jetzt mal Jet-GPT so richtig auf. Ja, sozusagen Arbeitsebene ein, was ich denke. Ja, also wenn man sozusagen ins Büro kommt und auf Zuruf dem Computer irgendwas befiehlt und der liefert dann wirklich die fertige E-Mail, die man dann nur noch mit seinem Signature irgendwie unterschreibt und abschickt, dann fragt man sich ja wirklich ja, wie lange braucht man dann eigentlich den Menschen, auch der den Befehl schickt. Also kann da nicht der Chef morgens einfach sozusagen alles an Jet-GPT direkt delegieren. Und Elon Musk ist der Kopf hinter OpenAI. Und bei Starlink eben auch. Elon Musk ist der Kopf hinter Starlink. Und Starlink ist die entscheidende Kommunikationsplattform, mit der die sich in der Ukraine mit Internet versorgen. Und zwar überall. Die brauchen da keine Handymasken, keine Kabel, kein gar nichts. Sondern die bauen sich so ein kleines Empfängerding für die Kommunikation mit dem Weltraum auf. Und dann haben die da im 10 Kilometer Umkreis Internet. Und zwar richtig schnell und richtig gut. Und können da richtig operieren. Und die Russen eben nicht.
Umso rätselhafter, dass sich Elon Musk mit so einem Gedöns wie Twitter abgibt. Wenn ich das alles hätte, dann würde ich ja nicht sagen, gut, jetzt tue ich mich mal auf so einer Social-Media-Plattform um. Also das wäre, wie wenn dann Bundeskanzler ist und sagt, ja, ich könnte doch noch ins Dschungelcamp gehen oder so.
Ja, und hier sieht man auch, also egal was mit Twitter passiert, angenommen, keine Ahnung, die 45 Milliarden Investitionen stellt sich dann wirklich als 3 Milliarden Wert heraus, weil die Werbebranche dann nicht zurückkehrt und so weiter. Also innen in den Mask wird nicht fallen gelassen. So wie auch die amerikanische Politik total abhängig davon ist, dass Facebook gut funktioniert, weil sonst da gar keine Wahlkämpfe mehr funktionieren.
Und TikTok eine Übermacht bekehrt, die man nicht will.
Zum Beispiel, genau, um da auch TikTok im Zaume zu halten. Und damit in China wird innen in den Mask hier hofiert. Also das sind echte Arbeitsbeziehungen mit dem Pentagon und so weiter. Und da spielt dann auch Geld keine große Rolle.
Zumal ja auch die Leaks doch herausgegeben, also diese Leaks zu Twitter herausgekommen sind, die Twitter-Files. Und da zeigt sich ja dann doch, dass diese so sich neutral gebende Plattform politisch doch sehr stark beeinflusst wird.
Ja, ist ja auch für das ganze Influencer-Thema interessant.
Und zwar nicht im Sinne von Zensur, sondern im Sinne von, man sieht was nicht. Also man muss vielleicht kurz erklären, also es gibt diese Twitter-Files, ein sehr komplexes Thema, aber eigentlich ein hochinteressantes. Und die zeigen ja auf, dass es offenbar Absprachen gibt mit der Regierung, was macht man groß oder nicht. Das heißt, jeder kann alles twittern und da wird auch fast nichts zensiert. Nur die Sache ist, wird der Tweet auch allen angezeigt. Ich kann natürlich auch alles Mögliche twittern, wenn es aber dann am Ende nur 100 Leute zu Gesicht bekommen, dann kann man damit natürlich wunderbar Politik machen. Das ist ja auch etwas, was der User selbst nicht sehen kann. Wenn er zensiert wird, kann er es nachvollziehen. Wenn man aber nicht sieht, wie wird man überhaupt gesehen, dann ist da eigentlich die beste Manipulationsmaschine mitgeschaffen. Mindestens genauso gut wie der Newsfeed von Instagram und Facebook.
Und es ist eben nicht nur die Politik, sondern kam ja auch die Mail raus, auch von Biontech, dass sie halt bei Twitter nachfragten, könnt ihr mal diese Tweets so ein bisschen aus dem Spiel nehmen, die immer fordern, dass wir das jetzt global zur Verfügung stellen, unseren Impfstoff und so.
Ist das echt?
Ja, und daraufhin... Ja, hat stattgefunden. Biontech hat sich da involviert, wollte die Tweets ein bisschen gedimmt haben mit der öffentlichen Aufmerksamkeit, und dem wurde ja dann wohl auch entsprochen, wobei ich das nicht so genau weiß, wie die Reaktion. Aber dass überhaupt ein Unternehmen auf die Idee kommt, da mal nachzufragen, heißt ja, die haben ja auch einen Tipp bekommen. Ihr könnt da ruhig mal eine Mail schreiben, da reagiert jemand.
Aber da müsste es doch eigentlich als Thema viel größer, jetzt medial gespielt haben, oder?
Also, es war in meiner kleinen Bubble ein recht großes Thema, allerdings nicht. Im Deutschlandfunk hat man dazu nichts zu tun.
Also wenn ich jetzt dann denke, wie damals dieser Trump-Wahlkampf und Facebook rezipiert wurde, und jetzt hört man das so und denkt, ach ja, das ist ja doch erstaunlich.
Ja, aber es kam ja auch nochmal bei TikTok, das ist da auch, die haben das so als Dial dargestellt, als Rädchen, wo man so ein bisschen die Temperatur hochdrehen kann, dass da, obwohl immer der Algorithmus so gelobt wird, einfach auch eingegriffen werden konnte. Also Mitarbeiter konnten festlegen, dieses kleine Video wird jetzt mal richtig prominent weltweit ausgespielt und damit, ja, bestimmt man eben auch, in welche Richtung sich Künstler so entwickeln, wenn man ihnen zeigt, also wenn du in die Richtung gehst, dann unterstützen wir dich ein bisschen, ohne dass der das mitbekommt. Die glauben ja wirklich allen Publikums Erfolg zu haben, so wie auch bei YouTube immer noch nicht so richtig erkannt wird und bekannt ist, dass 80% der Views aufgrund der Empfehlungsspalte ablaufen, über die nicht die Content Creator bestimmen, sondern allein die Plattform. Was taucht rechts in dieser Empfehlungsspalte ab?
Und da kommt man fast nie rein. Also ich war glaube ich mit der Firma in dieser ein oder zwei Mal.
Genau, und wenn man mal drin ist, dann hat man dann gleich vier Mal als viele. Genau, und dann ist es ein Selbstläufer.
Aber das vielleicht nochmal ein ganz guter Hinweis. Unser Podcast ist ja nicht irgendwie groß angebunden. Und wir haben auch bislang noch nicht, also wir sind noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen, bei Twitter anzurufen, ob die mal die Tweets zu unserem Podcast ein bisschen heißer laufen lassen. Aber generell freuen wir uns darüber, wenn der Podcast in den sozialen Medien geteilt wird, wenn so ein bisschen Werbung dafür gemacht wird von denen, die den Podcast gerne hören oder irgendwie einen Clip rausschneiden und das dann posten und verlinken dann mit Spotify oder Apple oder was auch immer, wo sie das hören. Das würde dem Podcast sehr helfen. Und Bewertungen sind auch immer schön.
Genau. Es ist grundsätzlich so, fällt mir auch immer wieder auf, dass man doch, wenn man weiß, was einem gefällt, darüber gerne reden sollte, weil man immer wieder übersieht, wie viel Kram es gibt. Also mir fällt das immer wieder auf, wenn meine 12-jährige Tochter mir Musik vorspielt. Und sie immer wahnsinnig genervt ist von meiner Musik, die ich so anmache. Und dann sag ich, na, mach du doch. Und sie hat eigentlich jede Woche neue coole Musik dabei. Und das ist quasi meine einzige Quelle, denn ich kriege weder auf Twitter noch sonst irgendwo Musik empfohlen. Und da denke ich mir dann auch wieder, man sollte grundsätzlich mehr breit treten, was man gerade so konsumiert und was Gutes. Man scrollt sich bei Netflixen so auch zu Tode. Man braucht einfach diese persönliche Empfehlung, um sich mal was anzuhören und so anzuschauen. Also in deren Sicht, das sind immer gute Hinweise, die natürlich dann auch der Podcastlandschaft zugutekommen, wenn man einfach hört, was die anderen so hören. Gut, und dann bevor wir da einsteigen in diese Bundesherranalyse, nur dieser kleine Hinweis, wir wollen es einmal in echt hören. Wir haben es ja auch nur im amerikanischen Fernsehen bei PBS, also in Deutschland dazu nichts. Aber für uns, wir haben uns entsprechend sensibilisiert, natürlich eine schon ganz wichtige Nachricht. Auf der Wartung in Ukraine, der vorkommende US-Militärer, Arme-General Mark Milley, behalte sein erstes F-Faß-Meeting mit seinem ukrainischen Gegner. Ja, also die höchsten Militäristen der Ukraine und die höchsten Militäristen des Pentagon-Rien jetzt direkt miteinander haben Kontakte ausgetauscht nach zehn Monaten Krieg. Also all das lief bisher so auf, wir unterstützen mal und so. Jetzt wird das alles nochmal intensiviert. Also dieses Bundesheer-Video, ich habe es zuerst von Tilo empfohlen gekriegt, aber es kam dann aus allen Richtungen irgendwie. Es ist so eine 26-minütige Analyse.
Die machen das ja schon sehr lange.
Auch schon die zweite. Also ich glaube, es gibt zwei. Es gab eine frühere und jetzt so eine aktuelle, wo einfach so ein Bundesheersoldat, also österreichische Armee, mal vor so einer Leinwand steht und so ein paar Sachen aufzeigt. Und er macht relativ am Anfang eine Unterscheidung, die für uns, die wir in Deutschland nur den Leo sehen, die ganze Zeit, wo man sich auch fragt, hat der Panzer nicht eine Typenbezeichnung, die man so ein bisschen weniger niedlich sachlich verwendet werden kann? Ja, so ein Fernseher hat auch irgendwie nur 15 zahlende Buchstaben in seinem Name wild zusammengewürfelt. Aber so ein Panzer ist dann plötzlich Leopard. Also, das ist ein echtes Problem. Aber gut, wir diskutieren in Deutschland eben über die Leos. Und er, der Soldat, macht uns mal eine ganz, ganz wichtige Unterscheidung auf.
Die nächste Ebene ist die strategische Ebene. Jene Ebene, die entscheidend ist, wenn es darum geht, einen Konflikt über lange Zeit zu führen. Hier war es der Fall, dass die russische Seite erkannt hat, dass durch den Einsatz der Luftstreitkräfte mit weiterreichenden Waffensystemen wie ballistischen Raketen, Kruzmissiles, aber auch Drohnen es möglich ist, die Achillesferse der Ukraine anzugreifen. Und das ist die kritische Infrastruktur. Das heißt, obwohl paradoxerweise die ukrainische Seite sehr erfolgreich auf operativer Ebene ist, hat sie die Herausforderung, dass die russische Seite auf strategischer Ebene immer wieder versucht, die kritische Infrastruktur, und das ist natürlich die Stromversorgung der Ukraine anzugreifen.
So, die Ukraine kann operative Gewinne machen, also Schützengraben ein bisschen weiter buddeln, weil man irgendwie 100 Meter Raumgewinn hat, weil das Fahrzeug besser gepanzert war als ein Monat zuvor, wenn man jetzt mit einem Marder loszieht statt mit einem gepanzerten Bus oder so. Und jetzt wird das nochmal gesteigert, man heißt es Leoparden, die können ja auch während der Fahrt schießen, also schafft man vielleicht nochmal einen Kilometer mehr. Das ist operative Ebene. Die Ukraine kann aber keine strategischen Gewinne machen, grundsätzlich, weil sie keinen militärischen Zugriff auf russische Infrastruktur hat. Also die Russen können, solange sie auf ihrem Grund und Boden sind, Flugzeuge betanken, 2000 Soldaten in ein Gebäude stecken, ohne dass Angriffe drohen, weil die Ukraine nicht auf russischen Boden operieren. Gleichzeitig operieren aber die Russen natürlich auf ganzem ukrainischen Boden und können dann die Infrastruktur komplett auseinandernehmen. Was bedeutet, das ist ein echt krasser, mega großer Nachteil. Und das ist mir auch erst da klar geworden.
Die Zivilbevölkerung natürlich in ganz erheblichem Maße. Das ist nicht nur der Kriegssoldat gegen Soldat.
Genau, wir diskutieren immer so, wer kämpft da eigentlich gegen wen? Führen wir den Krieg gegen Russland? Nein. Die Ukraine kämpft gegen Russland, aber nur auf ukrainischem Boden. Es eskaliert nicht auf den russischen Boden, womit die russische Armee immer einen strategischen Vorteil hat. Sie kann sich damit einfach zurückziehen.
Es hat die Holze auch keine Jets zum Beispiel schicken will, weil er sagt, na die fliegen vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter dann.
Genau, wir haben dann gestern mit Mick so ein bisschen rumgealbert, wenn jetzt die Soldaten, die Amerikaner Waffen schicken, die in Reichweite begrenzt sind, damit die nicht so weit über die Grenze schießen können, falls das mal passiert. Ob man nicht einfach auch die Abrams Panzer mit so, die laufen mit GPS und so weiter, ob man die einfach blockiert. Also selbst wenn die Ukrainer wollten, die würden eine Vollbremsung an der russischen Grenze machen, weil die Amerikaner nicht wollen, dass sie darüber fahren. So und die können auch nicht mit dem, darüber schießen oder so. Es wäre technisch alles möglich heutzutage. Die Waffen genauso zur Verfügung, wie so ein E-Roller, der halt nicht in den Park fahren darf. Der wird dann einfach abgeriegelt, bevor er da das Gebiet betritt. Naja, also wir haben eine ganz wichtige Unterscheidung zwischen operativer und strategischer Kriegsführung. Und wenn wir einen Leopard liefern, nützt das nur operativ, aber nicht strategisch. Also super wichtig, weil was müssen wir eigentlich mitliefern, damit sich die Ukraine verteidigen können, wenn die Russen eben nicht nur operativ, also militärisch konkret, sondern auch strategisch auf die Infrastruktur des Landes zugreifen. Und dann hier spielt ja auch Zeit immer eine große Rolle. Ausdauer, wer bringt wie viel mit. Und hier verstehen wir auch nochmal, wie wichtig es eigentlich ist, den ökonomischen Krieg mitzuführen, da wo wir ja schon auf Weltkriegsebene sozusagen eskaliert haben.
Das Ergebnis dieser Angriffe auf strategischer Ebene ist, dass, wenn man an diesen Bildern es betrachtet, die Stromversorgung der Ukraine immer mehr getroffen wird und die Ukraine die große Herausforderung hat, mit dem Einsatz der eigenen Fliegeabwehr auf dieser strategischen Ebene dem etwas entgegenzusetzen. Hier geht es also vor allem um die Ausdauer diesem Konflikt weiterführen zu können.
Ja, es wäre mit jeder Leopardlieferung unsere Aufgabe, Russland auch strategisch zu treffen, wie wir es ja mit den Sanktionen usw. machen, aber halt so richtig konkret und konzentriert. Man dürfte Marietas Lombgas gar nicht durchgehen lassen, nur zu Leopard zu fragen und gar nicht zur strategischen Kriegsführung über Sanktionen usw. um eben auch die zivile Infrastruktur, die den Russischen Krieg unterstützt, da so zu schädigen, dass die eben auch strategisch ausfallen. Stattdessen haben die alles in der Hand und liefern alles nach, was für die operativen Erfolge da vonnöten ist. Und dazu zählt dann zum Beispiel auch, dass man die operativen Fähigkeiten der Russen so schwächt, dass sie beispielsweise nicht das hier machen können, was sie die ganze Zeit schon machen, wovon ich auch erst in dem Bundesheer-Video gehört habe.
Hier kann man bereits erkennen, dass der Einsatz dieser Marschflugkörper, ballistischen Raketen und Drohnen sehr wohl einen Effekt erzielt, nämlich auf dieser strategischen Ebene, wo Russland immer noch festlegen kann, wann, wo und in welchem Umfang es die ukrainische Seite trifft, die immer noch das Problem hat, der mangelhaft vorhandenen Fliegerabwehr und des Problems der immer zunehmenden Zerstörung der kritischen Infrastruktur. Wir sehen das auch in einem Zitat des Präsidenten, der im November gesagt hat, dass bis jetzt über 4700 ballistische Raketen, Marschflugkörper und Drohnen gegen sein Land eingesetzt worden sind. Mittlerweile ist die Zahl bei 5000 plus. Das ist eine Zahl, die es noch nie so in der Kriegsgeschichte gab.
Ja, also werden wir immer hören, ja, für die kleinen Länder gewinnt den operativen Erfolg, brauchen die Panzer.
Da wird ja mensch gejubelt dann. Das wird ja so getan, als hätten die Russen schon halb verloren. Und jetzt hören wir hier, es ist ein Pflichten von Bad De Boer, über das ganze Land. Und ich finde auch die Ansprache, die er wählt, sehr gut. Also von diesem Herrn fühle ich mich angesprochen.
Ja, das ist sehr sachlich, da wird uns erklärt, was das ist.
Und er hat es mal gesagt, und der muss jetzt nicht noch mal in Ballung gehen und noch dreimal erklären, wie der brutale Angriffskrieg usw. Sondern er sagt einfach, das sind die Fakten. Und dann ist ja jede Schlussfolgerung daraus, nur logisch zu sagen, ja klar, ist dieser Krieg brutal, was denn sonst?
Genau, und Mark Milley hat ja gesagt, alles, was man sehen kann, kann man auch abschießen. Und man kann im Grunde alles sehen. Und das gilt insbesondere für die Ukraine, denn es finden sich dauerhaft 5000 Drohnen in der Luft. Das ist auch so eine Zahl, die er nennt. Es ist einfach dieses Land wird flächendeckend, sowohl mit Spionage als auch mit bewaffneten Drohnen überflogen. Also hier findet einfach, es ist eigentlich sehr viel mehr Luftkrieg, als wir immer hören, wenn wir so dieses, der Leopard, der Leopard, also der schießt sicherlich keine Flugzeuge ab. Weshalb Pistorius auch nochmal betont, und er sagt es halt, hier im Gespräch mit Anne Will, sie hat eben noch mal im Einzelgespräch, bevor die Diskussionssendung beginnt, aber es findet sogar keinen Widerhall, weder in der Diskussion danach noch in der Nachrichtenberichterstattung.
Ach wissen Sie, Frau Will, Deutschland steht an der Spitze derjenigen Länder in der Welt, die die Ukraine unterstützen. Wir haben zusammen mit dem Frühlingspaket, was jetzt auf den Weg gebracht wird, insgesamt Systeme, Waffen und Ausstattung im Wert von 3, 3 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung gestellt. Nur Großbritannien und die USA noch mehr, aber die Großbritannien bewegt sich auf dem gleichen Level. Wir müssen uns da nicht verstecken und diese Schuldzuweisungen helfen. Niemandem, ich würde es nochmal sagen, auch in Rammstein hat der Oberbefehlshaber der amerikanischen Streitkräfte die Priorität nochmal unterstrichen, um die es tatsächlich aktuell geht. Und das ist Air Defense, also Luftverteidigung und die dazugehörige Munition. Die steht gerade jetzt im Mittelpunkt.
So, wir liefern unglaublich viel. Und im Mittelpunkt steht Air Defense, Luftverteidigung.
Also das, was wir im Januar so gut wie kaum gehört haben.
Was wir gar nicht gehört haben seitdem. Und hier sieht man wieder, ja, die wissen schon, was sie tun in dieser Kriegsführung. Die sitzen da in Rammstein und reden über die Sachen, auf die es wirklich ankommt. Dann kommen die Journalisten hintenrum und sagen, ja, was ist mit den Leopard-Panzern? Und dann sagt Leut oder er auch, Pistorius hat ja auch ein Gespräch gesagt, ja, darüber haben wir jetzt gar nicht konkret gesprochen. Und die Journalisten so, hä, wie? Das ist doch das wichtigste Thema überhaupt. Er so, nee, da fliegen 5000 Raketen und da sind auch, ist immer alles in der Luft. Das sind ja diese lauernden Drohnen, über die wir auch schon gesprochen haben.
5000 Drohnen.
Flächendeckend hast du einfach das Land übersegelt mit Zeug.
Aber da müsste man sich ja jetzt mit den Drohnenmodellen auseinandersetzen. Das ist dann ein bisschen viel Arbeit. Da ist mit dem Leopard was Greifbares. Das Emoji ist schon da. Eigentlich ist das dann Selbstläufer.
Ja, also hier sieht man, in Rammstein haben sie dann doch sozusagen über das gesprochen, was die Ukraine eigentlich quält. Nämlich, dass da einfach flächendeckendes Licht ausgemacht wird und die Wärmeinfrastruktur bombardiert wird, während es minus 20 Grad sind. Und das ist auch, da war ich nicht sehr viel kritisiert, weil sie so das Induktus des wir haben Marder geliefert und damit Putin dazu provoziert. Muss man sich nicht so formulieren, aber den Zusammenhang gibt es eben trotzdem. Wir haben Marder geliefert, also operativ die Ukraine gestärkt und damit gab es eine strategische Vergeltungsreaktion und die sehen wir dann halt. Es gab diesen flächendeckenden Stromausfall und 80 Prozent der Heizung haben nicht funktioniert bei minus 20 Grad. Also das sind dann halt die Zustände, die dann in Rammstein besprochen werden. Und da spielt dann Air Defense eine große Rolle. Also auf operativer Ebene, ja klar, man schickt jetzt ein paar Panzer, ein paar im Sinne von 419 angefragt und man kann erstmal so 14 liefern.
Aber auch als nächstes Jahr.
Die müssen auch erst hergestellt werden in Amerika. Die schicken keinen eigenen Bestand, sondern die wollen neu produzieren. Also es dauert alles eine Weile. Entsprechend wird auch der Krieg nach einer Weile dauern.
Die Botschaft, die ich Ihnen mitgeben kann, ist, dass dieser Konflikt noch länger dauern wird. Und wir dürfen nicht nur auf die Ukraine und auf Russland sehen, sondern wir müssen auch bedenken, dass Käfte im Hintergrund eine Rolle spielen. Also China, der Iran oder vielleicht auch sogar Indien. Oder auf der anderen Seite natürlich die USA, die Europäische Union oder andere signifikante Unterstützer. Man kann sich den Konflikt auch vorstellen wie einen Boxkampf. Eine Runde nach der anderen findet statt. Die ukrainische Seite hat mehrere Runden nach Punkten gewonnen, aber es hat bis jetzt noch kein K.o. gegeben.
Ja, und hier wird locker flockig. Also er arbeitet auch so mit Bildern, die man auch auf Twitter mal so findet. Aber es wird halt einfach genannt. Da wird mal Belarus wird genannt, Kanada wird genannt, Amerika, die Europäische Union, alle involviert. Also für ihn ist das ja schon. Stefan, Krieg, Weltkrieg, wie auch immer.
Die Frage stellt er sich jetzt nicht mehr, darf man das sagen oder so?
Für die ist das alles eingepreist, was ich höre noch ewig. Der Ansicht schon ganz interessant. Er wird noch lange dauern und es ist eine unfassbare Materialschlacht schon gewesen. Und jetzt schicken wir noch mehr Material.
Man nimmt an, dass die ugrinischen Streitkräfte die quantitativ stärksten Streitkräfte Europas im Beginn des Krieges waren. Über 2000 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge, Kampfschützenpanzer, über 1000 Panzer, die hier verfügbar waren. Diese Kräfte wurden verwendet, um in der ersten Phase die Angriffe an die russischen Kräfte abzunützen. Das heißt, Russland hat sehr hohe Verluste erlitten, aber auch die Ukraine hat sehr hohe Verluste erlitten, bis im Juni aus ukrainischen Quellen ca. die Hälfte ihres Equipments der Landsteilkräfte.
Ja, also wir müssen uns das echt vorstellen, wie so ein Roller, so ein E-Roller, der in Köln rumsteht, von dem alle, die Beteiligten wissen, also die städtische Politik, die Hersteller, die Betreiber, der fährt nur 28 Tage. Und dann liegt der im Rhein. Und jetzt hoffen wir, dass wir in den 28 Tagen genug Profit rausziehen. Also die durchschnittliche Lebenserwartung eines Rollers in einer urbanen Großstadt in Deutschland ist 28 Tage.
Ja, viel zum Thema Nachhaltigkeit.
Und da lagen Jahrhunderte im Rhein. Die mussten ja rausgefischt werden. Die Frage ist, wer bezahlt denn das eigentlich? Und dann hat sich der Hersteller dann doch durchgerungen, da mitzuhelfen und so. Und so ist das hier auch. Also jeder Panzer, der da geliefert wird, hat eine Lebenserwartung von. Und dann sind die Erfahrungswerte, das sind ja überhaupt die ersten richtigen Kriegseinsätze. Das Leopard zum Beispiel. Der ist ja bisher nur für die Türkei mal so ein bisschen durch die syrische Wüste gefahren. Aber ansonsten hat er ja keine Kampferfahrung. Und dann wird er da eingesetzt. Und dann gucken die sich das mal genau an. Wie weit kommt er eigentlich? Also 28 Kilometer oder 280 oder je nachdem. Und ja, bisher war es eine Materialschlacht. Und die wird natürlich weitergehen. Ich denke mir manchmal auch, so einen Leopard zu liefern, wo also jeder russische Beobachter weiß, da sitzen jetzt fünf drin. Und ich will auch nicht, dass der weiterfährt. Ob man dann wirklich plötzlich super geschützt ist, weil man ist ja in so einer Stahlwanne drin, aus der man auch nicht besonders leicht flüchten kann, wenn es drauf ankommt, oder ob man sich damit erst recht zur Zielscheibe macht. Mit welchem Gefühl steigt man eigentlich in so einen Panzer ein, wenn der dann ankommt in der Ukraine?
Also witzig ist das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Da müsste man sich auch nochmal durchdenken irgendwie. Da fehlt auch eine gewisse Reflektion in den Medien.
Du hast jetzt diese verheerenden Zahlen genannt. Wir hatten Berichterstattung über Kriegsverbrechen, russische Kriegsverbrechen an den Ukrainern und haben da auch entsprechende Bilder gesehen. Diese Bilder hatten eine Wirkung. Was aber nicht gezeigt wird uns, ist die Alltäglichkeit des Sterbens in diesem Krieg.
Von 300 Menschen am Tag.
Wir sehen abends, wenn wir die Nachrichten schauen, keine Leichen. Wir sehen Debatten, wir sehen schweres Kriegsgerät, wir sehen die Protagonisten dort, vor allem aus der Politik. Aber wir sehen eigentlich nicht, was Krieg bedeutet. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz großes Problem. Wir müssten eigentlich, und damit meine ich jetzt auch auf beiden Seiten, das Sterben zeigen. Man müsste zeigen, hier liegen die toten jungen russischen und ukrainischen Männer.
Wir hatten ja auch diese Nachrichtenlage rund um den Jahreswechsel, dass da diese Ankunftsstätte für russische Soldaten kurz vor der Front bombardiert wurde mit 600 Toten. Weil die sind halt da angekommen, junge Männer holen das Smartphone raus, geben sich damit zu erkennen, Ziel ist ausgemacht, also wird es bombardiert. Und das wurde ja erstaunlich nüchtern weggemeldet, dass es da so einen operativen Erfolg der Ukrainer gab. Man hat eben 600 russische Soldaten mit einem Angriff innerhalb von fünf Minuten da getötet.
Das ist kein Krieg zwischen Zelensky und Putin oder zwischen ein paar Militärs nur, sondern das sind alles irgendwelche Jungs, die zum Teil ideologisch verführt, manche mögen Überzeugungstäter sein, was auch immer. Sie alle sind aber nun in einer Situation, wo ihr Leben sehr jäh enden kann. Viele hat es schon geendet und damit ist dann alles, was sonst im Leben wichtig wäre, Familie und dergleichen, ausgelöscht. Also das ist in dieser Weise eigentlich zu berichten und das findet nicht statt.
Ja und nachdem man hier über den Holocaust und auch über den Zweiten Weltkrieg so redet, kann man ja überlegen, in 80 Jahren ist das noch Thema in der Ukraine. Also es ist ja nichts, was jetzt mal plötzlich so schnell wegentschieden wird und dann hat man halt eine politische Lage geklärt, sondern hier wird ja richtig Geschichte geschrieben.
Und wir haben ja über die russische Demografie gesprochen, genauso auch die ukrainische. Wir haben es da mit alten Ländern zu tun, in Russland. Das heißt, da sind jetzt auch viele Eltern, die haben dieses Einzigkind, so wie ich ja auch ein Einzigkind bin. Und das wird jetzt da verfeuert.
Genau, in der Ansicht, das ist alles hochgradig dramatisch und manchmal schimmert es so ein bisschen durch in so Moderationen. Hier zum Beispiel im heutigen Niveau bei Christian Sievers. Aber es ist wirklich nur so ein ganz kurzer Ausschnitt.
Die Situation an der Frontlinie in der Ukraine, die weckt ja schlimme Erinnerungen an die Lage im Ersten Weltkrieg. Keine wirklichen Geländegewinne, aber ein furchtbar hoher Preis auf beiden Seiten. Abnutzungskrieg, ein grauenhaftes Wort im Grunde, aber es passt. Die Berichte über getötete Soldaten werden immer häufiger.
Ja, und das ist dann wirklich nur so kurz, aber da steckt dann in 20 Sekunden alles drin. Abnutzungskrieg, Erinnerungen an den Ersten Weltkrieg werden wach. Und damit meinen wir kulturelle Erinnerungen, also nicht unsere privaten. Das heißt, diese Empfehlung schaut euch im Westen nichts Neues an, ist ganz ernst gemeint, denn da steckt sozusagen der Impressionistisch drin, worum es geht. Und Berichte von getöteten Soldaten werden häufiger. Also mal gucken, er hat das jetzt hier am 24. Januar einfach so gesagt. Mal gucken, wann die Berichte häufiger werden in den deutschen Medien, um uns das mal zu zeigen.
Also kleiner Tipp an die Journalisten, es dürfte auch ruhig mal eine Woche ohne Strackzimmermann vergehen. Und stattdessen könnte man ja mal die zeigen, die vom Krieg betroffen sind oder ihnen nicht überlebt haben.
Also ich sehe eigentlich nur Isabel Schajani in der Ukraine, die Berichterstattung mitbringt, wie es so an der Heimatfront, die zurückgelassenen Frauen und so weiter, wie es da so zugeht. Ansonsten, also Kathrin Eigendorf und so, die berichten uns nicht davon. Die stehen irgendwo auf der Straße und...
Die erzählen irgendwas, ordnen noch mal das ein, was jeder weiß, der eine dpa-Meldung lesen kann. Also das ist ja überhaupt nichts.
Ja, also das, was Eigendorf aus der Ukraine liefert, was ich sehe, vielleicht macht sie noch irgendwo für die Mediatheken irgendwas, ist das, was man auch im Studio vorlesen könnte. Aber es wäre natürlich cool, wenn man noch mal eine Live-Schalte ins Land macht und so. Und naja, die Militärs haben halt dann auch, sagen wir mal so, die ordnen das dann. Also wir kennen ja jetzt seine Unterscheidung. Operative, strategische Kriegsführung. Wir hören die Diskussion, Panzerlieferung. Und hier wird es so eingeordnet in den Verlauf des Krieges.
Wenn man jetzt aber genau hinhört, dann hört man, dass der ukrainische Generalstaffchef ganz klar gesagt hat, wenn ihr wollt, dass wir wieder in die Offensive gehen, dann brauche ich noch einmal eine dritte Lieferung. Ich brauche noch einmal 300 Panzer. Ich brauche noch einmal 600 bis 700 Kampfschützenpanzer. Ich brauche noch einmal 500 Artilleriesysteme. Das heißt, die ukrainischen Landsteigkräfte müssen zum dritten Mal neu offensivfähig gemacht werden.
Ja, und so läuft ja dann auch die Argumentation wahrscheinlich intern. Also Selensky, klar, für die Öffentlichkeit ist es immer so allgemein, wir fordern Unterstützung und so weiter und so fort. Aber hier wird halt dann intern ganz klar gezeigt. Ja, mit dem Marder haben wir diese Erfolge feiern können, aber das ebbt jetzt ab, weil die sind alle zerschossen und so weiter. Was könnt ihr dann als nächstes schicken? Und so ist jetzt die Leopard-Lieferung die dritte Welle an Offensivfähigkeitsherstellung für die ukrainische Armee. Und die zieht sich jetzt natürlich ein bisschen, je nachdem, wann sie da ankommen. Aber aus der Richtung ist natürlich total klar, dass die dann als nächstes Flugzeuge fordern und so. Also in der Hinsicht, mal gucken, wie das weitergeht. Jetzt ist fast ein Jahr rum, und das nächste Jahr kommt bei einem Flugzeug gar nicht drum rum, wenn der rote Faden so weitergesponnen wird, wie es bis jetzt geschah.
Genau, und diese Gefahr sollte man ganz klar sehen, denn dann sind wir ja mittendrin. Also dann ist ja nicht mehr, naja, wir haben da mal irgendwas hingeliefert oder so, sondern dann entgrenzt sich dieser Krieg ja immer weiter dadurch und dann werden wir sehen. Wir gehen nach Davos, schlage ich vor. Dort war mal wieder die Elite aus Politik und Wirtschaft zu Gast. Schwab hatte wieder eingeladen zum Weltwirtschaftsforum. Und das ist doch eine Veranstaltung, die in gewisser Weise aus der Zeit gefallen ist. Deshalb, weil ja eigentlich mal diese Idee war, die Welt ist dort zu Gast, aber die Welt ist dann gar nicht dort zu Gast mehr. Das heißt, wir haben es mit kleineren Ländern dort natürlich noch zu tun, außer aller Welt, die dort sind. Dort sind aber es gibt zum Beispiel China kaum in Davos. Wir werden aber was hören, nämlich der Vizepräsident von China war dann sehr wohl dort. Aber wir können doch sehen, es ist eine sehr, sehr europäisch-amerikanische Veranstaltung, plus die da so mit dranhängen. Das heißt, man tappt da auch ein bisschen im Dunkeln. Also man kann gar nicht mehr sagen, wir machen jetzt hier Weltwirtschaft, sondern wir sprechen hier über einen sehr kleinen Rahmen oder wird dieser Rahmen vielleicht noch viel kleiner werden? Das ist also eine Frage, der wir jetzt nachgehen werden. Und auch interessant, George Soros war erstmals nicht dort. Er kommt zur Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz. Also auch da sieht man so einen Prioritäten-Shift. Ja, Weltwirtschaft, wir haben jetzt gerade hier Geopolitik.
Also hat er es erklärt, also aus innerlichen Gründen und so?
Nein, aber er hat schon die Sicherheitskonferenz zugesagt. Henry Kissinger war da, aber das erspare ich dir jetzt mal. Ich will dir nicht immer Henry Kissinger vorspielen. Es war aber auch jetzt nicht so unglaublich interessant.
Das müsste man da auch in 5-Fahrgeschwindigkeit spielen.
Ja, aber dafür brummelt er so viel. Olaf Scholz war dort, hat eine Rede gehalten. Und wir fangen jetzt erstmal mit dem Schluss der Rede an.
Und so viel Prognose sei gewagt.
Auf dem Jahrestreffen des World Economic Forum 2045 wird mein Nachfolger oder meine Nachfolgerin zu Ihnen sprechen.
Er oder sie wird Deutschland dann als einen der ersten klimaneutralen Industriestarten der Welt präsentieren. Die Energieversorgung Deutschlands und Europas wird dann fast ausschließlich aus grüner Elektrizität, Wärme und Wasserstoff stammen.
Auf unseren Straßen und Schienen werden wir uns abgasfrei bewegen. Unsere Gebäude werden energieeffizient sein. Unsere Unternehmen werden klimaneutral produzieren.
Ja, wir haben ja die Baubranche gehört, die meinte, ein Prozent pro Jahr schaffen wir zu erneuern. Also ich würde sagen, 2085 schaffen wir das mit den Gebäuden. Aber nicht 2045.
Hier müsste man mal, gibt es eigentlich ein Tool bestimmt? Man müsste jetzt hier mal so eine Erinnerung haben. Ich möchte einfach beim Weltwirtschaftsforum 2045, so Gott will, erinnert werden, dass Scholz das damals gesagt hat.
Einfach eine Erinnerung an Siri ins iPhone einsprechen für 2045?
Hab ich ja nicht, aber vielleicht sollte ich mir dafür mal ein iPhone anschaffen. Und wenn wir dann auch noch hier sitzen und der Podcast heißt dann Die Klimaneutralen Viertiger.
Wie heißt denn vor allem Die Neuen Vierziger?
Die Klimaneutralen Vierziger. Dann können wir sagen, ja, Scholz hat es gesagt und hat recht behalten. Wir sind mal gespannt. Er skizziert dann, was alles gemacht wird, gerade in Deutschland für die Grüne Transformation. Das erspare ich uns jetzt erst, erzählt er ja dort den globalen Investoren. Also was er oder was jeder Staatsmann dort tut, ist aufzuzeigen, was geschieht hier gerade, kommt doch, wir sind ein sicherer Hafen, hier ist das Investitionsklima gut. Und deswegen dann auch dieser Höhepunkt. Erstaunlich ist aber, was er zum Thema Arbeitslosigkeit und Demografie sagt, beziehungsweise es ist nicht erstaunlich, wenn wir wissen, was er sonst schon dazu gesagt hat. Wir hören mal rein.
Die Inflation geht langsam zurück, übrigens auch dank den Schritten der Zentralbanken.
Die industrielle Produktion in Deutschland ist in den vergangenen Monaten stabil geblieben, trotz aller Widrigkeiten.
Die Zahl der Beschäftigten liegt auf Rekordniveau, und hat zuletzt weiter zugelegt.
Ja, also wir kommen nachher auf Demografie zu sprechen. Ja, das Statistische Bundesamt hat jetzt gerade 84, 4 Millionen und so weiter. Es ist alles auf Rekord. Aber die Einschläge ins Erwerbsversuch und Potenzial kommen so nahe, dass Hubertus Heil gerade weltmeisterliche Politik macht, um das mal in Sportmaßstäben auch zu zeigen, wirklich auf der Höhe der Zeit argumentiert und auch mit entsprechender Dringlichkeit. Warum Scholz hier immer noch seiner alten Linie treu bleibt, ist mir unklar. Er könnte ja auch so langsam anfangen, das Thema zu verschweigen. Stattdessen ist er immer wieder...
Nee, er macht es mal ganz groß hier.
In diesem Jahr heben wir in unserem Land endlich ein modernes Einwanderungsrecht.
Denn wenn wir als Industrieland wettbewerbfähig bleiben wollen, brauchen wir Praktiker mit Erfahrung, qualifizierte Ingenieurinnen, Handwerker und Maschinenbauer.
Wer bei uns mit anpacken will, der ist uns willkommen, so lautet die Botschaft.
Für Jahrzehnte haben es die Prognosen nun vorausgesagt, dass die Bevölkerung schrumpfen wird.
Bislang ist es anders gekommen.
Deutschland hat heute genauso viele Einwohner und so viele Erwerbstätige wie nie zuvor.
Stimmt alles, aber ich finde es schon bemerkenswert, dass man nicht mal reflektiert, wie alt diese Leute sind und dass wir dann sehr viele Menschen haben, die uralt sind und die dann sterben werden und dann wenig nachkommen, wenn man es nicht über Einwanderung regelt.
Man wächst, dann wird man alt und dann schrumpft man. Und wir werden alt, Prozess, der ist jetzt so weit, abgeschlossen.
Die werden ja nicht dann irgendwann 120.
Genau, und Lebenserwartung stagniert seit 2014.
Das ist dann auch die Frage, wie weit man das noch am Arbeitsmarkt einsetzen wollte, wenn man Menschen hat, die sehr, sehr alt sind. Und dass er auch noch mal vorher sagt, die Zinserhöhung wirkt, die soll ja eigentlich Arbeitslosigkeit produzieren. Das ist ja eigentlich die Idee, dass man versucht, Kredite und all das teurer zu machen, Investitionen wären dann seltener, dann gibt es Arbeitslosigkeit. In den USA können wir das mitunter jetzt erleben. Bei uns ist ja die Inflation überhaupt anders getrieben, nämlich in erster Linie durch Lieferketten, Energiepreise, kurz um Krieg. Und die Zinserhöhung, obwohl sie so scharf sind, sorgen nicht einmal dafür, dass eine Arbeitslosigkeit entstehen kann, weil so viele Leute fehlen. Also klar, hätte man jetzt Überschuss an Leuten, dann hätten wir jetzt eine erhöhte Arbeitslosigkeit durch die Zinspolitik. Wir haben aber eine solche Knappheit an Leuten, dass, obwohl man jetzt schon da alle Häne zugeschraubt hat, immer noch nicht genügend Leute da sind, um die Häuser zu bauen, die dann noch gebaut werden können.
Es ist weiter der Running Gag, wie ich finde, in den Kurzmeldungen, Börsenberichterstattung usw. Man beschreibt die größte Krise aller Zeiten und schließt dann mit, aber der Arbeitsmarkt zeigt sich robust. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Man bleibt da immer noch bei, man geht der Frage nicht nach, man versucht, das nicht zu erklären.
Gut, wir verlassen dies und sprechen lieber über den globalen Handel. Die Frage ist ja, gibt es ein Decoupling? Werden wir das Ende der Globalisierung erleben? Sind wir gerade schon mitten in dem Prozess? Und Scholz ist angetreten, und Linden hören wir später, Scholz ist angetreten, um zu sagen, nein, die Globalisierung muss schon bleiben.
Unsere Leverketten müssen an neue geopolitische Realitäten angepasst werden.
Realitäten, die Sie, lieber Klaus, gestern als Matchy Patchwork of Powers bezeichnet haben.
Und über all dem hängt das Damocles-Schwert einer neuen Fragmentierung der Welt, die Gefahr von Deglobalisierung und Decoupling.
Hier ganz klare Ansage, Decoupling, Deglobalisierung ist Scholz Sache nicht, aber man muss natürlich sich da entsprechend neu aufstellen. Das bedeutet aber für Scholz, nicht jetzt zu schauen, wie können wir nur noch regional produzieren, sondern er spricht sich dezidiert für Freihandelsabkommen aus.
Ich setze mich mit aller Kraft dafür ein, dass den erfolgreich verhandelten Freihandelsabkommen mit Kanada, Korea, Japan, Neuseeland und Chile bald weitere ambitionierte Freihandelsabkommen folgen werden, mit dem Mercosur, Indien und Indonesien.
Nun wissen wir beide, mit den Freihandelsabkommen ist das oft so eine Sache, aber grundsätzlich finde ich die Stoßrichtung gut, denn zu glauben, wir könnten uns jetzt abschotten, wir machen jetzt da unser eigenes Ding, und dann werden auch damit die Weltprobleme geringer. Das ist ja ein Irrglaube. Nur weil das jetzt in Bezug auf Russland nicht funktioniert hat und man da ja auch eine sehr einseitige und sehr totale Abhängigkeit mit der Energie geschaffen hat, was man ja so nicht hätte machen können, kann man ja jetzt nicht einfach den globalen Handel abwickeln und glauben, man kommt damit weiter. Sondern dann, wenn diese Verflechtungen nicht mehr da sind, kann ja noch viel mehr Potenzial für Krieg auch darin bestehen, weil man nicht mehr in einem Austausch sich befindet. Das war ja auch die Sache, dass die Kommunikation mit Russland auch irgendwann gar nicht mehr gelang.
Genau, wir haben ja immer nur eine Welt. Wir haben ja immer keine Kontrollwelt, sozusagen, um Argumente zu testen. Aber wer glaubt, jetzt haben wir ja gerade ein ganz schlechtes Verhältnis mit Russland. Wie wäre es denn ohne diese Energiepartnerschaft gewesen? Schon vor 2022 zum Beispiel. Also das sind ja auch alles Fragen, die stehen so im Raum. Ist man denn da mal so ein bisschen ins Detail gegangen? Ich meine, Weltmarkt, klar, es gibt natürlich Produkte, die sind so raffiniert und dann lohnt es sich dann auch, wenn man sie einmal hergestellt hat, sie in die ganze Welt zu exportieren. Smartphones, Autos, der ganze Elektronikkram und so. Deswegen brauchen wir aber keinen Weltmarkt für Milchpulver zum Beispiel. Also diese Differenzierung.
Die wurde natürlich nicht gemacht, bzw. wir werden sie vielleicht gleich implizit hören. Du hast ja völlig recht.
Es gab dieses von Ayaan Bremer moderierte Globalisierung, nicht mehr Globalisierung, also Relokalisierungsargument oder Diskussionen mit Adam Toos und diesem Ferguson und so weiter. Und die sind so drüber geschwebt über diese Themen, statt da irgendwo mal ins Detail zu gehen. Und irgendwie, es war immer nur Schlagworte hier und Schlagworte da. Das hat mich auch ein bisschen, selbst bei Toos, so ein bisschen gestört. Also die Veranstaltungen gehen ja immer nicht lange. Die haben ja immer nur Ausdauer von 25 Minuten oder so. Genau, und dann reden die so 20 Minuten lang über Hardware und Software und so und machen dann so Quatschargumente, die ansonsten, keine Ahnung, besperrt sind.
Wir werden da gleich eine Antwort drauf bekommen, aber es ist nicht die Antwort, die du haben möchtest, befürchte ich. Noch einmal kurz, Scholz, das ist eine Rede, die erhält für die Weltöffentlichkeit. Aber ist es wirklich die Weltöffentlichkeit? Nein, erhält diese Rede eigentlich den Amerikanern. Das würden wir jetzt.
Protektionismus verhindert den Wettbewerb und Innovationen und schadet dem Klimaschutz.
Darüber sprechen wir als die EU mit unseren amerikanischen Freunden.
Da gibt es auch wirklich Streit und Geschrei. Aber das findet ja mehr auf Ursula von der Leins Arbeitsebene statt. Und da ist ein bisschen Rambazamba. Wobei Ursula von der Lein schon versucht, ihre etwas sanftere, mütterliche Karte da so zu spielen. Sie macht das ja ganz clever, finde ich, was für die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit angeht. Aber da ist Streit.
Christian Lindner war ja dort. Und den Clip habe ich jetzt nicht mitgebracht, aber er sagte, dort angesprochen auf die großen Investitionen der Amerikaner jetzt hinsichtlich des Inflation Reduction Act. Ja, das sei beachtlich, aber da müssen wir uns gar keine Sorgen machen. Denn wir haben ja den mit 800 Milliarden Euro gefüllten Klimafond der EU. Und dann denke ich mir, ja wie, den hättest du doch wahrscheinlich am allerliebsten noch verhindern.
Er wollte den verhindern.
Ja, du bist doch derjenige, der auf keinen Fall wollte, dass der größer ist und gar keine gemeinschaftliche Verschuldung.
Eigentlich sagt er immer, jetzt wo er da ist, der war ja wirklich nur für die Pandemie-Krise.
Er sitzt da und sagt, wir haben ja diesen Klimafond, das können wir...
Ein Clip mit Ewigkeit würde ich sagen. Also alle noch mal suchen Lindner Davos.
Christian Lindner in Davos wird darauf angesprochen und sagt das dann. Wir hören ganz kurz den spanischen Ministerpräsidenten Pedro Sanchez. Auch er ist auf Scholz Kurs beziehungsweise auf Freihandelskurs.
Wir werden auch weiterhin für eine ökologische und interkommunikative Wirtschaft advocate.
Es gibt natürlich einige Dinge, die zu beachten sind.
Ja, aber das ist ja nun kein sehr tragfähiges Argument, um den Amerikanern auszureden, dass sie nur in Amerika investieren. Weil da gibt es weder Security-Fragen noch andere, die das stellen.
Wir hören jetzt ihnen auch von Multilateralismus sprechen. Das ist ja doch nochmal was anderes als jetzt Freihandel. Das ist ein Aussprach für eine multilaterale Welt. Damit sagt er auch ziemlich deutlich, wir werden schon auch mit anderen Ländern zu tun haben, auch wenn das den USA dann nicht so recht ist. Und er macht noch mal dieses Argument für Spanien, gilt das ganz besonders.
Spanien ist das 16.
größte Land der Tradition im Weltmeer und das zweitmöglichste Land, das wir besitzt haben. Das werden wir in der Zukunft auch noch tun, während wir auch noch für eine europäische Union mit den restlichen Leuten, insbesondere unseren Freunden in Lateinamerika, als Bewerber für eine Europäische Union advocate.
Du hast es ja mitgebracht im Salon, sehr leicht nachvollziehbare, schlagende Argument. Auf empirischer Ebene. Man vergleiche Belgien und Nordkorea. Dann sieht man die eine in abgestatteter Armut und die anderen in weltoffenem Reichtum. Was ja eigentlich so einer Merzdenke komplett widerspricht. Da müssen ja die Grenzen erstmal aufgezogen werden. Und zwar nicht nur die physischen, sondern auch die mentalen und so. Aber die Relativ ist andersrum.
Nun, wie ist es mit der Öffnung der Welt? Wie ist es mit den Systemrivalen Amerika-China? In Zürich hat ein Treffen stattgefunden, von dem nicht sehr viel nach außen gedrungen ist. Deswegen hören wir hier nur ganz kurz, was CBS uns davon berichtet. An sich ist das ein ganz guter Schritt, dass da mal wieder ein Austausch entsteht. Also Janet Yellen traf Chinas Vizepräsidenten Liu He. In Zürich? In Zürich, naja, Liu He war in Davos und Yellen war da auch unterwegs. Das heißt, das funktionierte dann ganz gut. Und Zürich, ich war ja auch im Januar wieder dort, ist ja herrlich. Wo wenn nicht in Zürich sollte man sich treffen.
Da sind echt die Fische gestorben, weil der See zu sauber war, der Zürichsee.
Tatsächlich.
Man hat den so blank geputzt.
Ich würde mich am liebsten jeden Abend mit irgendjemandem in Zürich treffen.
Ja, Zürich macht das her. Das Essen ist nur ein bisschen teuer. Ich habe da mal einen Döner gegessen, der hat 10 Franken gekostet.
Ja, es ist alles ein bisschen teuer in Schweiz. Das ist schon so. Ja, das ist so. Aber es ist zumindest doch ein klares Zeichen, nicht für Entspannung, aber zumindest, dass wieder Dialog stattfinden. Denn nach Pelosi's Taiwan-Besuch und so was war das nochmal erkalteter, dieses Verhältnis zwischen China und USA. Das ist also so eine ganz, ganz zarte Annäherung. Antonio Guterres war auch da, der Generalsekretär der Vereinten Nationen. Und er hat in Davos auch noch mal gemahnt.
Eine tektonische Verbrechung, die zwei verschiedene Regeln der Handlung, zu dominanten Wahlen, zu Internet und zu konflikten Strategien auf der artificialen Intelligenz kreiert.
Ja, ganz klare Ansage. Er weiß auch, worauf das hinauslaufen würde. Er weiß, dass das am Ende keinem auf Dauer nutzen wird und schon gar nicht der ganzen Welt an sich. Ich hoffe, dass man diese Worte dann sehr verinnerlicht. Gut, er ist es ja häufig so, er sagt Richtiges, aber es wird nicht gehört. Wir hören jetzt mal Liu He. Er war also auch dort, hatte eine 35-minütige Rede gehalten, berichtet da ausführlich, welch wunderbar wirtschaftlichen Erfolge China zum Bezeichnen hat. Das spare ich uns jetzt. Und ja, das ist dann so ein Zahlengeklingel, was da stattfindet und wortgeklingelnd. Und da wird natürlich vieles, was wirklich interessant wäre, nicht benannt und analysiert. Aber wir bleiben jetzt mal ganz auf dieser Ebene, sagen wir, der Rhetorik, der Ebene, was ist jetzt so das ideologische Programm? Und wir hatten ja durch Sirocovid in China, durch diese Abschottungspolitik, den Eindruck, die Chinesen wollen sich abschotten, auch tatsächlich, verstärken ihre Macht auf die Bürger und versuchen eigentlich einen Binnenmarkt so zu etablieren, dass sie immer weniger aufs Ausland angewiesen sind. Sicherlich gibt es diese Tendenz der starken Binnenwirtschaft, und das hat ja selten einem Land geschadet, wenn man eine starke Inlandswirtschaft hat. Aber wir bekommen hier von Liu He doch sehr deutlich gesagt, es geht keineswegs um eine Abschottung.
China's national reality dictates that opening up to the world is a must, not an expediency. We must open up wider and make it work better. We oppose unilateralism and protectionism and look forward to strengthening comprehensive international cooperation with all countries.
Gut, wir haben jetzt so gleich die Seidenstraße. Also es gibt ja durchaus die Bestrebungen, in alle Welt vernetzt zu sein. Das bedeutet dann aber natürlich, wenn man diese Öffnungen ernst nimmt, dann kann man nicht sich ein eigenes Internet bauen. Da müsste es tatsächlich auch auf so eine Verletzung hinauslaufen. Das ist ja auch etwas, was jetzt Freihandelsabkommen eigentlich immer wollen, dass es da nicht abgeschottete Bereiche gibt. Also man muss diese Aussage erst mal so hinnehmen. Es leuchtet natürlich wirtschaftlich gesehen ein. Und wenn wir wissen, dass die Menschen in China auch nicht mehr werden, dann muss man ja auch ins Ausland denken, um expandieren zu können. Wir können also erst mal festhalten, es gibt offenbar nicht den Versuch in China, sich nur auf die eigene Bevölkerung und die eigene Wirtschaft zu konzentrieren. Dann hören wir jetzt noch einen zweiten Clip. Jetzt erzähl mir doch mal, was ist denn Material Duality? Ist das Yoga? Ist das vom Yoga? Also diese Dualität, ist materielle Dualität, wir sind voneinander abhängig, was der eine haben will, das gehört dem anderen und umgekehrt. Er führt das nicht näher aus, hat das auch dann noch mal nachgelesen in seiner Rede, ob ich da irgendwas überhört habe oder was es damit auf sich hat. Es ist nur etwas, worauf er zwei oder dreimal zu sprechen kommt. Das heißt, es scheint so eine Staatsphilosophie oder Wirtschaftsphilosophie vielmehr zu sein, die sagt, dass es immer von beiden Seiten zu betrachten ist, es gibt gar keine Loslösung daraus. Also es ist nicht irgendwas Dialektisches gemeint, sondern es ist eher die Schatten- und die Sonnenseite. Oder man kann das eine nicht ohne das andere haben.
Ying und Yang?
Ying-Yang-Geschichte ist das eher schon. Warum das jetzt da so prominent in der Rede vorkam, hat mich etwas irritiert. Vielleicht weiß da jemand ganz konkret weiter. Das wäre auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Hinweis.
Vielleicht eine materielle Dualität. Also es ist halt immer so Licht, Schatten, Leib, Seele, Ying und Yang. Aber materiell vielleicht ist das wirklich bezogen auf Wirtschaft für China, Wirtschaft für die Welt. Weil sie haben es ja schon geschafft und es war ja auch ein erklärtes Ziel ihre sehr erfolgreiche Außenwirtschaft so ein bisschen damit abzuschotten, dass man es intern halt aufbaut. Und der Exportsektor sind ja irgendwie nur noch, obwohl die die ganze Welt beliefern, 25 Prozent oder sowas. Das ganze Bips. Man hat ja auch große Angst, darf Siemens jetzt mit diesem französischen Zugbauer zusammengehen? Nein, weil dann wären die in Monopol und so. Und dann hatte man ja Angst und so weiter. Und der größte Hersteller von Zügen ist in China und exportiert aber nichts, baut nur China auf. Solche Sachen, da sieht man ja schon, dass es so eine gewisse materielle Dualität gibt, beide Felder zu bespielen.
Kommen wir zu Lindner. Bevor er dann den Klimafond von Ursula von der Leyen lobte, sprach er auch über die Coupling.
Wir konnten auf dem G7-Level unter der deutschen Präsidentenheit letztes Jahr ein Klima-Club finden. Ich denke, das ist ein beeindruckendes Beispiel der politischen Macht der Macht.
Der lobt hier lauter, sagt, das ist wie Merkel, die einfach öffentlich im Ausland auftritt und sich feiern lässt dafür, was sie intern mit genau umgedrehten Vorzeichen macht, Klima-Club und so.
Klima-Club, das war ja bestimmt seine Idee.
Ich finde das richtig gut. Ein paar Grenzen hochziehen.
Ich würde es auch nochmal argumentativ ein bisschen infrage stellen. Ja, das war ein Erfolg bei G7, aber hier ist ja die Frage nach einer Weltwirtschaft, wer ist dann bei G7 alles nicht dabei? Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht Russland, sondern klar, da sind immer mal wieder andere Länder noch eingeladen. Aber was hier mit Weltwirtschaft gemeint ist, ist ja doch eine sehr westliche Ausrichtung mit den ein paar verbündeten Partnern, den unmittelbar verbündeten. Das heißt, wie wirksam ein Klimaklub ist, wenn man sich mal ansieht, wo haben wir die ganz großen Volkswirtschaften, ist ja auch etwas, was in Frage zu stellen ist.
Na ja, es ist halt so diese Olaf-Scholz-Idee, wie bei dieser Mindestbesteuerung. Wir machen es nicht, bevor es die ganze Welt macht. Und jetzt hat er da so einen Erfolg eingefahren. Und jetzt geht das bei dem Klimaklub dasselbe. Aber es wird wahrscheinlich auch noch ewig dauern. Und ob dann sein 2045-Ziel so erreichbar ist, mal sehen.
Janet Yellen hatte ja schon vor einem halben Jahr von Friendsharing gesprochen. Damit meinte sie, jetzt ist die Globalisierung zwar nicht zu Ende, aber man macht es jetzt mit Freunden nur noch. Und das ist ein Gedanke, der von Lindner aufgegriffen wird.
Instead of having a kind of trade controversy between the US and the European Union, we should consider whether there is an opportunity for Friendsharing, as my US colleague Janet Yellen suggested.
Das ist also diese Idee.
Das ist hier Reiner Schützeichel, die ethnische Differenzierung. Wir machen Profite und wir wissen auch, was wissenschaftliche Wahrheit ist. Wir organisieren politische Macht, aber nur unter dem Deckmantel der ethnischen Differenzierung. Hier die liberal aufgeklärten guten Länder und da halt die anderen.
Ja, und dann können wir ja mal durchgehen im Kopfe. Das machen wir jetzt nicht ausführlich.
Ist Ungarn dann dabei oder nicht?
Genau. Wie viele liberale Demokratien, also liberale Demokratien, nicht einfach nur, wo mal gewählt wird, sondern liberale Demokratien haben wir. Und wovon müssten wir uns dann lösen und wer bleibt noch? Wenn Lindner das ernst meinen würde, da wäre ich doch sehr gespannt, wie er das seinen Freunden von der Kapitalfraktion erzählen will.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja so eine Idee. Steinmeier ist in Brasilien, während Lula dort vereidigt wird und willkommt ihn dann auf der internationalen Bühne zurück. Das ist ja nur semantische Spielerei. In dem Fall wäre das ja ernst gemeint. In Frankreich hat Le Pen gewonnen, raus.
Das wollen wir nicht mal machen.
Genau, in fünf Jahren gibt es die Chance und dann nimmt man sie wieder auf, aber in so ein echtes Gebilde. Also total fluide Mitgliedschaft in so einer quasi europäischen Union oder sowas.
Sehr richtig. Du nimmst jetzt schon etwas vorweg, nämlich von Nogosi Okonyo-Iweala. Sie war auch zu Gast, saß dort mit Larry Fink und mit Habeck.
Wer ist sie denn?
Sie ist von der Afrikanischen Union, ich glaube Sondergesandte. Sie spricht da sehr klar über die Probleme, die afrikanische Länder haben, an Kapital zu kommen, um zum Beispiel eine grüne Transformation hinzubekommen. Larry Fink sprach nämlich, also der BlackRock-Chef, sprach da auch von Friendshoring. Und das hören wir uns jetzt gar nicht an, sondern wir hören gleich uns mal von Okonyo-Iweala an, was sie davon hält.
Und ein Freund heute kann vielleicht nicht sein, morgen wird er kein Freund sein. Auch wenn du das sagst, höre ich in Afrika keine Länder nennen. Larry hat gesagt, Indonesia und Brasilien könnten beseitigen, aber es gibt Potenzial für grüne Hydrogen in Namibien.
Ja, richtige Punkt.
Also stell dir mal vor, du organisierst das wie den DAX, ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen. Das ist die Bundesliga, du kannst auf und ab steigen, je nachdem welche Umsätze du so fährst oder wie du dein Unternehmen organisierst. Dann hast du so die G20, aber so eine echte Liste. Also nicht nur, was weiß ich, irgendeine Organisation, Amnesty International, die gibt zum Thema so und so was raus, oder zum Thema Pressefreiheit oder so, sondern eine echte Harte, auf die sich alle geeinigt haben, Liste irgendwie. Oder zumindest die oberen Länder, auf die es dann ankommt. Und dann ja, begrüßen die einfach Länder, die aufgestiegen sind und verabschieden die, die abgestiegen sind und dann sind die jeweils dabei oder nicht bei so Treffen.
Naja, und afrikanische Länder, wie sie hier ganz zurecht anmerkt werden, natürlich da einfach noch übergangen. Das ist jetzt nicht so relevant. Da kann man gucken, wenn man da noch irgendwie ein gutes Geschäft machen kann, kommt es mit dazu. Aber Friendsharing meint natürlich, dass sich da die Machtblöcke, die schon da sind, nochmal verfestigen vielleicht. Larry Fink macht ein Argument für die Globalisierung. Du hast ja eben gefragt, wurde denn auch mal darüber gesprochen, muss man eigentlich Milchpulver um die ganze Welt schiffen? Oder sprechen wir jetzt nur über iPhones, die tatsächlich nicht mal gerade so hier auch noch in Frankfurt produziert werden können? Nun, ich würde mal sagen, es geht bei der Globalisierung darum nicht, das ist vielleicht was für Sinfluencer oder so, oder für Leute, die sich mit den Lieferketten auseinandersetzen. Das ist hier überhaupt gar keine Frage. Also es ist ganz interessant, sondern es geht eigentlich um Preise und Kosten.
Und jetzt ist die Idee, mit den meisten Kooperatoren, eine Rezilienz zu schaffen. Rezilienz bedeutet mehr Inflation, und Rezilienz bedeutet Duplikation.
Dann müsste man nämlich anfangen, hier zum Beispiel Milchpulver zu produzieren.
Ich frage mich aber auch, ob das stimmt.
Damit steigen die Kosten. Das ist seine These jetzt da. Aber das ist quasi die Ideologie, mit der man natürlich rechtfertigt, oder mit der seit Ricardo eigentlich der Freihandel gerecht wird. Ich würde sagen, seit 200 Jahren. Warum man, wenn die einen das herstellen, die anderen das herstellen, dann muss nicht jeder das selbst herstellen. Und dann können damit die Preise fallen. Und das stimmt natürlich gerade bezogen auf Milchpulver oder so etwas. Aber wir sind dann bei so einer ganz kleinen Gewinnmarge, aber bei genügend Partikularinteressen, die da bedient werden, sodass das erhalten bleibt. Aber sinnvoll ist es natürlich nicht. Und klimaschonend auch nicht.
Ich habe mir diesen Talk auch mal rausgesucht. Larry Fink und Robert Habeck auf einer Bühne ist natürlich irgendwie spektakulär. Es passiert wirklich nichts. Und ich war auch überrascht. Man hat ja hier so gehört, dass Larry Fink, man hört ihn ja quasi, wie er so nach oben schaut und so. Und auch wenn die anderen reden, sich total langweilt, wie man das halt so macht als so Supermilliardär, der eigentliche Chef der Welt und so. Und ich fand erstaunlich, wie lobbyistisch und aktionistisch er da aufgetreten ist für seine Sache. Also gar nicht als, ja, ich habe jetzt 100 Milliarden bewegt, ich kann auch mal Ruhe lassen und mal die Dinge laufen lassen, sondern ich fahre dann dahin und sage, also ja, die Globalisierung muss unbedingt vorangetrieben werden. Und das private Kapital, also wir, wir suchen ja auch überall Häfen und deswegen ist es total wichtig, dass jedes staatliche Handeln immer mit privaten Kapital organisiert wird und so weiter. Also voll diese Christian, also da sieht man so richtig, das ist halt, also Christian Lindner ist so der politische Arm davon, so in allen Belangen und dass man ihn, also dass ich jetzt denke, ja, wenn der nächste Jahr wieder auftritt, dann denke ich mir, ja gut, muss ich mir nicht anhören, weil weiß ich so, da ist nichts zu erfahren von ihm. Das fand ich so ein bisschen überraschend und auch schade, dass er da so gar nicht locker lässt, sondern komplett auf Mission ist.
Ja, aber bei Habeck, naja, wir werden das jetzt mal hören. Also Habeck war ja da und spricht auch mal über dieses Decoupling, das da stattfindet. Und das ist jetzt auch eigentlich das, was Lindner sagt. Auch er will jetzt so eine Unterscheidung machen zwischen den Liberalen, Demokratien und den anderen.
I see a decoupling and this is a threatening because we have to see, we are seeing a decoupling of economic growth and market driven economies and democracies. So I think we have to understand and to learn from my perspective. It is impossible to have an open liberal democracy without a market driven economy. But surely you can have a market driven economy without democracy. There is a decoupling and this brings me to WTO, to the UN, to all the multilateral organizations. We can surely find ways of better, fairer, more sustainable trade agreements and we can foster this. But we need grounds for debate what the global rules also values are.
Ja, das ist sehr gut, das nochmal zu sagen, aber da ist ja auch mehr Philosoph als Politiker, was will er tun?
Und verweist dann auf WTO oder sowas. Die Sache ist ja, die Staaten, also die WTO ist ja nicht ohne die Staaten denkbar. Das heißt, wir haben es ja da nicht mit irgendeiner, mit einem Weltrat zu tun und bei den anderen Institutionen gilt das ja auch, die einfach so da sind und die können jetzt sich entscheiden, mächtiger zu werden. Nein, die Nationalstaaten entscheiden darüber, wie mächtig diese Institutionen sind. Und natürlich wird ein jeder Staat dann wieder sagen, naja, aber nicht so mächtig, dass die unsere Wirtschaft in irgendeiner Weise gefährden können. Und auch hier würde ich wieder sagen, diese Äußerungen, ja wir erleben, dass der Kapitalismus, dass der Markt nicht mit der Demokratie Hand in Hand gehen muss. Das ist ja eine richtige Aussage. Aber das erleben wir ja nicht jetzt durch einen russischen Angriffskrieg, sondern das ist ja eine Sache, die können wir seit spätestens den 90er Jahren beobachten. Oder auch noch länger zurück, ja warum denn nicht? Also es ist ja überhaupt nicht gegeben, dass ein Markt mit einer liberalen Demokratie zusammengehören muss. Das war mal eine Hochphase, die wir so viel im Westen erlebt haben. Aber in anderen Ländern sah das ja immer auch schon anders aus.
Also es ist halt eine historische Erfahrung, die er über Jahrzehnte getragen hat. So wie der Wandel durch Handel und so weiter als Idee durchging, weil er auch ausgeblendet, was dann anderen Ländern war. Ja, aber diese Verkopplungen.
Also er macht doch gerade mit Katar und Aserbaidschanen Geschäfte. Das sind ja keine Demokratien und schon gar keine Liberalen. Und dann muss man sagen, na ja, wir haben ja für Energie, wenn man jetzt an die Ölstaaten oder so denkt, diese Rechnung ja nie gemacht. Da haben wir immer gesagt, das machen wir dann danach.
Ja, aber wir haben diese Rechnung hier in Europa gemacht. Wir hatten die Nachkriegszeit, haben Nationalstaaten gegründet. Immer mit der Erwartung. Und es porzelten ja dann auch nach und nach die Diktaturen weg. Spanien, Portugal ja bis in die 70er und so weiter. Und es sind alles Demokratien geworden im Zuge dieser Vermarktwirtschaftlichung, dieser Öffnung und dann auch dieser inneren Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Ländern. Also hatte man gedacht, das ist so ein Selbstläufer. Wenn wir jetzt die Europäische Union so richtig wirtschaftlich integrieren, können da nur Demokratien teilnehmen. Und plötzlich hast du am Ostrand so Ungarn und Polen teilweise und jetzt Tschechien, wo die ja lange gezögert haben, darauf politisch zu reagieren. Jetzt machen sie es. Jetzt drehen sie den einfach den Geldhahn zu, mit inhaltlichen Argumentationen. Aber dieses Aufbrechen, dieses Decoupling, dass er das hier auf Augenhöhe holt, wenn wir über Decoupling sprechen, dann auch darüber. Die Frage ist dann immer, interessiert die das in Davos? Weil die wollen ja nur Geld verdienen. Also das war ja bei Leo Fink ganz deutlich, dem ist ja total egal, wer da unter ihm regiert, sozusagen. Und wie vor allem. Und deswegen hat er da so einen philosophischen Spruch gemacht, der aber wahrscheinlich erstmal folgenlos bleibt. Was die Erkenntnisse, die Learnings aus Davos angeht.
Genau und wenn man jetzt ja auch sieht, dass die USA sehr stark zarte Bande knüpfen mit Indien, dann geht es ja nicht darum, da die demokratischen Kräfte zu unterstützen oder so, sondern das Gegenteil ist ja da derzeit der Fall, wenn man sich die Entwicklung von Modi und seiner Partei ansieht, sondern geht es natürlich darum, einen guten Machtblock zu haben und die wirtschaftliche Einflusssphäre auszuweiten. Also es geht hier dann gar nicht darum. Und dann wird Habeck aber ganz staatsphilosophisch und zeichnet uns jetzt noch so ein Bild.
In einem eilen Weltkrieg gibt es keine solchen Dinge als schlechte politische Intentionen. Alle Länder werden in einem multilateralen Weltkrieg und reden mit einander. Weizen nicht, haben keine Arme und nutzen ihre wirtschaftliche Situation gegen andere für eine Vorteile. Aber wir haben gelernt, wenn wir über Energie reden, ist es offiziell, aber das gleiche geht, oder könnte zumindest für Digitalisierung und Telekommunikation gehen, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Ich würde auch sagen, in einem idyllischen Weltkrieg, die Staatsanleitung oder die Ersatzteile in einer marktfrieren Wirtschaft sind immer nur die letzten Antworten eines Staats, die nur für diese Bereiche nicht die Angelegenheit und die Angelegenheit verhindern.
Wir können gar nicht in die Welt hinausschauen. Wir erinnern uns alle noch dran, wie die Schweiz Masken bestellt hatte und Deutschland als Transferland dann plötzlich sagte, ja, das können wir gerade mal nicht ausführen. Das muss jetzt hier bleiben, wo wir es gerade auf unserem Boden haben. Also da muss man nicht...
Du meinst, dass Deutschland auch schon mal...
Wenn man sich Deutschlands Politik in Europa so anschaut, würde ich sagen, das war doch immer solidarisch. Die anderen sparsam gehalten. Das war ja die CDU oder sowas, aber da muss er nicht in die Welt raus. Aber guter Versuch.
Es ist so erstaunlich und dass er dann auch noch mal ganz klar sagt, eigentlich sind Subventionen und all das, also Staatsinterventionen problematisch. Nur leider gibt es diese konfligierenden Interessen, da merkwürdigerweise, wo ich sagen würde, ja klar, konfligieren kapitalistische Staaten um wirtschaftlichen Einfluss, was denn sonst. Und dass er dann aber noch mal so deutlich macht, naja, also nur mit Zähne knirschen eigentlich Subventionen, also diese staatlichen Sachen, da ist er ja schon fast so auf so einer Art Lindner, ihn dann noch mal ins Gebet genommen. Da müsste er doch einfach sagen, nee, es geht auch um Sphären, die man loslösen kann davon, dass sie, da können sie einfach mit Blackrock kein Geld machen. Gehen sie, machen sie irgendwas anderes. Gibt ja genug Modekonzerne, was weiß ich. Aber wir wollen eigentlich auch Bereiche schaffen, wo es nicht die Einflusssphäre des privaten Kapitäts gibt. Aber du siehst es doch jetzt bei der Energiewende. Wir haben das, als wir die Neuen Zwanziger begonnen haben, immer wieder gesagt, eigentlich kann ja diese Energiewende, die auf dem eigenen Dach mit entsprechenden Panels stattfindet, ja auch so gerahmt werden, dass man sagt, es ist eine Souveränität, die man dadurch erlangt, eine Unabhängigkeit von den Konzernstrukturen. Das heißt, man kann das zum einen privat, zum anderen aber auch ganz klar kommunal, regional organisieren. Und jetzt erleben wir ja doch, dass es zwar eine Energiewende gibt, aber eigentlich die alten Player nun so ausgestattet und unterstützt, dass sie ihre Windparks bauen und quasi ihr Geschäftsmodell mit staatlichen Handeln weiterhin rechtfertigen.
Die Bundesregierung hat ja schon die Pflicht eingeführt, Solardächer auf allen gewerblichen Immobilien, die neu gebaut werden. Und da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, aber vielleicht passiert es ja doch, dass man dann das ganze Dach vermietet. Also dass die Unternehmen wirklich ihr Dach einfach abgeben, an Betreiber und das ist dann wieder RWE oder so. Weil erstmal ist das ja auch eine Einflugsschneise, dass dann die Unternehmen einfach denken, ach so, ja dann betreiben wir das auch selber. Weil das wird einmal installiert, so wie auf einem Privathaus und dann hat man halt so ein Gerät im Keller und eine App und dann weiß man genau, wo die Energie herkommt. Also vielleicht findet da dann mal ein Decoupling statt von den großen alten Erzeugern. Aber mal sehen, aber ja genau, also bei der Windkraft haben wir auf jeden Fall so einen Drang, es doch in dieser zentralen Hand zu lassen und es eben nicht zu popularisieren oder wie man gerne sagt, zu demokratisieren, sodass die einzelne Kommune dann nochmal was mit profitiert und so.
Nee, man macht eigentlich das, was very think gefallen wird.
Das sind jetzt dezentrale Atomkraftwerke sozusagen. Man hat nicht mehr den einen Standpunkt, sondern so viele verteilt, aber es ist immer noch an einer Hand.
Und dann kann BlackRock auch bei den deutschen Energiekonzernen gut investieren.
Da kann sie auch bleiben dann.
Die Zukunft ist sicher.
Da ist für BlackRock dann die Zukunft sicher, genau. Apropos Davos und China. Xi war wahrscheinlich nicht da, weil er die Hände voll zu tun hat. Er hat ein neues Thema, eine Chefsache, wie man so schön sagt. Es ist die Demografie, denn es ist passiert. Wir hören uns einmal im heutigen Journal, einmal in den Tagesthemen.
China meldet zum ersten Mal seit sechs Jahrzehnten einen Bevölkerungsrückgang. Ende Dezember habe das Land 1,411 Milliarden Einwohner gehabt und damit rund 850.000 weniger als ein Jahr zuvor gab das Statistikamt in Peking bekannt. Nach dem Ende der Ein-Kind-Politik dürfen Paare inzwischen drei Kinder bekommen. Ein geburten Boom ist trotzdem ausgeblieben.
So, das erste Mal seit sechs Jahrzehnten schrumpft China. Vor sechs Jahrzehnten, das ist dann so Kulturrevolution und sowas, oder? Also einer der größten Massenmorde überhaupt auf der Ebene.
Der große Hunger.
Da findet das jetzt statt. Also eine echte Zäsur und die Ein-Kind-Politik schon seit einer Weile aufgehoben. Jetzt gibt es Familienpolitik. Das Ziel sind drei Kinder pro Familie, das funktioniert nicht. Die Geburtenzahlen sind so niedrig wie nie, wie sie auch nie während der Ein-Kind-Politik waren. Und im Tagesthemen wird es dann ähnlich thematisiert.
Die Einwohnerzahl in China ist zum ersten Mal seit 60 Jahren zurückgegangen. Die amtliche Statistik zählt jetzt 1, 4 Milliarden Menschen, knapp eine Million weniger als vor einem Jahr. Ursache ist, nach Ansicht westlicher Beobachter, eine niedrige Geburtenrate aufgrund der hohen Lebenshaltungskosten und wirtschaftlicher Unsicherheit. Inzwischen werden in China Familien mit mehreren Kindern gefördert, nachdem es jahrzehntelang verboten war, mehr als ein Kind zu bekommen.
Statt dass das mal richtig ist. Es fällt ja auch historisch zusammen mit diesem. Und das kann man sich jetzt auch in seinem Kopf abspeichern. China ist nicht mehr das größte Land der Welt. Es ist jetzt Indian. So, Ausrufezeichen für das jetzt neues Wikipedia-Wissen für alle und für uns in Deutschland. China ist nicht mehr das größte Land der Welt. In den PBS-Nachrichten wurde das ein bisschen ausführlicher diskutiert. Zum einen äußert sich natürlich auch die chinesische Regierung. Also es ist sozusagen eine öffentliche, offizielle Kommunikation. Und danach haben sie eine ganz interessante Gesprächspartnerin.
Die weltweit die größte Population hat einen historischen Rundpunkt getroffen.
Heute hat China in sechs Jahren den ersten Populationstest geklaut.
Ja, also um fast eine Million geschrumpft. Das sind so Zahlen, die dann auch jetzt, man sieht es hier in dieser Entwicklung noch mal, ein bisschen rapider abfallen als die letzten Jahre. Also es nimmt so zu, so wie auch in Japan zum Beispiel. Diese Zahlen, alle doppelt so hoch liegen wie vorher. Also der Geburtenrückgang ist von 5% auf 10% einfach mal hochgesprungen. Hat sich so verdoppelt, was seinen Anteil angeht. Das sind schon erstaunliche Werte. Und wir kennen ja so mit Böttchen in Deutschland auch die inhaltliche Diskussion, dass die letzte Generation auch immer so eine Aura von, und wir sind auch die Generation, die keine Kinder mehr bekommt und so. Und zwar ganz bewusst. Also da denkt man nicht drüber nach und dann geht man einfach anders mit so großen Themen um.
Und wir haben ja generell die Entwicklung, dass Ländern, in denen der Wohlstand wächst, es ja so ist, dass die Geburten zurückgehen. Und das hat ja für ganz viele Chinesen auch stattgefunden in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten, dass die jetzt nicht sich von der Regierung überreden lassen, doch nochmal Kinder in die Welt zu setzen. Es gab ja, wir hatten das auch mal im Salon, so ganz verrückte Entwicklungen da in China, dass man beispielsweise K-Pop und alles, was da so dranhing, verboten hat, weil man sagte, die verkörpern ja nicht den Mann, sondern den effeminierten Mann, der sich also folglich auch nicht fortpflanzen wird. Und deswegen hat das einen schlechten Einfluss auf unsere Jugend, die dann auch gerne Kinder haben wird. Also diese ganzen ideologischen Kämpfe, die dort gekämpft werden, sind völlig aussichtslos. Also das wird nicht dazu führen, dass die jetzt sagen, ich will wieder drei Kinder haben, seit ich kein K-Pop mehr höre.
Genau. Und das kommt wirklich in China alles so geballt auf einmal. Wir haben ja durch die Ein-Kind-Politik auch, Familien mussten sich für ein Kind entscheiden, also hat man sich gegen das Mädchen entschieden. Wir haben also auch einen gigantischen Männerüberschuss, der natürlich auch wieder dadurch, dass Männer unter sich sind, zu komischen Männer-Selbstbildern und Fremdbildern führt und entsprechenden Verhalten, auf das dann wieder reagiert wird mit so einer Art Politik und so weiter. Mai Fong hat ein super interessantes Buch über diese ganze chinesische Demokratie-Misere aus Einflugsschneid, also Politik, also dieses One Child-Ding geschrieben. Da gibt es unendlich viel zu sagen. Ich habe das auch im Buch versucht. Wenn du so eine ganze Generation von geschwisterlosen Einzelkindern hast, die begegnen sich alle als Konkurrenten, weil die das gar nicht gelernt haben. Abseits des, ach so, ich kann auch in der Klasse Freunde haben, wie ich zu Hause Brüder habe. Weil wenn man zu Hause keine Brüder hat, gibt es auf Augenhöhe schon mal Solidarität, Erlernen und so weiter. Sondern man trifft auf Kinder sofort in diesen sozialen Zusammenhängen, wo es Zeugnisse gibt und stellt dann fest, ach so, der Notenspiegel setzt für uns alle einen Benchmark und dann gibt es oben und unten. Und dann versucht man sich dazu platzieren.
Und Familien, die natürlich aufgrund von illegalen Abtreibungen, aufgrund dieses Drucks doch ein Mädchen zur Welt zu bringen, es mit vielen Schwierigkeiten zu tun bekommen haben. Wir haben ja diese Massenabtreibungen gehabt. Ich empfehle auch sehr diesen Roman Frösche von Mo Jan, der ja auch den Nobelpreis bekommen hat, wo das doch sehr drastisch, aber literarisch auch ausgezeichnet geschildert wird, was es eigentlich bedeutet hat, wie diese Ein-Kind-Politik umgesetzt wurde.
Ja, also aus dieser Region gibt es sowohl interessante Literatur als auch Sachbücher. Eine Autorin ist hier. Sie erklärt mal, wie brenzlig es jetzt für China wird.
Was ungewöhnlich ist, ist, dass diese Transition auf sehr schnellen Höhen geschieht.
Das ist die Einstimmungspolitik.
Also die Herausforderungen für China, die vorwärts geht, ist, dass es schwer wird, diese Bevölkerungsdeklare zu übernehmen, weil sie diese Faktoren haben.
Ja, das sind jetzt echte Herausforderungen. Das ist noch wichtiger als, was weiß ich, Exportmanagement, Industriepolitik und wie auch immer.
Vielleicht hast du doch recht, du hattest ja, als wir immer über Taiwan sprachen, immer gesagt, die haben so viel jetzt in den nächsten Jahren zu tun, die können sich nicht noch da ein neues Spielfeld auftun.
Ja, hier stellt sich schon allein die Frage, mit welchen Soldaten, wenn du Familien hast, die seit Generationen nur Einzelkinder haben, dann hast du in dem Moment, wo die im Soldatenalter ankommen, mit 18 oder so, eine 18-jährige Familiengeschichte hinterher, wo die nicht bereit sind, auf das Kind zu verzichten. Dafür hat man sich nicht durch 3.000 Stunden Klavierunterricht gequält, um das Kind vorzubereiten für die amerikanische Eliteschule. Dafür hat man sie nicht im Sportverein relativ früh aussieben lassen und so, damit es dann einfach weggefeuert wird, weil irgendwer auf die Idee kommt, wir nehmen jetzt mal 160 Kilometer entfernt, irgendwo mit so einer Fallschirmjägerbataillon. Also das ist immens wichtig, das alles im Blick zu haben und zusätzlich zu diesem, die Familien sind nicht bereit, auf ihr Kind zu verzichten, ist auch die Politik, also wir sehen das ja jetzt gerade, wie sehr der Ukrainekrieg alle anderen thematischen Kompetenzen einfach rausnimmt. Wir haben derzeit keine Fortschritte in der Familienpolitik, Ernährungspolitik wackelt so vor sich hin. Nichts funktioniert, alle reden nur über Leoparden und so weiter und es gibt auch kein Interesse beim Journalismus für irgendwas anderes. Und so ist das in China gerade umgedreht. Dort hat man keinen Kopf frei für den Krieg, den man lieber einfach vermeiden kann, bevor man sich da reinvergaloppiert, weil man die Hände voll hat und das betont sie hier auch. Demografie ist jetzt Chefsache in China so sehr, dass Qi auch öffentlich darüber spricht.
Und für chinesische Leader, wo sie viele sehr oblige Beweise machen, war das so explizit, wie du das gemacht hast.
China hat noch keine richtige Alterssicherung im Sinne eines Rentensystems. Sie haben quasi keine Familienpolitik, weil zwei Leute kriegen ja wohl ein Kind großgezogen, aber drei, da wird es dann knifflig, da braucht man Kinderbetreuung und sowas. In China gibt es ja so Berichte, dass da irgendwie Kinder einfach angekettet werden. So, weil dann weiß man, wo sie sind und die werden den Tag schon überstehen und dann liegen da so angekettete Kinder irgendwo rum wie so Hunde. Also in der Ansicht, hier gibt es viel zu tun und es wird wahnsinnig kompliziert. Da müsste man sich echt diese Chi-Reden mal wieder im Original angucken. Er verschweigt ja Themen nicht, die ihm wichtig sind, baut uns dann eine seiner großen, blumigen drei Stunden lang reden. Und da kommt jetzt auch immer mehr diese Demografie.
Ja und das Wirtschaftswachstum lag jetzt bei drei Prozent.
Was wahnsinnig schlecht ist, wenn man eigentlich acht braucht und so.
Ganz richtig. Man wollte 5, 5 erreichen. 2022 hat er aber nur drei bekommen. 2021 Wirtschaftswachstum lag noch bei 8, 4 Prozent. Aber im Vergleich zum Vorjahr, das damals nicht so gut war. Aber generell müsste man eigentlich so 8 Prozent. Das wäre super. Das verspricht Indien nach wie vor. Beziehungsweise sind die sich ziemlich sicher, dass sie noch einige Jahre auf diesem Pfad wandeln werden. Deshalb jetzt bewegen sich viele Investoren nach Indien. Aber das ist natürlich ein großes Problem. Und das wird nicht nur mit Zero-Covid zusammenhängen, dass dieses Wirtschaftswachstum so schwach ist. Denn es war ja 2021 auch eine sehr strikte Corona-Politik und trotzdem hatte man ein gutes Wachstum. Das heißt, da kann man mal schauen, ob die das noch mal anders entwickeln. Andererseits gibt es natürlich ganz viele Sektoren, die extrem boomen. Das ist ja auch die Frage, wie viel Wirtschaftswachstum, also wie viel BIP braucht man, um so eine Volkswirtschaft zu haben?
Es ist, Issa Klein hatte auch eine sehr interessante chinesische Gesprächspartnerin letztens in seinem New York Times eine Stunde Gesprächspodcast, wo die auch noch mal dargestellt haben, wir kriegen es eigentlich aus Deutschland oder aus Amerika gar nicht richtig beobachtet, wie wir China beobachten müssten. Weil wir ja immer noch so dieses, okay, wir haben ein Land, dann wechseln halt immer mal die Regierung und so. Und dort gibt es halt eine Regierung, und die ändert einfach das Land, wenn sie es anders haben will. Also dort ändert einfach die Sozialstruktur statt die Partei. Also da ist es einmal komplett umgekehrt, was eben auch bedeutet, und das hat ja Habeck eben noch mal betont, man kann sich marktwirtschaftlich öffnen, ohne sich demokratisieren zu müssen. Und das gilt hier noch mal im Quadrat, denn die chinesische Regierung kann eben von heute auf morgen einfach sagen, ohne politische Diskussion, es gibt jetzt kein Corona mehr. Es ist jetzt alles offen. Egal, was in eurem Kopf vorgeht und egal, was ihr gerne twittern würdet zum Thema, aber wo ist meine Impfung und so. Diese deutsche Diskussion, die ist mal ganz vorsichtig und so, lieber noch die Masken auflassen. Nö, die sagen einfach von heute auf morgen, was sie jetzt anders haben wollen. Und das ist ja vorwildhaft für sehr viel. Also das muss ja nicht nur die Corona-Politik betreffen, sondern das kann genauso gut die Familienpolitik, die Industriepolitik, die Außenhandelspolitik und so weiter betreffen, dass es da von heute auf morgen einfach alles umgekrempelt wird und ein Sechstel der Weltbevölkerung einfach mitmacht, gezwungenermaßen. Einfach neu erfunden. Sie nennt hier nochmal eine ganz interessante Zahl, das ist jetzt mehr so ein Gedankenspiel, aber das ist schon zum Nachdenken.
Und die andere Teil der Sache ist, ich denke, China ist sehr unik, weil die Population so sehr mahl ist und es so sehr älterlich ist. Das Statistik ist, wenn alle China-Retiree ihre eigene Nation erwerben, wären sie eine der weltweit besten Populationen. Nachdem China in Indien, die jetzt China übernimmt, die größte Population, dann wäre China selbst Senior.
Also nur die chinesischen Rentner, und sie haben keine Rentenpolitik. Also da hat man nicht jetzt 40 Jahre gearbeitet und sich irgendwas erworben oder so, sondern die wissen nicht genau, wie sie es jetzt hinkriegen, die überhaupt durch ihren Lebensarm zu kriegen. Nur die chinesischen Rentner alleine sind nach China und Indien die drittgrößte Nation der Welt, vor Amerika und so.
Die könnten die Rentnerrepublik gründen Stefan.
Ja, und da steckt aber null Produktivität drin, die arbeiten ja nicht mehr und so. Also das sind wirklich mal Herausforderungen, denen muss man sich stellen. Besser früh als zu spät. Wir, in China entscheidet sich's noch, können für Deutschland sagen, wir sind sehr reich geworden, bevor wir jetzt alt werden. Wir hätten also gewisse Potenziale, es zu managen. Und am Ende sind wir auch nicht 400 Millionen alte Leute, sondern 20, 30. Also da Nahrungsmittelversorgung und so weiter wäre doch rudimentär. Oder Arzneimittelversorgung, wo das ist auch erstaunlich, dass das jetzt schon ein Problem ist. Mal noch 10 Jahre abwarten und so. Das muss man dann auch marktwirtschaftlich organisieren, dass die Versorgung aller Apotheken sichergestellt ist, ohne dass dann irgendein Gesundheitsminister unabgesprochen einfach mal 50 Prozent mehr Profite beim Verkauf verspricht oder sowas. Und dann wissen die Kassenärztliche Vereinigungen plötzlich, also wir müssen das jetzt organisieren oder was? Jaja, hat der Minister gesagt. Ja gut, dann machen wir das jetzt mal. Also noch kann man das einfach so übers Knie brechen, aber das muss demnächst auch alles organisiert werden. Also nähern wir uns den deutschen Thematisierung zum einen. Und das ist schon erstaunlich. Nicht nur haben wir gerade Rekordbevölkerung in Deutschland. Und wir sind jetzt alle aufgeklärt. Rekordbevölkerung und Erwerbspersonenpotenzial sind zwei verschiedene Größen. Also man kann sehr viele alte Leute haben, aber man braucht halt auch ein paar Leute, die produktiv an der Volkswirtschaft teilnehmen und nicht nur in den Sozialkassen auf Empfängerseite sind. Und da sind nicht die Ausländer das große Problem, sondern die Alten, wenn man es mal einfach nüchtern unterbricht. Sondern wir hatten auch eine Zuwanderung 2022, natürlich auch durch den Ukrainekrieg, die Maßstäbe setzt. Jetzt kann jeder überlegen, wenn er die Zahl hört, ist man eigentlich überrascht oder nicht?
In Deutschland haben zum Ende des vergangenen Jahres mehr Menschen als je zuvor gelebt. Grund ist die Zuwanderung. Der Statistische Bundesamt schätzt die Zahl der Menschen auf 84, 3 Millionen, fast 4 Millionen mehr als vor zehn Jahren. Allein im vergangenen Jahr kamen etwa 1, 4 Millionen mehr Menschen nach Deutschland als ins Ausland wegzogen. Demgegenüber stehen allerdings weniger Geburten sowie mehr Sterbefälle, was das Bevölkerungswachstum verlangsamt hat.
So eine Nettozuwanderung von 1, 4 Millionen bedeutet eine Bruttozuwanderung von zwei Millionen. Aus Deutschland ziehen ja sehr zuverlässig 600.000 Menschen weg jedes Jahr. Wir hatten also 2022 eine Zuwanderung von zwei Millionen Menschen. Hat das irgendwer mitbekommen? Wurde das thematisiert? Das ist sehr viel mehr als 2015, also wirklich krass mehr. Aber es wurde soweit alles locker weggesteckt, würde ich sagen. Man kann durchaus mal mit Millionen Zuwanderungen in Deutschland klarkommen.
Es gibt Probleme mit der Verwaltung, das liegt aber am Personalmangel.
Genau, das ist eine Verwaltung.
Da müsste man eigentlich die, die jetzt kommen, schon mal ausbilden, damit die beiden in der Verwaltung arbeiten können, wenn die nächsten zwei Millionen kommen. Aber hier hätte man ja mal die Gelegenheit gehabt, eine große Geschichte draus zu machen. Also gut, man kann sagen, vielleicht ist es gut, dass es nicht passiert ist, weil man weiß, wenn es thematisiert wird, was Friedrich Merz dann daraus macht. Der hat ja dann da auch schon gesessen und sagte, ja, ich habe da ja schon gehört, da kommen die Ukrainer und die fahren dann auch wieder zurück, wie sie gerade lustig sind.
Der Pendelverkehr.
Der Pendelverkehr, als hätten die jetzt nur noch so ein neues Reiseland für sich, entdeckt die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge. Da muss man dann immer vorsichtig sein, aber grundsätzlich zeigt das natürlich, dass wir nicht Probleme haben mit, also wir haben natürlich Probleme an den einzelnen Orten und hier werden uns Leute zuhören, die sich um diese Flüchtlinge zum Beispiel kümmern und die werden von ihren Odysseen durch die Verwaltung berichten können und man schüttelt dann nur mit dem Kopf eigentlich, wenn man das hört, aber es zeigt grundsätzlich einmal, dass Deutschland dazu in der Lage ist und das müsste man natürlich jetzt viel stärker spielen, wie sinnvoll das ist und ja auch die Frage, wie viel von denen werden also bleiben, denn wenn der Ukrainekrieg einmal endet, sind da ja nun auch sehr viele, die zurückgehen wollen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die jetzt alle sagen, sie wollen hierbleiben, sondern da wird es sicherlich auch wieder Bewegungen geben. Vor allem, wenn sie dann hier nicht entsprechend aufgenommen und willkommen geheißen werden, dass die dann sich auch wieder abmachen.
Aber wir können erstmal für uns...
Was ja auch der Ukraine zu wünschen ist insofern, wir können jetzt auch nicht sagen, wir importieren alle eure Leute und wenn ihr mal irgendwann aufbauen müsst, dann ja hat leider Pech gehabt.
Genau, also wir können jetzt die historische Sonderstellung 2022 auch vorheben, so wie 2015, damals Syrienkrieg, jetzt halt die Ukraine.
Aber wir können der Ukraine nicht die Leute wegnehmen in dem Sinn.
Aber wir können auf jeden Fall für uns mal festhalten, zwei Millionen Menschen, die nach Deutschland die Grenze überschreiten, sind gar kein Problem. Auch die AfD zuckt kein bisschen, wenn der Journalismus nicht durchdreht deswegen. Sondern es ist einfach nur, ah ja, ist halt so, müssen wir ja nicht thematisieren, nicht mal in einer Kurzmeldung. Wir können dann Bilanz ziehen, sozusagen zwei Monate später, um dann, und das wird jetzt in einer Kurzmeldung so wegnotiert, aber ja, es ist ganz schön viel möglich in Deutschland.
All die, die man vor den Grenzen hat stehen lassen all die Jahre, und das haben wir ja auch 2022 auch gleichzeitig erlebt, wirklich verzweifelte Szenen dort an den europäischen Außengrenzen, dass man einfach eine ganz, ganz falsche Medienpolitik betreibt mit dem Thema Zuwanderung. Es ist so dramatisch eigentlich.
Ja, und vielleicht kann man jetzt für den Januar mal so ein bisschen die mediale Zäsur, wie ich sie eben schon nekkisch nannte, mal nennen, denn wir sehen hier eine Wortspende vom Institut für Arbeitsmarkt- und Berufsforschung. Die sind natürlich in meinem Buch, die spielen eine große Rolle und auch in der Politik, aber im Journalismus noch nicht allzu sehr. Und wenn man mit denen spricht, ist der Tenor auch anders als Angst vor Zuwanderung oder was auch immer. Also da kriegt man nichts mit was ist Silvester gewesen und so zu hören, sondern da ist der Tonfall einfach ein ganz anderer. Und vielleicht ergänzt man demnächst diese abschließenden, aber der Arbeitsmarkt zeigt sich robust, dass man dann immer mal häufiger bei den Berufs- und Arbeitsmarktforschern nachfragt, was ist denn jetzt so Sachlage.
Das Fehlen von Arbeitskräften ist in vielen Branchen spürbar und es droht noch schlimmer zu werden, warnen Arbeitsmarktforscher. Viele ältere Beschäftigte gehen in Rente, zu wenig Junge kommen nach.
Gegen die demografische Schrumpfung müssen wir wirklich alle Hebel in Bewegung setzen. Das heißt, wir brauchen eine stärkere berufliche Entwicklung von Frauen. Wir müssen die Arbeitslosigkeit, gerade die Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit, noch weiter senken. Wir müssen ältere Menschen länger im Erwerbsleben halten und wir brauchen eine offene Zuwanderungspolitik kombiniert mit einer wirklich guten Integration in Deutschland.
Ja, ansonsten Altersarmut für alle. Selbst für die, die Geld haben, die können sich dann die Dienstleistungen, die sie brauchen, nicht kaufen, weil sie niemand anbietet. Das ist einfach dann die Schlussfolgerung daraus.
Meine Heimatzeitung, die Reihenzeitung, titelte vor wenigen Tagen noch 20 Jahre Lehrermangel.
Noch 20 Jahre?
Lehrermangel. Also man hat so wenig ausgebildet, also der Lehrermangel ist so groß, dass man das auch jetzt wohl nicht so schnell hinbekommt.
Also die Unis können auch ein bisschen mehr, wenn nicht jedes Studienfach mit Lehrer gleich mit NC 1 Komma Abi und so weiter, wenn man sich da mal ein bisschen locker macht. Also die Unis sind da sehr viel flexibler und 20 Jahre ist ein bisschen quatschig. Ich fand es auch erstaunlich, als ich mit Thomas Fernsehpodcast gemacht habe, weil er dann meinte, und er ist ja Lehrer, die Kultusministerkonferenz, die erhebt da keine Zahlen nach Bedarf. Zum Sinne von meldet uns noch mal, wie viele Geburten es gab, dann ermessen wir den Lehrerbedarf in sechs Jahren, wenn die eingeschult werden. Findet nicht statt, aber da könnte man doch ein bisschen schneller reagieren, als 20 Jahre warten zu müssen. Aber keine Ahnung, wie man auf 20 Jahre kommt. Ich habe ja ein Buch auch so, in 2023 geht es los, aber 45 hört es halt auf, weil dann haben wir Alten einfach die Lebenserwartungen erreicht. Wenn man sich die Neugeburtenzahlen anguckt, es sind ja mehr Kinder jetzt. Also der Lehrermangel hat ja auch mit mehr Schülern zu tun, dem da nicht gerecht geworden ist. Warum das jetzt in 20 Jahren? Also demografisch ist ja eigentlich alles, gerade was die Alten angeht, mathematisch evident nachrechenbar, weil alle Variablen sind geboren, außer was die Schüler angeht. Wir wissen nicht, wie viel Grundschülereinschulung wir in zehn Jahren haben, weil die ersten sechs in vier Jahren geboren werden. Wie man da einfach proktisizieren kann, 20 Jahre?
Ich glaube, vielleicht ist es aber schon die Resignation, dass man glaubt, das wird sich doch nicht so viel tun.
Das kann auch sein, dass man schocken will.
Ja, dass man schocken will. Also ich finde schon, dass man nicht nur auf der Lehrerebene, sondern die Sache ist ja auch, wir hören jetzt 1, 4 Millionen Menschen netto mehr in Deutschland und zugleich haben wir Arbeitskräftemangel noch und nöcher, haben wir jetzt auch gerade gehört. Also das heißt, wir spüren auch diese 1, 4 Millionen nicht im positiven Sinne, weil wir, also eigentlich müsste man denken, ja dann ist ja für alles gesorgt, aber wir sehen ja überall verkürzte Ladenöffnungszeiten, wir sehen wie Restaurants keinen Mittagstisch mehr anbieten. All diese Dinge zeugen ja davon, dass Arbeit fehlt, dass Arbeitskräfte fehlen und ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass sich das, also die, ich vermute, dass wir nächstes Jahr nicht so eine hohe Zuwanderung haben werden, nachdem wir das in der Ukraine weitergegeben haben. Das heißt, wir gehen dann ja wieder einer, also wir gehen dann einer Phase entgegen, wo das wirklich schwierig wird. Du hast ja mal diesen schönen Satz, irgendwann wird man feststellen, dass man Geld nicht essen kann. Wir werden schon in die Situation kommen, dass man irgendwann feststellt, dass man mit dem Geld nichts kaufen kann, weil die Geschäfte zu sind und die Restaurants machen auch erst morgen wieder auf.
Genau. Also irgendwann, letztens gab es so eine Straßenumfrage, wo gefragt wurde, was glauben sie denn, wie viele Rentner in Deutschland bekommen mehr als 3000 Euro Rente aufgrund besonders hoher Einzahlung vorher und so. Und die Antwort war dann 40, aber nicht in Prozenten oder so, sondern in absoluten Zahlen. Also die Durchschnittsrente in Deutschland ist ja dreistellig und es bekommen 40 Rentner mehr als 3000 Euro, weil sie entsprechende Ansprüche erworben haben. Was ja bedeutet, die Leute haben sowieso schon wenig Geld. Und wenn man dann noch feststellt, dass man selbst für wenig Geld wenig kaufen kann, weil einfach die Verfügbarkeit nicht da ist, dann wird es wirklich brenzlig. Also dann kriegen ja die Leute auch echt Angst. Wie jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn es einfach heißt, wir wissen, dass das Medikament für sie überlebenswichtig ist, aber wir können es ihnen trotzdem nicht liefern. Fragen sie mal in ihrem Freundeskreis, ob noch jemand was hat oder so. Dann kann er ihnen was abgeben in der Hoffnung, dass es dann in drei Wochen für beide was gibt, anstatt dass der eine sechs Wochen schafft, bis zur nächsten Lieferung und dann muss aber derjenige, der was abgibt, auch hoffen, dass es dann in drei Wochen wirklich was gibt, sonst hat er seinem Freund geholfen, dann geht es trotzdem beiden schlecht.
Ja, deswegen wühnen ja überall schon so Privatkliniken und all das. Also für die Leute, die richtig Geld haben, für die bedeutet das dann Potmanier aufmachen und dann bekommt man alles, was man zur medizinischen Versorgung oder Kontrolle benötigt.
Also da muss man sich dann richtig für vierstellige Beträge tageweise wahrscheinlich schon einmieten. Das ist dann richtig teuer. Ansonsten gilt, und das ist ja erstaunlich, vielleicht fehlt da auch mal ein pointierter Text, der das mal darstellt. Aber so wie wir jetzt gerade in Deutschland Medikamente verteilen, dass einfach die Politik aufruft, ja machen sie mal so einen privaten Flohmarkt draus. Fragen sie einfach in der Klasse nach, ob noch jemand irgendwelche fiebersenkenden Medikamente hat oder wie wir auch in urbanen Zentren an die jungen Leute WG-Zimmer verteilen, läuft nicht nach marktwirtschaftlichen Regeln, sondern nach anderen, ästhetischen Gesichtspunkten, Vitamin B ganz viel. Wer kennt denn überhaupt noch jemanden so?
Da fragt Katharina Barley mal für eine Freundin auf Twitter.
Genau, solche Sachen. Da sehen wir schon, da kommt so eine März-Idee von jetzt mal die Grenzen zuhalten, damit wir hier unser, das was wir erreicht haben, absichern können. Ne, damit hebeln wir alles auf. Also dann funktioniert auch einfach die marktwirtschaftliche Logik. Dann spielt Geld einfach keine Rolle mehr. Wir haben es ja in Frankreich und so weiter. Ich warte eigentlich noch auf die Texte aus Deutschland, aber aus Paris und London kennen wir ja diese Berichte von jungen Frauen, die auf Wohnungssuche sind und dann eben mit sexuellen Dienstleistungen bezahlen. Solche Sachen. Das sind ja alles so Horrorberichte, die vor allem Väter dann nicht hören wollen, wenn sie ihre Töchter dann in die nächstgrößere Stadt zum Studieren schicken und so. Aber das ist ja dann irgendwie Realität. Also hier steht die Marktwirtschaft selber echt unter Druck. Das muss man einfach so sagen.
Und zugleich steigen die Löhne nicht. Also ich habe jetzt noch mal mit einem Freund in Berlin gesprochen, der in so einem Callcenter arbeitet. Und ja, es ist ein Mangel, aber der sorgt nicht dafür, dass man Löhne steigen lässt. Und auch generell sagt er auch in seinem Umfeld, er kennt ja viele Leute, die jobben. Es ist nicht möglich. Es sind jetzt Zustände, dass um sich die Miete weiterhin leisten zu können und dann auch noch ein paar Annehmlichkeiten in Berlin, man würde ja vielleicht dann doch auch mal gern feiern gehen, wenn man schon in Berlin lebt, reden wir da von Studenten, die bis zu 30 Stunden die Woche arbeiten, neben ihrem Studium. Das heißt, wenn man das Studium jetzt mal auf 40 Stunden beziffern würde, wie es eigentlich mindestens sein müsste, mit Lektüre und allem, dann sind die bei einer 70-80-Stunden-Woche angelangt. Und natürlich lässt man das Studium dann schleifen, ist ja klar. Das heißt, das sorgt wir ja auch für schlechtere Ausbildung und sorgt auch dafür, dass gerade diese Phase, in der man ja eine unglaubliche Freiheit eigentlich hat, man ist jung, man ist in der Regel gesund, man ist weltoffen und all das und kann es aber eigentlich überhaupt nicht wahrnehmen, weil man überhaupt nicht das Geld hat, um an dieser Weltoffenheit teilzunehmen. Und dann kann man nur sehen, dass man sich diese zehn Jahre so wild abstrampelt, dass man vielleicht dann mit Anfang 30 in eine Position kommt, dass man zumindest dann nicht mehr existenzielle Sorgen haben kann. Aber auch das zeigt sich ja nicht. Und dann kann man den jungen Leuten natürlich immer sagen, ja, aber du wirst bestimmt nicht arbeitslos. Nun, das ist dann vielleicht auch nicht das größte Geschenk.
Genau. Was alles in allem bedeutet, Postgrowth funktioniert irgendwie nicht so richtig. Vor allem nicht, weil man einfach so reinstolpert in so ein Phänomen.
Ja, man kann nicht einfach sagen, der Kuchen wird nicht mehr größer. Und jetzt überlassen wir das mal so einem Verteilungskampf.
Vor allem, weil der Verteilungskampf... Genau, es sind eben zuerst die Jüngeren, die das dann spüren. Und es arbeitet sich dann so die Altersgrenzen hoch.
Naja, man kann ja mal so gucken, wie man so aus der eigenen Klasse oder aus der Nachbarschaft von früher oder so noch kennt. Und dann kann man ja mal sehen, wo sind da Eigentumsverhältnisse, die sehr stabil sind und wo nicht. Und dann wird man zum Beispiel ganz viele Leute erinnern, die gar nicht so was Tolles in der Schule gerissen haben und die irgendeinen Job dann gemacht haben, weil man so ein bisschen vielleicht auch verdutzt war. Ach ja, das machen die nur. Und dann siehst du aber, haben die ein großes Haus bezogen. Und dann erinnerst du dich, ach ja, stimmt, da waren ja die Eltern und da waren ja noch die Großeltern. Das heißt, die selbst verdienen irgendwas 2000 Netto und könnten natürlich niemals zu diesen Zinsen ein Haus abstottern und bei diesen Preisen völlig unmöglich. Aber weil dann so nochmal von da vorgeschossen wurde, haben die dann ihr eigenes Gehalt zum Verkonsumieren. Und dann klappt das nochmal für die. Für die nächste Generation wird dann wieder ein anderes Ding, aber für die klappt das dann auf diese Weise. Und da kann man es ja schon sehr sehen. Und das ist die Minderheit. Die meisten Leute müssen überhaupt sehen, dass sie einen Job bekommen, mit dem sie die Miete finanzieren können.
Monatlich keine Wohnkosten zu haben, befreit von extrem viel. Weil dann reicht auch das Gehalt. Aber wenn du Wohnkosten hast, ist 50 Prozent weg. Also da sieht man schon, wir kommen so langsam an in dieser neuen Gesellschaft, die wir Altenrepublik nennen wollen. Und jetzt gibt es Kräfte, die dagegen wirken. Und man muss in dem Falle sagen, auf Augenhöhe mit der Realität. Das ist ganz erstaunlich. Hubertus Heil hat abgelehnt, Verteidigungsminister zu sein, weil er schon eine Aufgabe hat, wie er gesagt hat. Und ich dachte mir so, na, ein Glück, wenigstens das nicht, dass man ihn jetzt da auch noch vergeudet und verschwendet, sondern er ist an der richtigen Stelle. Wir steigen mal ein in seine Rede, wie er das Fachkräfte-Stärkungs-Zuwanderungs- was-auch-immer-Gesetz, wie es halt so heißt in Berlin. Wenn man jetzt. Das Erwerbspersonenpotenzial mal in speziellen in Angriff nimmt und in allen Dimensionen stärken möchte. Also er hat wirklich eine sehr gute Rede im Bundestag dazu gehalten am 20. die wir hier mal durchgehen.
Frau Präsidentin, meine lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen, Fachkräftesicherung ist Wohlstandssicherung. Wir alle spüren das in diesen Tagen, in allen Sektoren unserer Volkswirtschaft. Schon heute fehlen in vielen Bereichen Fachkräfte. Ob im Handwerk, ob bei der Energiewende, im Wohnungsbau, in IT-Unternehmen oder auch in der Pflege. Das ist erst mal in der jetzigen Situation das Ergebnis einer überaus positiven Entwicklung, weil wir den höchsten Stand von Beschäftigten haben, den es je im Verein in Deutschland gegeben hat. Über 45 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland sind erwerbstätig. Wir haben auch den höchsten Stand sozialversicherungspflichtiger Beschäftigung. Aber wenn wir jetzt nicht alle Register ziehen, droht Fachkräftemangel zu einer dauerhaften Wachstumsbremse in Deutschland zu werden.
Ja, und das ist ganz wichtig zu verstehen. Es geht fast so unter als Selbstverständlichkeit. Zäsur heißt, eine Entwicklung vorher hört auf und sie geht in die andere Richtung weiter. Was eben auch bedeutet, man muss sie diskutieren und dann politisch planen und steuern in dem Moment, wo wir gerade Peak-Beschäftigung haben. Wir sind nicht gerade irgendwo, sondern historisch gesehen am Gipfelpunkt. Das sagte dann Olaf Scholz auch zurecht. Noch nie wurden so viele Arbeitsstunden geleistet. Noch nie haben so viele Menschen Sozialverzichtung. Es stimmt alles, aber jetzt ist eben trotzdem Zäsur. Und naturgemäß ist direkt vor der Zäsur der Peak.
Was jeder Börsenspekulant natürlich weiß.
Was total logisch ist.
Wenn ein Unternehmen einen Rekord hat und man aber schon weiß, es gibt keinen Wachstum mehr oder es gibt keinen noch größeren Markt, den man erschließen kann, dann ziehen die sich sofort zurück. Und dann wundern sich manchmal Leute und sagen, obwohl das Unternehmen einen Rekordgewinn hat, ist die Aktie gefallen. Weil man nicht mehr antizipieren kann, dass es besser wird. Und das tut er hier. Aber er antizipiert, dass es schlechter wird, wenn wir jetzt nichts tun.
Es ist wie in so einer Goldmine. Man findet eine Goldader, also schafft man ein Gerät zum Schürfen an und noch eine und noch eine und so. Nach ein paar Jahren haben sie ein paar Geräte angesammelt. Dann versiegt sie. Und dann schafft man innerhalb von einer Woche alle Geräte raus. Und dann ist einfach vorbei. Und das hat er hier mit so einem großen Aber. Ja, es ist gerade die beste Situation aller Zeiten. Aber wenn wir jetzt nicht alle Register ziehen. Und erstaunlicherweise nennt er hier eine Zahl. Die habe ich ja im Buch, im Cover drauf geschrieben. Ich habe sie aber nur so ganz salopp ausgerechnet. Also ich habe mir die offiziellen Zahlen der Bevölkerungsvorausberechnung des Statistischen Bundesamts genommen und habe dann einfach verglichen. Jetzt und dann und so weiter. Und dann kam eben 18 minus 11 Millionen raus. Also 18 Millionen gehen in Rente die nächsten 13 Jahre. Und nur 11 Millionen werden volljährig. Also da ist ja eine Lücke von 7 Millionen. Und diese Zahl scheint jetzt auch, kriegt jetzt sozusagen eine offizielle Bestätigung.
Das Institut für Arbeitsmarkt und Berufsforschung der Bundesagentur für Arbeit hat hochgerechnet, wenn wir nicht alle Register ziehen. Fehlen uns bis 2035 7 Millionen Fachkräfte.
Ja, 2035. Also genau mein Zeitraum. Das ist so, als hätte ihr ja meinen Buchcover, meinen Deckeltext vorgetragen hier. Sowohl was den Zeitraum als auch die Millionenanzahl begeht.
Na ja, gut, er wird einen Redenschreiber haben und so. Vielleicht nehmen die auch Dinge zur Kenntnis.
Also ich lass mich gern mal einladen, Herr Heil.
Durchaus möglich.
Aber er ist ja schon auf Augenhöhe.
Das ist jetzt die magische Zahl, 7 Millionen.
7 Millionen bis 2035. Und 7 Millionen sind, wenn 45 Millionen arbeiten, also das ist dann schon ein zweistelliger Prozentbereich minus. Dafür, dass wir bisher nur ein Plus gewohnt sind, ist das schon ziemlich hammerhart. Und er beschreibt hier auch mal, mit wem zusammen er an seiner Fachkräftestrategie arbeitet.
Und deshalb hat die Bundesregierung ihre Fachkräftestrategie im Gespräch mit Wirtschaft und Gewerkschaften Bund und Länder neu aufgestellt.
Also Bund, Länder, als große Beteiligte, auch als Arbeitgeber zum Beispiel für ihren großen Bereich. Und dann die Sozialpartner, also Arbeitnehmer, Arbeitgeber. Und das ist super interessant, weil wir dann solche Sprüche wie von Merz haben zum Thema Pascha, wo man weiß, okay, kann sein, dass er im Fernsehen gerade noch irgendwelche Opaennas, die seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr im Berufsleben teilnehmen, damit überzeugt, ihm eine Werlstimme zu geben. Aber die ganzen Handwerkerverbände, die Industrie- und Handelskammern usw. die hatte alle gegen sich. Die Arbeitgeber und die Arbeitnehmer, die in den Ländern die Verantwortung haben und der Bund, weil die alle händeringend nach Zuwanderungen suchen und dann nur sehen, also das schreckt sie ab.
Man konnte das im Übrigen ganz gut sehen, diese Silvesterdebatte, die wurde ja bei Twitter von den üblichen Verdächtigen gespielt. Aber ich fand's dann doch ein bisschen erhellend, da mal bei LinkedIn zu gucken. Dort hast du ja dann nur Leute aus Unternehmen, sowohl Angestellte als auch Unternehmer. Und da ist gar kein Verständnis für eine Debatte. Wir müssen jetzt nochmal gucken, wen wir so alles reinlassen und so weiter. Also das ist wirklich für die... Also das ist so weit weg. Ich glaube, das ist eher sinnvoll, wenn man da nochmal postet, dass man jetzt eine Idee hat, wie man Schreibmaschinen wieder an einen Mann bekommt.
Du hast ein Unternehmen, schreibst Stellen aus und kriegst null Bewerbung. Es ist vor allem so viele Handwerker jetzt mit der Werbung direkt aufs Auto geklebt. Wenn sie Handwerker sind, arbeiten sie doch bei uns, rufen sie an und da steht einfach die Telefonnummer und dann kannst du direkt den Chef anrufen und sagen, ich will bei dir arbeiten.
TikTok ist die Plattform jetzt, auf der Unternehmen Werbung machen für Azubis.
Dass Azubis zu ihnen. Genau, also die versuchen mit der Zeit zu gehen und Merz torpediert das rechts und links und naja. Aber es ist nicht nur Zuwanderung, sondern hier ist wirklich großes Win-win-win, das ist ja für die Altenrepublik insbesondere wichtig, dass wir ja auch schon Menschen hier haben, die mit einem gewissen Gemütszustand durch diese Altenrepublik durch müssen.
Und das Wichtigste ist, dass wir alle inländischen Potenziale nutzen. Das fängt beim Thema Ausbildung an. Wir haben 50.000 Schülerinnen und Schüler, die Jahr für Jahr die Schule verlassen, ohne schulischen Abschluss. Wir haben 1, 3 Millionen Menschen zwischen 20 und 30 ohne berufliche Erstausbildung. Wir müssen da ran. Das kann sich Deutschland nicht mehr leisten.
Ja, wenn man da anfängt mit diesen manchmal auch wirklich schwierigen Fällen, nicht mehr fordernd, sondern nur noch fördernd ranzugehen, sodass man sagt, also unsere Tür ist für dich immer offen. Auch wenn du dich morgen nochmal wegballerst und dann eine Woche nicht einsetzbar ist, dann kommst du halt in zwei Wochen wieder und wir schicken dich dann aber nicht weg und wir disziplinieren dich auch nicht, sondern wir machen dir das Angebot. Bist du irgendwann bereit, es wirklich anzunehmen? Dann ist es ja Win-Win für alle. Also sowohl für die deutsche Produktivität, als auch für diese einzelne Biografie. Und umso mehr gute Beispiele es dafür gibt, umso früher fangen auch andere an, diesen Weg dann mitzugehen.
Lass mich ein bisschen Salz reinstreuen. Ich war bei der Gewerkschaft, bei der IG Metall, hab da einen Vortrag gehalten in Sprockhöfel, in NRW. Und es war ganz lustig, weil wir uns in der Pause dann da unterhielten. Also die Gewerkschafter, die da waren, ich unterhielt mich dann mit ein paar Männern, die waren so um die 50, hatten Kinder. Und ich hatte während meines Vortrags ein bisschen gesagt, naja, aber die jungen Leute, wir dürfen jetzt nicht diesen faul narrativ bedienen, aber es ist schon eine andere Mentalität. Und dann fingen sie so an zu lachen. Und dann sagten die so, ja, ja, mein Sohn, der so erzählt und worüber die sich Gedanken machen. Und dann fühlen sie sich schlecht und so. Da hab ich mir früher nie Gedanken gemacht, ob ich mich schlecht fühl, mal ging halt zur Arbeit. Oder dass sie, dann sagt er, ja, irgendwas mit Mental Health. Also es war sehr sympathisch. Man hat jetzt nicht gesagt, so sind die. Aber es ist schon eine Kluft zwischen dem, zwischen den Jungen und den Älteren jetzt, sodass das natürlich auch, glaube ich, für viele Arbeitgeber, sage ich jetzt mal, durchaus eine Herausforderung wird, mit dieser neuen Mentalität zurechtzukommen. Also das schien schon ein Thema zu sein, dass da so, also alle wussten sofort, ich brauchte nur so ein paar Dinge zu erwähnen. Und alle wussten sofort so, ja, ja, genau, das ist irgendwie jetzt anders mit jungen Leuten. Und das war aber nicht böse von denen gemeint, aber die haben gesagt, das ist schon sehr anders.
Also es gibt sehr amüsante Geschichten von Menschen in unserem Alter, die jetzt in den Universitäten im Mittelbau, so in die Junior-Professor-Schiene aufsteigen. Sich eigene Drittmittel erarbeiten und da sehr erfolgreich sind. Das erste Mal als Arbeitgeber Nachwuchs suchen. Diese Millennials haben sich diesen Posten, den sie da haben, hart erkämpft. Für sie war immer klar, wir haben dieses komische Zeitarbeitsdienst gesetzt, das muss alles hinhauen, innerhalb von zwölf Jahren, aufgeteilt in zweimal sechs Jahre. Wenn das nicht klappt, stehe ich mit 45 so auf der Straße.
Und vielen Augen ringen.
Genau, und zum Glück hat man dann diese Junior-Professor irgendwie errungen, ging mit vielen Anträgen und so weiter einher und Pieperpum. Und dann schreiben die Stellen aus. Und denken so, ich mach mal eine richtig tolle Stellenausschreibung. Da hätte ich damals mich richtig krass gefreut, wenn ich so eine Stelle gekriegt hätte. Und dann kommen die Bewerber rein und mit ihren Ansprüchen. Freitags nur bis 14 Uhr, weil danach das und das. Mittwochs, morgens ein bisschen schwierig, da würde ich dann Bescheid sagen, wann ich komme und wann nicht und so. Solche Sachen, wo die Millennials da sitzen und sagen, ne warte mal, ich hab hier gekämpft für alles. Und du willst jetzt hier einfach so reinschneiden? Und die Universitäten geben sehr viel Geld für diese Mediation aus, damit das nicht ausartet. Also es gibt richtiges Coaching für diese Millennials, die in Arbeitgeberposition angekommen sind, um da intergenerationsales Verständnis.
Und da sind die, wir sprechen hier noch von alte Frauen, die eng beinahe, die gehen ja nicht hier von den Hummern, die noch sagen, Lea, ja, sind keine Herrenjahre oder so. Das würde ja der Millennial auch nicht mehr sagen. Aber da ist doch, das ist schon ein sehr weiter Fernsehen.
Dieter Nuhr erreicht keine 25-Jährigen mit seinem Fernsehprogramm. Da ist die Kluft dann zu groß und die prägt aber Deutschland. Es gibt so viele Alte und jetzt wieder relativ mehr, denn auch Jüngere und so.
Nur kommt ja jetzt noch etwas hinzu. Also ich hab ja da Sympathien dafür. Also gut, ich selbst bin ein Arbeitstier und kann das auch nicht so. Da bin ich anders gestrickt. Aber was ich natürlich nachvollziehen kann, ist, dass man doch, wenn man in einem Angestelltenverhältnis vor allem ist oder einen Job macht, um jetzt Geld zu verdienen gerade, und das jetzt nicht gleich die Leidenschaft ist, das ist ja jetzt auch nochmal bei mir ein anderer Fall, dann kann ich natürlich verstehen, dass man sagt, ja, aber das Leben ist ja noch was anderes als Arbeit. Das ist ja sehr richtig, dies zu erkennen. Und tatsächlich haben wir ja das Problem gehabt, dass wir auch Generationen hatten, die ihr Leben auf Arbeit ausgerichtet haben. Wenn die Arbeit wegfällt, ist das große Nichts da, das gefüllt wird mit dem Fernsehen. Das heißt, es ist ja eigentlich eine sehr gute Entwicklung, dass Leute nicht nur das für sich mental einfordern, damit mehr Flexibilität oder sowas zu haben, sondern ja auch eine Arbeitszeitverkürzung eigentlich wollen. Wir wissen von diesen Umfragen, das ist eigentlich der große Wunsch. Das heißt, es gibt also eine Verschiebung, dass andere Dinge wichtig sind. Zugleich haben wir es jetzt mit dieser Demografie zu tun. Wir haben es damit zu tun, dass wir eigentlich schon jetzt extrem Personalmangel trotz hoher Zuwanderung haben. Und es gibt aber ja die Forderung von linken Aktivisten und auch Politikern nach Arbeitszeitverkürzung und auch den allgemeinen Wunsch danach, lieber weniger zu arbeiten.
Während Heil die Teilzeit der Frauen ausbauen will zur Vollzeit.
Ganz richtig. Und das haben wir eben auch schon gehört von dem Demografie-Experten, dem Arbeitsmarktexperten. Also ich weiß natürlich, warum man das macht. Wir wissen, wir haben jetzt mal diese Quote bekommen. Ich glaube, ein Drittel aller arbeitstätigen Frauen werden in die Altersarmut geraten. Also die Ernte wird hoch sein. Das liegt natürlich daran, dass die nicht, oder das liegt an verschiedenen Dingen auch, dass die schlechte Jobs angeboten bekommen, Gender Pay Gap. Aber es liegt auch daran, dass die natürlich dann nicht Vollzeit arbeiten wollen können, was auch immer. Aber wie passt das jetzt hier noch zusammen? Beziehungsweise können wir jetzt, also die Arbeitszeitverkürzungen, die uns ja allen sinnvoll erscheint, ist zugleich so illusorisch wie, weiß ich nicht, das BGE oder sowas.
Also wir haben ja den Text von dieser Johanna Schöner gelesen.
In der Zeit.
Die hatte ja diese schöne Proante, eigentlich müssten sich die jetzt Rentner oder baldigen Rentner festkleben an Kitas, Kinderkliniken und so weiter, damit die Läden ordentlich funktionieren, damit deren sozusagen Produktivitätsschaffender Nachwuchs, den sie in 10 Jahren brauchen, wenn sie dann wirklich in Rente sind, da ist. Und unter dieser Maßgabe würde ich sagen, da das ausbleibt, haben wir es mit extremen Problemen zu tun, bei denen ich dann überall in Radiointerviews sage, ja, wir können ja gerne drüber reden, aber das ist ein Problem, für das vielleicht keine Lösung gibt. Also wir haben sehr viel Reichtum in Deutschland und den könnte man ja auch anders verteilen, wenn man jetzt aber nur die kleinen Stellschrauben nehmen. Also einfach nur sagen, okay, da müssen Frauen ein bisschen länger arbeiten und Männer statt bis 63 bis 65, also wirklich ausschöpfen, das gesetzliche Renteneintrittsalter, oder vielleicht sogar 66, 67. Das wird ja dann nicht reichen, schon allein, weil dieser Kampf, diese kleinen Sachen noch rauszuholen, nicht funktionieren wird. Denn am Ende ist ja das, worauf es hinausläuft, was du meinst, dass man irgendwann den Jungen sagen wird, wir brauchen deine Produktivität für die Alten. Und dann werden die Jungen fragen, was haben dir die Alten je für mich getan? Die haben mich bei der Miete abgezockt, dann haben sie mir jeden Spaß verwehrt, mir keine ordentliche Berufsschule gegeben, ich musste quasi meine Stifte und meine Lineale alles selber zahlen, um zu lernen, wie man zu fließen legt. Und jetzt soll ich für die noch länger arbeiten. Also wenn das so ausbricht, und in so einer twitterartigen, okay Boomer, du willst was von mir? Okay Boomer, willst du halt was von mir? Ist mir doch egal. So, also das birgt echte große Konflikte. Deshalb ich einmal wieder dafür werbe, dass man jetzt mit relativ viel Verständnis, auch von Seiten der Älteren, jetzt schon mal an die Sache rangeht, bevor es zu spät ist.
Eine andere Herangehensweise oder eine ergänzende Herangehensweise wäre ja zu sagen, ja, wir haben diesen Arbeitskräftemangel und der wird sich verschärfen. Und wenn man Arbeitszeitverkürzungen bekäme, sagen wir fünf Stunden weniger die Woche, dann wäre das noch stärker. Aber das ist ja immer nur unter der Voraussetzung, dass die Arbeit, die jetzt gerade geleistet wird, auch geleistet werden muss. Wenn wir jetzt über gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit sprechen, damit werden wir zum Beispiel bei Kinderbetreuung oder Pflege der Alten oder viele andere Dinge, die wir als notwendig erachten würden. Wir haben schon über Bullshit-Jobs gesprochen. Das ist jetzt aber noch nicht 30 Millionen Bullshit-Jobs, aber die gibt es. Und es gibt natürlich auch Produktion, die wahnsinnig produktiv ist, aber die vielleicht auch wenig sinnvoll ist mit Blick auf Klima oder sonst was. Das heißt, man müsste eigentlich die Arbeitszeitverkürzungsdiskussion nicht illusorisch führen. Deswegen wollte ich das jetzt mal extra aufgreifen, dass man sagt, ja, das fordern wir jetzt trotzdem mal. Das kann man natürlich machen, aber angesichts der demografischen Entwicklung ist es ja so ein bisschen aussichtslos. Man kann also diese Diskussion, die ich für gut erachte, nur dann sinnvoll führen, weil man die Arbeitszeitverkürzung verknüpft mit einer Debatte, was ist eigentlich die gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit, die geleistet werden muss? Und wo müssen wir eigentlich nicht wirtschaftlich schrumpfen, in dem Sinne, wir müssen mal irgendwie schrumpfen, sondern welche gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit sollte priorisiert werden? Und wenn dann noch genügend Zeit da ist und auch Lust da ist, bei den Jungen geht es ja dann auch um Lust, das andere zu tun, dann können die das ja noch machen. Aber zur Not habe ich ja eine Krawatte weniger im Schrank.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt hier mal einen Clip rausgesucht, der so crazy ist, mit dem wir das mal kurz unterbrechen und dann wieder zur Heil zurückkommen. Marietta Slomka moderiert hier einfach mal zum Thema Fachkräftemangel, Zukunft, technischer Fortschritt usw. und wir hören mal ihren Tenor.
Christian Benefeld hat seiner KI noch etwas beigebracht, Bilder zu erstellen, die er per Text beschreibt, etwa Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz im Stile von Van Gogh vor einer Winterlandschaft. Nach einer Minute Rechenzeit ist das Werk vollendet, ohne dass irgendjemand den Pinsel schwingen musste.
Was natürlich auch wieder mal die Frage aufwirft, welche Arbeitsplätze künftig durch solche und andere Formen künstliche Intelligenz ersetzt werden. Zum Teil vielleicht auch ersetzt werden müssen angesichts des Fachkräftemangels und unserer demografischen Entwicklung. Womit wir beim nächsten Thema wären, der Diskussion über das zukünftige Renteneintrittsalte.
So, Chet Chippity ist da und stellt uns vor die Frage, welche Berufe können wir eigentlich dadurch ersetzen? Und da würde ich sagen, lassen wir uns mal überraschen, denn Chet Chippity ist ja auch veröffentlicht worden, um das Ding immer weiterzuentwickeln. Also man hat sozusagen dieses erstmal einen Datensatz trainiert, dann so ein bisschen unsuperweist gemacht und dann dachte man sich, jetzt lassen wir uns mal auf die Welt los. Und das kennen wir ja von Google, das Prinzip. Wir wollen ja nicht nur wissen, was in den Büchern steht, sondern auch wie sie gelesen werden oder Spotify. Wir haben ja nicht nur alle Musik, sondern wir wollen auch wissen, wie sie gehört wird und so. Und jetzt lernt man gerade bei Chet Chippity, also Elon Musk und so weiter, die machen ja echte Studien jetzt zum Thema, wie nutzen das die Leute eigentlich? Worauf wird besonders zugegriffen? Sie sind alle sehr überrascht, wie viel Quellcode geschrieben wird. Also sehr strukturierte, grammatikalisch ganz klare Textformen, einfach maschinenlesbares Zeug. Und jetzt stellt sich halt wirklich die Frage, welche Berufe kriegt man damit ersetzt? Man hat so ein Team und das entwickelt Software und zehn Leute holen sich die ganze Zeit aus ihrem Dings da so ihren Quellcode, aber in den weiter, dann guckt mal jemand drüber und so weiter. Da gibt es doch relativ viel, dass man das einfach automatisiert macht. Also dass man gar nicht mehr an Personen delegiert, sondern eben wirklich an die Maschine.
Gilt aber wenig für gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit dann.
Genau, aber geht eben sehr viel für Verwaltungsbullshit-Scheiß und so. Wo man einfach nur eine Excel-Tabelle offen hat, in der man halt irgendwas reinschreibt. Also das wird so schnell automatisierbar sein demnächst. Da werden, glaube ich, noch einige überrascht sein. Und das setzt natürlich viel Arbeitskraft frei. Also mal gucken, wie das weitergeht.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob es diesmal stimmt. Also wenn man in die Geschichte zurückblickt, da hat das also seit Beginn des Bundesrepubliks dann am Ende nie gestimmt. Beziehungsweise sind einfach nochmal neue Sachen entstanden. Also das bleibt jetzt wirklich abzuwarten. Ich glaube aber schon, dass das natürlich sehr disruptiv für einige Branchen sein wird.
Das kann ja nicht anders sein. Die Mieter selbst, Open AI, unterziehen das jetzt einer praktischen Prüfung. Mal gucken, was sie bringt. Und je nachdem, am Ende ist, also was klar ist, nun das ist wie die ganze Revolution der menschlichen, körperlichen Arbeit. Aus Kostengründen werden die alles ausprobieren. Ganze Unternehmen komplett umstrukturieren, wirklich nur noch wie bei Amazon. Am Ende wird der Mensch nur noch da gebraucht, wo seine Hand in das Fach reingreift, wo die Computer reinleuchten und er weiß dann, da muss ich was rausnehmen und so, wo man diese Picker-Tätigkeit, alles andere drum herum, wird in diesem Maße umstrukturiert, dass man es automatisieren kann. Und warum sollte das nicht der geistigen Arbeit auch drohen? Wir sehen ja auch, wie weit das schon ins Künstlerische ausgeht. Am Ende wird ein Tatort Musik, bis auf die 5 Minuten Highlight, wo es drauf ankommt, vielleicht wirklich so ein Gedudel von irgendeiner Musikgenerierung. Kennt ja alle anderen Tatorts, weiß also, was in Tatort Musik ist und macht halt eine aktuelle, je nach Schnittfolge und so weiter, die dann vorgegeben ist. Also da ist doch einiges in Bewegung. Weshalb wir mehr Menschen woanders vielleicht bräuchten. Also es geht auch um eine Umstrukturierung. Jetzt hat er die Schulabgänger und Berufsausbildungskandidaten schon genannt. Jetzt kommt Teil zur Akademikerquote.
Das fängt bei der Berufsorientierung an. Über die Hälfte eines Jahrgangs macht inzwischen Abitur. Viele gehen aufgrund von elterlichen Erwartungen zur Hochschule, aber schließen nicht ab. Dieses Land, meine Damen und Herren, braucht nicht nur Master, wir brauchen auch Meister. Die berufliche Bildung muss gestärkt werden. Genau das machen wir mit der Ausbildungsveranziehung.
Das steht ja ganz groß im Koalitionsvertrag drin. Anheben der Berufsausbildung auf akademisches Niveau, Auslandssemester, Stipendien, alles das. Mal gucken, da steht der Krieg noch im Wege. Und nächste Säule, die Älteren.
Ja, wir müssen auch dafür sorgen, dass Menschen beschäftigungsfähig bleiben, auch ältere Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer. Da ist die Quote gestiegen von 60 bis 64. Wir haben vor 20 Jahren nur 20 Prozent der Beschäftigten gearbeitet. Heute sind es 61. Aber wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass Menschen gesund bleiben können, dass sie qualifizieren.
Also diese Zahlen mal wirklich, er hat jetzt die sozusagen Vorruhestandsalter genannt, 60 bis 64, 62 bis 64. Da haben vor 20 Jahren nur 20 Prozent gearbeitet. Das ganze Land ist flächendeckend mit 61 Jahren in Rente gegangen. Also vier von fünf. Jetzt hat man es auf 60 Prozent gehoben. Diskussionen wie, sollten wir mal bis 67 arbeiten, obwohl es schon gesetzlich so vorgesehen ist, muss dann auch erstmal mit Leben gefüllt werden. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass die wirklich so lange arbeiten, nur weil das im Gesetz drin steht.
um auch tatsächlich das gesetzliche Renteneintrittsalter erreichen zu können. Wir brauchen keine Debatte über Rente mit 70, sondern das Durchschnittsalter ist heute 64, aber wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass auch ältere Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer nicht zum alten Eisen gepackt werden. Die haben Erfahrung, die haben Kompetenz, die werden gebraucht.
Genau, und da ist ja die Frage, so 65-Jährige, wenn man denen einen angenehmen Arbeitsplatz bietet, arbeiten die gerne noch länger, weil die ja genau wissen, was ihnen droht. Rente und Einsamkeit. In der Ansicht hat man so ein bisschen Motivation für sehr viele dann doch dabei. Ich weiß, liebe Hörer, sehr viele, insbesondere eurer Großeltern, freuen sich auf die Rente, weil sie natürlich ein aufregendes Leben haben und viel zu tun ist, aber flächendeckend ist dieses Phänomen nicht. Frauen?
Ja, bzw. es müsste ja vielleicht nicht darum gehen, dafür nur diese Art zu verlängern, also die Art der Beschäftigung zu verlängern und die dann ein bisschen vielleicht zu reduzieren auf drei Tage die Woche, sondern man könnte ja auch hier tatsächlich die Frage der gesellschaftlich notwendigen Arbeit stellen. Hier konnte man ja mal diesen Steinmeier-Idee, der hat ja dann doch auch nachher gesagt, ja, es geht ja auch um die Älteren vielleicht. Also ich würde es nicht als ein Pflichtjahr machen, nur die Sache ist, dass wer tatsächlich mit 65 in Rente geht und Lust hat, irgendwas zu machen, muss sehr viel Eigeninitiative zeigen, um irgendwo dann zu sein, muss dann so, ach, kann ich da jetzt mit 65, da sind aber auch schon, ich hab mal von draußen geguckt, so viele junge Leute, aber wenn das, glaube ich, in ganz anderer Weise vermittelt würde, hier freuen wir uns eigentlich, wenn du mit 68 bei uns zwei Tage arbeitest. Wäre sicherlich nochmal ein anderes Klima, aber das ist...
Also auf betrieblicher Ebene gibt es das ja schon, ne? Ja, auf betrieblicher Ebene, ja. Dass man dann so einen Tag die Woche weiterarbeitet und solche Sachen.
Aber so, dass man nochmal neu, also viele Leute wollen ja doch auch nochmal dann vielleicht eine Zäsur machen, auch für sich. So und wollen nochmal sagen, ja, aber warum? Also klar, man wird da nicht mehr Herzchirurg oder so mit 65, aber es gibt ja durchaus Bereiche, in die man noch ganz gut mal reinkehren.
Gerade in der Kinderbetreuung. Jemand hat mir einen Text geschickt aus Kanada, wo man Weißenhäuser und Kindergärten miteinander kombiniert. Weißenhäuser und Altenheime. So, sich da, es ist ja, ob es jetzt Blutsverwandtschaft ist oder nicht. Die Beziehungen können ja trotzdem entstehen. Oder in Frankreich, wo ja konsequent Altenheime mit Kindergärten zusammengebaut werden. Sodass man sich da auf der Straße einfach, dass man sieht, wie die Jungen und so weiter. Nur in Deutschland ist es ja so radikal separiert, dass man alles der Familie überlässt und ansonsten in so nur halb funktionstüchtigen Institutionen zu wenig Betreuung. Und alles staut sich da auf, was dann eben auch zu den Frauen führt. Eigentlich eins der interessantesten Themen.
Aber das größte inländische Potenzial, das ist die Frauenerwerbsbeteiligung. Auch die ist erfreundlicherweise in den letzten Jahren massiv gestiegen. Aber leider nicht so sehr beim Arbeitsvolumen. Da ist es doch oft so, dass Männer Vollzeit arbeiten und Frauen manchmal und ganz oft auch ungewollt Halt sind. Und deshalb ist das Thema Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und Familie. Stichwort Rechtsanspruch auf Ganztagsbetreuung an Grundschulen. Ein ganz, ganz zentraler Punkt für ein selbstbestimmtes Leben für Männer und Frauen, aber eben auch zur Fachkräftesicherung in Deutschland.
Frauen von 75 auf 95 Prozent zu leveln, was die Wochenarbeitszeit angeht, bedeutet eben, dass man ihn so einen Nachmittag wegnimmt mit den Kindern. Das muss man erst mal inhaltlich irgendwie erklären. Da zählt am Ende wahrscheinlich auch der ökonomische Druck, ob es notwendig ist, wenn man es macht. Muss man den Frauen aber auch sagen. Das Kind ist aber auch dann gut betreut und so. Keine Ahnung, in der 6. Klasse gibt es keine Nachmittagsbetreuung. Da muss es dann irgendwie ein Vereinsleben geben oder was auch immer. Also das sind große Hürden. Und sehr viel wird da, glaube ich, auch nicht gewonnen. Denn diese Frauen sind ja, also die können ja die Berufe, die sie jetzt schon machen, dann nochmal 20% mehr. Aber damit füllt man ja keine Lücke irgendwo anders oder so. Da ist jetzt nicht sehr sektorübergreifend, sag ich mal so. Und dann Zuwanderung.
Wenn wir all diese inländischen Register gezogen haben und wir machen uns mit Macht dran, ich hab's eben beschrieben, brauchen wir trotzdem zusätzlich qualifizierte Zuwanderung, um unsere Volkswirtschaft am Laufen zu halten. Und meine herzliche Bitte ist, zumindest unter den demokratischen Parteien, dass wir einen Konsens haben, nämlich, dass wir zusätzlich zu den inländischen Potenzialen qualifizierte Einwanderung brauchen.
So, also ganz sorgsam argumentiert. Erstmal die inländischen Potenziale.
Weißbefehl hat die Zahlen am Uhr, geht.
Genau. Dann aber auch Zuwanderung ist eine Säule, die wir nicht mehr sehen sollen. Und jetzt hören wir uns mal genau den Ton an. Man muss sich Zuwanderung wünschen. Die inländischen Potenziale kann man politisch steuern, weil man macht ja Politik für Deutschland. Diese Anwerbestrategien, man macht keine Außenpolitik in diesem Maße. Also man ist darauf angewiesen, dass diese Leute auch kommen wollen. Man kann nicht nur auf Kriegsflüchtlinge oder so, die gerade mal müssen so abziehen, sondern Menschen müssen kommen wollen.
Und Deutschland ist ein Land, das auf der einen Seite beliebt ist, ist aber den Leuten schwer gemacht zu kommen. Und es gibt das Problem mit der Sprache.
Sprache ist ein ganz großes Problem. Merz und sowas ist auch ein großes Problem. Sowas wird ja international weitergegeben. Naja, er findet glaube ich schon den richtigen Ton hier.
Ich weiß, das geht nicht nur um ein Einwanderungsrecht. Wir müssen auch die Bürokratie abbauen in diesem Bereich. Das betrifft die Visa-Vergabe, die Frage von Sprachkursen. Und wir müssen eins im Gedächtnis halten. Es kommen nicht nur Arbeitskräfte, es kommen Menschen. Und deshalb werden wir Integration mit anbieten und auch erwarten können, wenn wir das miteinander schaffen können. Wir dürfen qualifizierte Zufahrende einfach bürokratisch hinnehmen. Wir müssen sie wollen. Wir brauchen eine Anwerbestrategie gemeinsam mit der Wirtschaft, um das zu gelingen. Meine Damen und Herren, der Ökonom Richard Florida hat vor 30 Jahren mal den schönen Satz gesagt, dass wettbewerbsfähige Volkswirtschaften der Zukunft drei Dinge brauchen. Technologien, Talente und Toleranz.
Ja, wenn wir Talente wollen, müssen wir auch Toleranz liefern.
Richard Florida, der hat ja dieses Buch geschrieben, Creative Industries, und seine These ist die. Und das beweist er dann auch da auf 400, 500 Seiten. Er hat sich stark mit Stadtentwicklung beschäftigt und er beschreibt dann, wie diese Gentrifizierungsprozesse stattfinden. Er beschreibt das nicht kritisch, also er möchte nicht jetzt eine Kritik der Gentrifizierung oder so etwas schreiben, sondern es ist so ein Autor, der sagt ja Kulturindustrie nicht im kulturkritischen Sinne wie bei der Frankfurter Schule, sondern Kulturindustrie ist ja was sehr Positives, davon profitiert die Wirtschaft. Wie aber kommt man zu einer florierenden Kulturindustrie? Man braucht ein Umfeld der Toleranz. Und dann hat er sich mit Städten beschäftigt und dann stellt sich heraus, in den Vierteln, in denen LGBT-Communities stark vertreten sind, herrscht ein Klima der Offenheit, was dazu führt, dass sich noch außerdem Künstler, Kreative, alles aus dem Bereich ansiedelt, weil man diese Offenheit genießt. Und dann kommt das Kapital. Dann kommen plötzlich Leute und sagen, ja, hier eigentlich ist doch gut. Hier findet man nette Leute, wenn man abends ausgeht. Es ist ein gutes Umfeld. Es gibt wenig Gewalt usw. Also kann man hier auch sich breit machen. Das heißt dann natürlich auch Eigentumswohnungen kaufen und so. Und dann werden dann oft die kreativen und LGBT-Leute und so wieder verdrängt daraus. Das ist immer diese Entwicklung. Aber grundsätzlich stimmt es natürlich, dass das Umfeld einer gesellschaftlichen Weltoffenheit eine florierende Wirtschaft mit sich bringt. Und dieses Städtemodell, was Florida aufzeigt, mal zu übertragen auf so ein ganzes Land, ist eigentlich sehr sinnvoll. Dass man sagt, naja, stellen wir sich mal vor, der Ton von Friedrich Merz wäre jetzt der einzig wahrnehmbare da draußen im Ausland. Das wäre jetzt so hegemonial schon. Da würde ja jeder sagen, alles nur nicht Deutschland.
Und Merz meint das ja immer im Sinne von, wir müssen ja unseren Wohlstand sichern gegen diese Invasoren, während die Antwort ist, nee, wir müssen unsere Autoindustrie opfern, um den Schritt in die Zukunft zu gehen, um unseren Wohlstand zu sichern. Wir brauchen die Zuwanderung, weil es Einwanderung in die Sozialkassen ist, auf Einzahlerseite und so. Also Merz ist einfach komplett diametral, er rennt im Grunde gegen den Lauf der Geschichte an und versucht unter irgendwie die Leute mitzuziehen. Es ist hochdramatisch. So, damit hat Hubertus Heil alle Pfeiler einmal umrissen. Das Gesetz liegt als Vorschlag ausformuliert da. Er hat es hier vorgestellt. Es antwortet Mark Biazic von der CDU. Er trägt so ein paar Sachen vor, die er glaubt, sind defizitär und wir denken uns, ja, aber ihr habt doch 16 Jahre regiert. Er stellt im Grunde noch mal eine Regierungsbilanz 16 Jahre Merkel auf.
Statt endlich zu liefern, verharrt die Bundesregierung weiterhin im Ampelgehampel und schafft ein weiteres Kompetenzwirrwarr, das unser Land lebt. Deutschland verfügt über 540 Ausländerbehörden und fast 220 Ausländsvertretungen, deren personelle Ausstattung und digitale Systeme stark variieren. Schon heute stehen diese Behörden vor einem massiven Antragsvolumen. Die Bundesregierung plant eine Fachkräftestrategie, aber kennt nicht einmal die Schwierigkeiten bei den Verfahren. Auf meine Anfrage an die Bundesregierung, wie lange ein durchschnittliches Visa-Verfahren dauert, antwortet Frau Baerbocks Ministerium, dass die Dauer gar nicht erfasst werde.
Das ist jetzt mehr als ein Jahr nach Regierungsübernahme immer noch CDU-Versagen. Und es ist auch in fünf Jahren noch so, dass die da schuld sind dran. Da braucht ja gar nicht anfangen, hier irgendwie sowas.
Das kann ja niemand anders gewesen sein.
Die haben das runtergerockt. Und natürlich dauert das ewig, sowas aufzubauen. Alexander Hoffmann auch von der CDU.
Vor allem die CDU, wenn was vereinfacht werden soll, im Sinne von Zuwanderung, sagen die ja gleich, ja wo kommen wir dann hin? Wie war da der? Da gab es auch schon so eine spezielle Äußerung, dass der deutsche Pass verliert an Wert. Der wird dann verramscht. Genau, der Pass ist kein Kinoticket und sowas. Die sind ja sofort dabei, noch eine weitere bürokratische Hürde aufzubauen.
Genau, also das, was er hier vorstellt, klar, die CDU hat es verhindert und er wünscht sich das nicht, auch wenn er es hier anders behauptet. Alexander Hoffmann antwortet auch für die CDU. Die darf natürlich immer mehrere Redner schicken, weil sie so einen großen Redeanteil hat durch ihre große Fraktion. Und hier kommt auch nochmal der CDU-TNOR bei rum.
Die Fachkräftestrategie, die sie vorlegen, die ist voll von wolkenreichen Formulierungen, Dingen, die sich gut anhören, aber am Ende des Tages alles Dinge, die nicht wirken werden. Und der Referentenentwurf, der ist eigentlich getragen von dem Geist und der Überschrift, naja, wir lassen mal möglichst viele rein und dann werden schon genug Fachkräfte und Arbeitskräfte hängen bleiben.
Wenn's denn so wäre, selbst da ist ja Heids Vorschlag natürlich nicht auf dieser Ebene, wir lassen die alle rein.
Wäre aber auch schon 10 Mal besser als... Das wäre ja klar.
Dass wir alle reinlassen und dann gucken, wer ist denn schon fertig? Und wen müssen wir noch rausbilden?
Und ich frage jetzt auch mal, wen, außer jetzt solche CDU-Politiker, brauchen wir nicht? Also gibt es jetzt Sektoren, wo man sagt, um Gottes willen, bloß nicht noch Altenpfleger, bloß nicht noch Ärzte, bloß nicht noch Informatiker? Gibt es irgendeinen Bereich, wo man sagt, bitte, wir haben so viele, wir könnten eher ein paar abgeben?
Und selbst wenn man ja so einen Bereich identifiziert, muss man sagen, aber gilt das dann auch in 5 Jahren noch?
Genau. Dann müssen wir nochmal in die Statistik gucken, ob die dann auch vielleicht in 5 Jahren alle weg sind.
So, jetzt an Veruska Jurisch von der FDP zum Thema soziale Sicherungssysteme.
Der Fachkräftemangel ist das größte Wachstumshemmnis für unsere Wirtschaft und das sagen uns auch alle Unternehmen, zu denen wir gehen. Und wir brauchen ja auch Wachstum. Wir brauchen Wachstum, um unsere sozialen Sicherungssysteme uns leisten zu können. Wir brauchen Wachstum, um in neue Innovationen finanzieren zu können, nämlich zum Beispiel auch für den Klimaschutz.
So, Wachstum, Wachstum, Wachstum, das ist natürlich die Semantik der FDP. Aber sie verkoppelt es eben so, wir brauchen Zuwanderung für Wachstum unserer sozialen Versicherungssysteme. Was ja verkürzt, heißt, wir brauchen Einwanderung in unsere Sozialsysteme. Schauen wir mal auf, natürlich auf der Einzahlerseite. Was glauben Sie denn? Also hätte sie sich auch noch mal deutlicher sagen können, um dann diesen Punkt zu machen. Nochmal Alexander Hoffmann, CDU.
Es soll eine Einwanderung geben ungelernter Kräfte, wenn eine Perspektive auf ein Mindestgehalt besteht von 45 Prozent der Beitragsbemessungsgrenze. Das ist eine Einwanderung, Entschuldigung, ins Sozialsystem.
So, und das stimmt. Wenn wir Menschen ab sofort mit so einer Grenze fahren, sobald sie uns zusichern können, dass sie hier 40.000 Euro verdienen oder so, dürfen sie kommen. Und dann sagt er, ja, das ist ja Einwanderung ins Sozialsystem, was ja stimmt, weil das sind ja Berufe oder so, eben wo wir dann aufstocken. Nur, das haben wir ja bisher gerne bezahlt. Wir haben ja der Wirtschaft den Freiraum gelassen, willige Löhne zu zahlen.
Das hat der Hans-Werner-Sinn ja immer betont. Da muss der Staat ein bisschen helfen, wir stocken auf. Das ist ja der Wahnsinn, dass der Staat das tut.
Genau, und hier möchte er jetzt sagen, wenn wir aufstocken müssen, verzichten wir darauf. Nur hat er das wirklich mal durchgerechnet.
Dann sollte Alexander Hoffmann sich mal für einen Mindestlohn von sagen wir 17, 18 Euro einsetzen. Zum Beispiel. Können wir noch mal gucken.
Genau, also in die Richtung. Oder volkswirtschaftlich kalkuliert im Sinne von Hans-Werner-Sinn, die ja totale Fans davon sind, dass man aufstockt. Oder auch hier Clemens Fuest und so weiter. Die sagen ja alle, Lohnpolitik darf keine Sozialpolitik sein. Wenn die Löhne zu niedrig sind, liegt es nicht daran, dass es ein Problem gibt, weil die Löhne zu niedrig sind. Sondern da gibt es halt zu wenig Sozialpolitik. Also die trennen ja da ganz scharf, was ja total bescheuert ist. Weil klar stehen erstmal die Unternehmen in der Pflicht für die, aber die sie abverlangen, dann auch entsprechend zu bezahlen. Nur in seiner Logik würden wir ja dann sagen, Deutschland hat jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder sie lassen den privaten Sektor gewähren und stocken nochmal mit zwei Euro Zusatzstundenlohn auf. Aber dafür erwirtschaftet er jemand wirklich. Also steht dann jemand in der Taunusanlage und verkauft dort den Kaffee und die Brötchen, den die ganzen Banker da brauchen. Oder wir sagen, ne, die zwei Euro sparen wir uns, aber dafür stehen alle, was den Dienstleistungssektor auf Kundenseite angeht, im Regen.
Und das passiert jetzt ja gerade.
Genau. Und das ist ja völlig undurchdacht. Eigentlich müsste er sagen, klar stocken wir auf. Für zwei Euro kriegen wir hier den Dienstleistungssektor abgedeckt. Klar machen wir das. Aber er wendet sich dagegen.
Und dasselbe findest du ja auf der privatwirtschaftlichen Ebene. Unternehmen erhöhen ja nicht die Löhne, um Leute zu bekommen. Also es wird eher die Bar zugemacht im Hotel. Ich komme immer mit meiner Hotelbar an, aber so ist es nun mal. Es wird eher zugemacht, als dass man ein paar Euro mehr bezahlt. Das ist so ein großes Versagen auf privatwirtschaftlicher wie volkswirtschaftlicher Seite, dass man es gar nicht fassen kann.
So, und bevor wir jetzt den nächsten Alexander-Hoffmann-Clip hören, es gab in der Börsenberichterstattung bei den Tagesthemen zum Beispiel diese Nachricht.
Eine Studie des Zentrums für Europäische Wirtschaftsforschung in Mannheim zufolge verliert der Standort Deutschland deutlich an Wettbewerbsfähigkeit. Mit Nordamerika, Skandinavien oder auch Nachbarländern kann Deutschland demnach nicht mehr konkurrieren. Mehr dazu von Markus Goerne aus der Frankfurter Börse.
Laut den Autoren der Studie sagt Deutschland bei der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit auf die hinteren Ränge ab. So steht die Bundesrepublik so schlecht da wie noch nie seit der Erhebung im Jahr 2006. Unter den 21 Industrieländern landet Deutschland auf Platz 18. Vorne auf den Plätzen 1 bis 3 sind die USA, Kanada und Schweden. Hinter Deutschland liegen Ungarn, Spanien und Italien. Als Gründe nennen die Autoren der Studie zu viel Bürokratie, hohe Steuerbelastung und zu wenig Innovationsbereitschaft als nachteilige Faktoren. Hinzu kämen Energiekosten und Fachkräftemangel, die den Standort Deutschland zunehmend unattraktiver machen.
Zu viel Bürokratie, zu viele Kosten. Maurice Höfgen hat das im Wirtschaftsbriefing bei Jung und Naiv sehr schön auseinandergenommen. Die Kriterien dort sind, in Deutschland musst du Lohnebenkosten zahlen für Sozialversicherungen, teuer. In Deutschland kannst du die Leute nicht einfach feuern. Innovationsfeindlich und lauter so scheiß. So auf der Ebene läuft das ab. Und jetzt hören wir mal den Alexander Hoffmann von der CDU, wie er diese Studie aufgreift und dann noch mal beschreibt, welcher Maßnahme in Deutschland den Fachkräftemagnet anschmeißen würde.
Die Welt titelt, Frau Präsidentin, sie gestatten, Deutschland für ausländische Fachkräfte kaum attraktiv. Die Welt vom 1. Januar 2023. Und die Gründe werden darin auch bezeichnet, es sind die hohen Sozialabgaben, die unter ihnen weiter steigen und es sind die hohen Steuern, die unter ihnen auch weiter steigen. Man denke nur an die Erhöhung der Erbschaftssteuer durch die Hintertür. Das sind die Ansätze, die sie wählen müssen und dann erzielen sie einen merklichen Effekt im Bereich Fachkräftezuwanderung und nicht durch wohlfeile Worte.
Genau, das ist das Hauptproblem. Die Fachkräfte sagen sich nämlich, wenn ich hier mal 3 Millionen verdiente, dann wäre es ja dumm, wenn ich es dann besteuern müsste beim Vererben.
Das ist so schräg.
Das liegt auf der Hand.
Es ist unglaublich, sich das überhaupt zu trauen.
Wenn wir wissen, dass unsere ukrainischen Flüchtlinge schon, dass wir diese Erbschaftssteuer haben, werden die dann freiwillig wieder abziehen und sagen, um Gottes Willen, hätten wir das vorher gewusst.
Es ist absurd.
Aber das ist ja so eine Rhetorik, das ist ja schon so wie AfD, wenn es eigentlich um Insektenschutz geht, dass die dann noch mal sagen, aber 2015 diese unkontrollierte Einwanderung. Man macht einfach sein Thema unabhängig vom eigentlichen Tagesordnungspunkt.
Er kann ja als Opposition alles behaupten. Es fließt ja nicht ein in irgendeine Gesetzgebung oder so.
So schlicht vorgetragen, es ist meine Güte, dass wir von so Leuten regiert werden.
Aber ich habe so ein bisschen durch die Bundestagswoche geswitcht. Wir kommen leider heute zeitlich nicht mehr dazu, über Ernährung zu reden. Diese Bundestagsdebatten heben wir uns auf, die jetzt im Januar stattfanden. Es ist absurd, wie derzeit, wo ja, keine Ahnung, Cem Özdemir die 60 Amtskollegen der Welt zu sich einlädt, eine große Konferenz macht, die EU sich jetzt für das fünfte Insekten-Ding zur Zulassung entscheidet und der ganze Kram. Man immer noch diese bayerisch sprechenden Bauern von der CSU im Bundestag hören zu irgendeinem Scheiß. Also diese Proanten werden wir uns alle noch anhören, spätestens dann im Februar. Zum Abschluss dieser Debatte aus dem Bundestag, bevor sie mit noch drei Clips abschließen, die Jurisch von der FDP, kommt noch mal auf das Punktesystem zu sprechen. Und ich finde, wir sollten hier noch mal rückkoppeln. So insgesamt, man stellt immer diesen Ausländern total viele Ansprüche. Habe bitte diese Ausbildung, sprich bitte Englisch, usw. Und ich denke mir, so ein paar Sachen kann man ja dann auch mal auf Deutschland anwenden. Sie nennt hier eins im Konkreten.
Dieses Punktosystem muss flexibel ausgestaltet sein. Es muss atmend sein. Es muss bedarfsorientiert sein. Wir brauchen zielführende Kriterien, wie zum Beispiel englische Sprachkenntnisse. Wir brauchen eine hohe Gewichtung von praktischer Berufserfahrung. Wir sollten auch die Kompetenz eines mit ausreisenden Ehegatten mit abfragen.
Ja, das sollten wir mal für Deutschland anwenden. Also man kommt mit, übrigens, ich möchte gerne in Deutschland arbeiten, ich bringe die und die Fachkenntnisse mit, ich spreche Englisch und ich habe auch einen Lebenspartner, der auch hier sich sozusagen... Jetzt fordere ich aber von der Ausländerbehörde, dass sie bitte mit mir Amtssprache Englisch mal haben, damit ich hier nicht erst schon am Anfang scheitere. Außerdem würde ich mir gerne wünschen, dass nicht nur mein Lebenspartner, den ich mitbringe, auch produktiv ist, sondern ich möchte, dass neben der Ausländerbehörde auch das Sozialamt mir gleich mal Hilfe bei Unterstützung für Wohnung oder sowas, also diese Verkopplung. Weil das ist ja das eigentliche Problem, dass wir hier so einen Behördenapparat haben, der so streng nach Vorschrift immer noch so, wie Michael Friedmann das in seinem Buch, man kommt halt so hin und ist dann komplett diesem Stempel ausgeliefert.
Der Willkürherrschaft dann auch einzelner Beamte.
Genau, in dem Fall ist es ja.
Wir haben ja auch diese ganzen Abschiebungsverfahren, die unendlich viel Geld kosten, Personal fressen ohne Ende und dann noch irgendwelche merkwürdigen Richter, die dann, glauben sie, verteidigen das Abendland da mit jedem Urteil.
Wir haben da viele, viele Probleme und wir hören uns zum Ende drei pointierte Clips an. Zum einen, und das finde ich absurd, wie hier über die Rentenkasse berichtet wird. 2, 1 Milliarden Euro Überschuss zum Jahresende, so die Erwartung von Gundula Rosbach, Präsidentin der gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung. Der Nachrichtenagentur DPA sagte sie, vor einem Jahr sei noch ein Milliardendefizit vorhergesagt worden. Doch trotz mehrfacher Krisen sei der Arbeitsmarkt in Deutschland stabil. Und, so Rosbach, dementsprechend sei die Einnahmelage gut. Das liege auch an der erheblichen Zuwanderung, die es in den vergangenen Jahren gegeben habe. So, Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag, 28.12. also zwischen den Jahren wird es so weggedudelt. Rentenkasse macht Überschuss, Chefin der Rentenkasse freut sich, zwei Milliarden werden verbucht. Klar, man kann jetzt einfach den Bundeshaushaltszuschuss einfach einpreisen und sagen, oh, da sind aber zwei Milliarden übrig geblieben. Wir zahlen in Deutschland ungefähr 350 Milliarden Rente aus, nehmen aber über die Lohnnebenkosten nur 250 Milliarden, also ganz grob gerundet jetzt ein, da fehlen also 100 Milliarden. Das sind Zuschüsse aus dem Bundeshaushalt. Wenn man dann am Jahresende einfach verkündet, ja, zwei Milliarden Überschuss, würde ich sagen, nee, wir sind immer noch bei 100 Milliarden Defizit, aber zumindest in Nennenswert, weil nicht mehr 0, % oder so, gibt es mal ein kleines so zu vermelden. Aber es bleibt ein krass defizitäres Geschäft, das auch immer weiter ausgebaut werden muss. Jedes Jahr braucht es diese Bundestagsdebatte, Haushaltsdebatte und so, wo dann erklärt wird, ja, klar, gehen wir jetzt von 117 auf 121 Milliarden Zuschuss und so weiter. Also wir haben ein krass defizitäres System hier, das natürlich so wie es finanziert ist, ich finde es nicht schlecht, aber man sollte das dann auch nicht so verschleiern unter so 2 Milliarden Überschuss und so ein Scheiß. Du hast es vorhin schon angesprochen, die Altersarmut, Androhung für Frauen, ist in Deutschland wirklich schlimm. Das ist hier in der Nachrichtenlage 15 Milliarden.
Benötigte man mindestens 50 Talkshows zu. Also das ist ja so gravierend, also wenn ich nochmal, wir müssen es nochmal sagen, mit diesem Silvester, ja, das ist irgendwo in Neukölln, 99 Prozent der Deutschen waren noch nie in Neukölln. Weiß ich nicht, das ist ja, also im Zweifelsfall ist es vielleicht auch nur Neukölln.
90 Prozent der Berliner waren noch nicht in Neukölln.
Oder es ist noch vielleicht ein Berlin-Thema, aber wir haben, wir bekommen so eine Zahl gemeldet und es müssten ja eigentlich alle Alarmglocken laut schellen, denn das bedeutet ja, also man, jeder kennt jemanden oder ist es selbst?
Genau, also wir hören uns das mal an hier, es ist natürlich nur eine 32 sekundige Kurzmeldung.
In Deutschland droht mehr als jeder dritten Frau mit einer Vollzeitstelle auch nach 40 Arbeitsjahren eine Rente von unter 1000 Euro im Monat. Das ist das Ergebnis einer Anfrage der Linken beim Bundesarbeitsministerium, über das das Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland berichtet. Betroffen seien 2, 7 Millionen Vollzeitbeschäftigte Frauen. Um auf eine Monatsrente von 1000 Euro netto zu kommen, müssen Beschäftigte derzeit 40 Jahre lang durchgehend 2844 Euro brutto im Monat verdienen.
Das ist ja noch schlimmer, als ich eben sagte. Ich hab da eben noch die Teilzeit mit reingenommen. Die spielt ja hier gar keiner runter. Dann wär's ja noch alles verrückt. Es geht ja wirklich darum, dass Vollzeitbeschäftigte 40 Jahre und die müssen durchschnittlich 2800 brutto verdient haben, damit man da drüber kommt. Das heißt, da sind die Löhne deutlich drunter. Und das versteh ich nicht, warum das nicht das große Thema ist. Und dann würde man ja auch mal sehen, was so verdient wird nochmal.
Das ist ja auch...
wie war das der... Ich glaub, es sind schon... Ich glaub, das Haushaltseinkommen, wenn das bei 5000 liegt, dann ist das schon das oberste 5. Es ist nicht so, dass viel verdient wird.
Genau, der Spitzensteuersatz greift so früh, dass es irgendwie 35% der Einkommen schon betrifft. Und da könnte man ja nochmal irgendwie Spielraum schaffen oder wie auch immer.
Nach oben kann man da gehen.
Wirklich crazy, dass man...
Man sieht einfach, wie wenig verdient wird. Auch das ist so eine interessante Debatte, die so wenig geführt hat, dass man einfach sagt, wie wenig auch verdient wird. Also klar, wir sind ein reiches Land. Und da sind diese Vermögensberge und die werden immer schön weiter möglich steuerfrei vererbt. Aber man kann auch einfach festhalten, es wird sehr wenig verdient. Und da ist auch nicht mit... Ja, dann muss man da mal... Man kann da ja mal sparen oder man gibt nicht so viel Geld aus. Da ist überhaupt gar keine große Reichweite. Genau, nicht beim Einkommen, beim Vermögen schon.
Aber Vermögen wird ja nie thematisiert. Es gab letztens einen sehr guten Tweet, über den könnte man... Es ist genau die richtige Darstellung des Problems. Wenn jetzt Elizabeth Warren oder so vorstellt, wir können ja mal eine Vermögenssteuer, die jährlich erhoben wird, wenn man über den und den Betrag liegt, muss man 1% bezahlen. Jetzt liegen ja die Renditen auf hohe Vermögen durch die Vermögenspreisinflation und so weiter bei ungefähr 13%. Also du könntest sogar eine Vermögens- also wenn du jetzt sagst, alle Vermögen über 50 Millionen Euro werden besteuert pauschal auf die Substanz. Also richtig was abgeschöpft. Wenn du 12% Steuer erhebst, verzeichnen die immer noch einen Gewinn. Das ist ja die Realität. Weil die Kapitalerträge entsprechend sind. Und dass man da nicht zugreift, ist wirklich grotesk. Jetzt gibt es im Gegenentwurf natürlich solche Programme wie von den Linken. Ich hab ja für das Buch oder auch für den Blättern die ganzen Parteiprogramme da gelesen. Und die Linken haben ja so ein ganz verträumtes... Jeder sollte die Rente bekommen, die er will. Und zur Not wird das eben, und das finde ich besonders verwerflich bei den Linken, dass sie da gar nicht groß differenzieren, wird das eben aus Steuereinnahmen finanziert. Wo ich sage, nein, sagt auch wenigstens Staatseinnahmen, damit zumindest Schulden mit einer Rolle spielen können. Sondern, nee, die wollen es natürlich irgendwen wegnehmen, was absolut nirgendwo hinführt in so einer Diskussion. Jetzt fragt man sich, wer macht denn so eine verträumte Politik? Gibt es wirklich irgendwelche Leute, die so, jemand sagt, keine Ahnung, können wir nicht einfach das Renteneintrittsalter abschaffen? Ja, also so auf der Ebene. Und stellt sich heraus, ja, solche Politik wird tatsächlich gemacht, und zwar ganz populistisch, um da auch Wählerstimmen zu generieren.
Die Rentenpolitik ist in allen Industriestaaten eine zentrale Frage. So sieht es auch der türkische Staatspräsident Erdogan, der befürchtet wohl bald selbst vom Volk in Rente geschickt zu werden. Also macht er ihm vor der Wahl noch ein Geschenk. Das Mindestalter für den Eintritt in die Rente soll abgeschafft werden.
Die Tür der Renten- und Sozialkasse im Istanbuler Stadtteil Unkapani ist geschlossen. Mittagspause. Trotzdem bildet sich auf dem Gehweg eine Schlange. Ganz vorne wartet Murat. Der 49-jährige Spielwarenverkäufer arbeitet seit er 13 ist. Er ist hier, weil er wissen will, ob er jetzt in Rente gehen darf.
Eigentlich ist es mit 49 Jahren noch zu früh, ich weiß.
Aber wenn der Staat einem diese Möglichkeit bietet, sollte man sie auch in Anspruch nehmen, nicht wahr?
Lange Warteschlangen wie hier werden aus vielen Orten gemeldet, seit Staatspräsident Erdogan angekriegt hat, das Renteneintrittsalter abzuschaffen. Das betreffe laut Erdogan gut zwei Millionen Menschen. Bisher konnten Frauen mit 58 Jahren in Rente gehen, Männer mit 60. Ab Mitte Januar zählt dann nur noch gearbeitete Zeit. 7200 Tage berechtigen dann zum Renteneintritt. Hier in der Schlange kommt das gut an, zum Beispiel bei der 54-jährigen Fatima.
Klar freut es mich, ich hätte sonst noch drei Jahre warten müssen. Mein Mann ist in Rente, aber was nützt ein einziges Rentengehalt? Und dennoch, Gott segne Taib Erdogan.
Das sind so Maßnahmen, 7200 Arbeitstage. Ich habe mir vor, man würde das machen. Du würdest alle in so eine Biografiebilanzierung wie in diesem Wissenschaftszeit-Arbeitsgesetz reinzwängen. Da habe ich immer noch mal drei Wochen eine halbe Stelle gehabt und da noch mal und so.
Aber die Rente wird ja schon so berechnet mit Arbeitstagen.
Naja, du kriegst diese Rentenpunkte zugeschrieben für Beitragsjahre. Du kriegst ja jährlich von deiner Rentenversicherung so einen Brief, wo drin steht, so und so weiter. Ich glaube, in Deutschland ist es so, wenn du 45 wirst, wirst du zum Gespräch eingeladen, um deine Biografie mal vorzustellen. Und dann gucken die mal so im Gespräch mit dir, haut das denn so hin, wo hatten sie denn mal Lücken, über was müssen wir noch mal reden und so. So kann man das organisieren. Aber jetzt 7200 Arbeitstage abzurechnen, um zu gucken, ob es nicht doch 7150 waren und so, ist völlig absurd.
Aber das wird ja sowieso auch davon abgesehen ein Fiasco.
Ja, also er nimmt sich damit jetzt wirklich auch, also klar, die Türkei hat eine andere demografische Lage, da gibt es junge Menschen und die haben eine Alterspyramide und keine Urne. Aber du nimmst halt wirklich sehr viel Erfahrung und so aus dem Berufsleben einfach raus.
Und vor allen Dingen sehr abrupt. Und das ist doch ein Kredit für die nächste Wahl, der da aufgenommen wird, aber doch nicht für eine nachhaltige Wirtschaftsperspektive.
Es ist wirklich nicht sehr klug insgesamt, weil schon allein mit dem, wir diskutieren das gar nicht vorher, sondern ich verkünde das einfach, dann hast du ja in den Menschen sofort diese Erwartung, dass das auch geht, aber du hast das gar nicht geprüft. Also jetzt geht das erst mal so ein Jahr, jetzt laufen die, stehen die da alle an, da werden so Gespräche in den Amtszimmern geführt, man weiß noch gar nicht genau, wie man das jetzt abrechnet, also wie weist man das nach? Das ist einfach dumm, das so zu machen. Vor allem unter der Maßgabe, wir schaffen jetzt das Renteneintrittsalter ab, aber faktisch gesehen hast du ja trotzdem eins, weil du kannst ja 7200 Arbeitstage auf die Jahre runterrechnen und dann kommt ja eine Jahreszahl raus, die du gearbeitet haben musst. Und in der Ansicht ist das ja, das ist so richtig populistische Scheißpolitik, wo so ein Volk einfach an der Nase herumgeführt wird und das extrem viel Arbeit für sehr viele Behörden und Familien macht, die jetzt darüber nachdenken, ob das geht oder nicht. Und am Ende kommt dann nichts darum. Aber es geht halt. Also du kannst so einen linken Wahlzettel dann doch mal irgendwie einfach in die Welt schießen und hoffen, dass es irgendwie aufgeht.
Nun war es aber ja doch so, dass hier diese Rentendebatte im Januar dann doch immer wieder so bei Twitter geführt wurde von irgendwelchen FDP-Leuten, die sagen, aber jetzt, wenn wir mal die Aktienrente haben, dann wird das ja schon alles gut werden. Ich meine, wir reden ja, egal wie man dazu stehen will, von solch einem Kleckerbetrag, da kann man ja auch nicht davon ausgehen, dass man damit das Ganze saniert.
Ja, also ich war ja angefragt für die 13 Fragen zum Thema Aktienrente. Die Sendung ist jetzt auch veröffentlicht. Ich habe sie mir noch nicht angeschaut.
Aber du warst nicht zu Gast dort.
Ich war nicht zu Gast. Ich werde es mir noch anschauen jetzt die Woche. Ich bin noch sehr interessiert, wie sie diskutieren. Weil meine Vermutung war so ein bisschen, die führen ja dann sehr ausführliche Vorgespräche, also mit mir so eine dreiviertel Stunde oder so. Die fand das ja auch alles sehr interessant. Die hat sich auch sehr ausführlich erklärt und entschuldigt dafür, dass ich jetzt nicht eingeladen wurde. Aber es ist ja immer die Frage, treffen dort zweimal drei Leute aufeinander, die gegeneinander argumentieren? Oder stellt man sich die ganze Zeit die Frage, lieber Sender, liebes Funk, liebe Moderatoren, was ist denn das für eine Frage, die überhaupt in den Raum stellt? Also dass man gar nicht auf innerliche Opposition geht, sondern so eine allgemeine Medienkritik zum Thema, ja klar macht die FDP jetzt gerade Aktienrente und nimmt auch mal 10 Milliarden Verschuldung in den Raum. Aber habt ihr mal drüber nachgedacht, wie sinnvoll es ist, jetzt zu diskutieren, dass Menschen in 65 Jahren das erste Mal eine Auszahlung kriegen? Also welches Problem löst das eigentlich gerade und so? Da ist ja Deutschland schon dreimal dekarbonisiert, bis das erste Mal, wenn jetzt jemand anfängt, eine Aktienrente aufzubauen, dann in... Ja, es geht ja wirklich ab Lebens, also mit Geburt sozusagen, ist das ja in Planung. Und lauter solche Sachen. Oder eben, wenn man das ganze deutsche Vermögen, also das bewegte Vermögen zum Thema Alterssicherung nimmt, also diese 350 Milliarden, was ist denn, wenn Deutschland jetzt 350 Milliarden am Kapitalmarkt investiert? Also wie läuft denn sowas ab? Geht man dann zu Blackrock und die machen das schon und verstecken das so ein bisschen? Wie generiert man denn die Sicherheit, die man da garantieren möchte? Naja, Norwegen hat halt den Vorteil, das ist ja für die Spielgeld sozusagen. Die nehmen das ja nicht aus dem laufenden Betrieb. Also die reduzieren ja nicht ihre Umlageneinzahlung, um dann Geld für den Kapitalmarkt zu haben, sondern die pumpen halt einfach Öl aus dem Boden, verkaufen das und nehmen das Geld.
Und haben damit diese holländische Krankheit abgefedert, dass sie nicht dieses Geld...
Genau, also die führen das ja gar nicht erst in ihren Wirtschaftskreislauf ein, sondern das ist leicht an vorbei. Das geht natürlich alles und dann schafft man auch über 40 Jahre eine Billion aufzubauen. Aber was ist die Zielsetzung für Deutschland? Also Deutschland hat ganz konkret ein Problem die nächsten 40 Jahre. Deutschland hat kein strukturelles Problem mit der Umlagesystem, also mit dem Umlagesystem, sondern das Umlagesystem selbst kommt halt durch die Empirie einfach in die Schieflage, aber eben nur für 20 Jahre. Und zwar die nächsten. Also beginnend jetzt, 2023. Wenn man jetzt anfängt mit Aktienrenten...
Ich ahne, warum du nicht einzigen geraten wurdest. Du hattest wahrscheinlich die Sendung so ausgehebelt und das ist natürlich immer die größte Angst an den Fernsehmachers.
Die Moderatoren wollen schon, dass ihre Fragen ernst genommen werden und das ist natürlich bestätigt.
Die Frage stellt sich, ob die Frage überhaupt die richtige ist. Das ist glaube ich auch das absolute Tabu in jeder Talkshow. Du hattest es einmal vorgeführt mit Clara Hinrichs die einfach zurückfragen. Und das ist glaube ich einfach verboten. Also ich würde so weit gehen, man darf alles sagen, nur man darf nicht die Frage zu fragen.
Also ich schaue mir die Sendung aber gerne an.
Ines Schwertner war zu Gast, also das habe ich gesehen.
Also wir werden sowieso nochmal auch hier im Podcast über der Aktienrente sprechen. Allein weil die FDP im Namen Christian Lindners ja immer gesagt hat, keine Verschuldung, keine Verschuldung, keine Verschuldung. Außer für den Anfangsschub der Aktienrente, da wollen sie ja 10 Milliarden Verschuldung akzeptieren. Das ist ja der einzige Punkt, wo die FDP laut Programm Verschuldung akzeptiert, dass man die Aktienrente anstattkriegt. Und da gibt es doch diesen Spruch der letzten 500 Jahre, dass man sagt, Aktien nicht auf Pump kaufen, oder? Und genau das macht die FDP jetzt da. Also es ist wirklich grotesk, was wir hier sehen. Aber ja, ich hätte es gerne in dieser Sendung da mal dargestellt. Aber gut, bei nächster Gelegenheit vielleicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Wir haben gar nicht mehr so viel Zeit. Ich würde aber gerne ein Thema noch aufgreifen, und zwar das Thema Wissenschaften. Mai Thi von dem Kanal Mailab war zu Gast in Sternstunde Philosophie. Und das Gespräch plätschert erst so dahin. Aber dann passiert da was ganz Erstaunliches. Man könnte es jetzt auch übertiteln mit Wolfram Eilenberger zerstört Mailab. Also es ist ganz merkwürdig. Und ich habe es deswegen auch in aller Ausführlichkeit mitgebracht. Weil wäre, glaube ich, hier nicht nur das Problem bei dem Content von MyTea betrachten können, sondern auch vielleicht ein generell gesellschaftliches Problem. Wir leben also jetzt wie Wolfram Eilenberger, der Moderator von Sternstunde Philosophie, Fragen stellt zum Wissenschaftsverständnis von MyTea. Wir wissen das ja, sie hat ja diese eigene Sendung jetzt, in der sie dann auch irgendwelche Lieder singt, was wissenschaftlich ist und was nicht wissenschaftlich ist. Na ja, es ist ein ziemlicher Klamauk. Aber man kann natürlich in Sternstunde Philosophie im Schweizer Fernsehen jetzt ganz anders eigentlich darüber reden. Und wir müssen auch nochmal die Situation uns klar machen, das ist jetzt Bildungsfernsehen. Sie richtet sich an Jüngere, aber macht ja auch da eigentlich Bildungsfernsehen. Sie steht jedenfalls nicht irgendwo auf einem Marktplatz und wird jetzt angebrüllt von irgendjemand, der sagt, Bill Gates will uns ja eh nur chippen oder so. Also wir sind hier in einem ganz anderen Diskursrahmen und jetzt hören wir mal rein.
Ich glaube, es war die erste Sendung auf dem Kanal NeoZTF. Und da blendeten sie einen Politiker ein, der sagte, Armin Laschet war das, ein CDU-Politiker, die Wissenschaft gibt es nicht. Das ist an sich ein trivialer Satz, weil man sagt, ja okay, es gibt verschiedene Wissenschaften, aber sie sind dann schon so weit gegangen, zu sagen, doch, es gibt die Wissenschaft, es gibt zum Beispiel drei Prinzipien, die für alle Wissenschaften gelten. Das ist Orkheims Razor, dass man die Erklärungsmodelle so hält, dass sie möglichst wenig Annahmen haben. Dann gibt es die falsifikation, es muss zumindest sinnvoll genug sein, um falsch zu sein. Das heißt, ein Satz muss sich an der Wirklichkeit messen können. Und da haben sie schon sehr klar gesagt, was Wissenschaft aus ihrer Sicht ist, und dass es doch so etwas gibt, wie die wissenschaftliche Methode.
So, gibt es die wissenschaftliche Methode? Das ist jetzt die Frage, die Wolfram Alenberger aufwirft. Okham's Rasiermesser wurde hier schon angesprochen. Also diese Idee, kann man ja erst mal nachlesen, Jahrhunderte alt, dass man darauf achten sollte, dass man nicht mit zu vielen Variablen arbeitet. Und dass man die wissenschaftliche Lesung, die einfachste Erklärung bevorzugt, diesen Weg bevorzugt. Und jetzt hören wir die Antwort.
Nicht ganz, also ich hab gesagt, es gibt zum Beispiel kritisches Denken. Und da wäre jetzt Occam's Razor ein Beispiel dafür. Ähm, so ähnlich komme ich im Buch auch raus. Da hab ich, also es gibt wissenschaftliches Denken. Ich hab, ich, ist natürlich alles nicht sehr, ähm, nicht sehr scharf definiert, wie jetzt im Naturwissenschaftliches Gesetz, aber es gibt kritisches Denken.
Also sie sagt jetzt einmal, es gibt kritisches Denken, aber es gibt wissenschaftliches Denken. Also kritisches Denken ist ja noch nicht gleich ein wissenschaftliches Denken. Wenn ich kritisch über einen Film nachdenke, denke ich nicht wissenschaftlich darüber nach. Jetzt wird man auch dort Beweise anführen können, aber viele Beweise sind nicht in dem Sinne da, wie sie in einem, sagen wir, biologischen oder chemischen Experiment sein können. Also ich kann sagen, Leonardo DiCaprio spielt gut in Avatar. Das ist eine falsche Aussage, weil der nicht mitspielt. Aber wenn ich sage, Sigourney Weaver spielt gut in Avatar, dann magst du mir zustimmen oder nicht. Oder wenn ich sage, die Ideologie des Films ist problematisch. Ja, es ist ein kritisches Denken, aber da gehen schon die Sachen durcheinander. Aber das ist ja noch nicht so schlimm. Wir gehen jetzt mal weiter, worauf sie so hinaus will, wie Wissenschaften wohl funktionieren.
Es gibt so was wie eine wissenschaftliche Streitkultur. Das ist jetzt, wenn man es genau nimmt, einfach eine Behauptung von mir, aber die ich eben wahrnehme, wenn ich sage, wenn ich in die wissenschaftlichen Communities reinschaue, dann ist das selten, wenn ich sogar nie reflektiert in der medialen Diskussion, die viel mehr auf Konflikt aus ist, weil da auch ein gewisser Unterhaltungswert drin ist und so. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass in der wissenschaftlichen Community gibt es so einen Ringen um eine Weiterentwicklung des Konsenses.
Ein Forschungsethos, könnte man sagen.
Ja.
Das ist auch nicht die Erfahrung, die Studenten machen, wenn die Auftragungen sind, wo die Profisone auch mal miteinander reden. Da wird es heikel.
Da wird es sehr heikel. Sicherlich gibt es wissenschaftlichen Konsens. Nehmen wir die Klimaforschung, ja, es gibt den Klimawandel. Aber wenn man dann spezieller wird, gibt es natürlich einen sehr starken Dissens.
Ja, wir lesen z.B. im Salon einen Text, den hat mir ein Leser empfohlen, aus dem Atlantic. Irgendwelche Forscher wollten in Amerika auch noch mal was zum Oxytocin wissen und haben dann rausgestellt, naja, so persönliche Hinwendung, auch körperliche Art, ist vielleicht gar nicht so sehr auf Oxytocin angewiesen, wie man immer dachte. Und sie wollten eigentlich noch mal zum Oxytocin fragen. Und dann haben sie plötzlich 30 Jahre Wissenschaft in Frage gestellt. Und so auch von diesem Ernst Pher, den ich ja da im Buch habe.
Und diese Kollegen hatten dann keinen Beifall und sagen, oh, das ist aber toll, wenn ich jetzt gerade verbessert werde. Wir wissen noch von Thomas Kuhn sagt es doch, dass wissenschaftliche Revolutionen sich auch vor allem dann durchsetzen, wenn die Alten absterben.
Genau. Und wie häufig beginnen solche Biografien mit so Geschichten wie 30 Jahre lang wurde er verlacht und so weiter. Und dann stellen sie sich raus, er hatte doch recht und so.
Kommen wir gleich zu, sehr guter Punkt. Einberger macht das ganz großartig. Wir hören jetzt noch einmal Maity.
Dann gibt es die Methoden, also wirklich das, was man tatsächlich macht. Und all das ist so eine Art, das klingt jetzt, ich weiß, dass das sehr nicht wissenschaftlich klingt, aber das ist so der wissenschaftliche Spirit. Natürlich kann ich nicht, ähnlich wie eine Statistik, das festnageln darauf, dass das ist Wissenschaft. Das wäre auch seltsam.
Sie arbeitet eigentlich hier mit höchstens anadotischer Evidenz. Wenn ich mal in die Wissenschaften reinschaue, frage ich mich auch, wie schaut man mal in die Wissenschaft rein? Man kennt vielleicht einige Wissenschaftler, hört von denen was, oder man kann mal in einem Labor dabei sein. Aber dieser wissenschaftliche Spirit, der hier diagnostiziert wird, ja, man weiß so, die Fuß haben Wissenschaftler, wollen Ethos und wollen Dinge herausfinden und sind der Wahrheit verpflichtet. Aber dann gibt es Partikularinteressen, dann gibt es rivalisierende Teams, was auch immer. Und dann gibt es auch natürlich bei diesen auch sehr hart naturwissenschaftlichen Sachen ideologische Herangehensweisen. Also, oder wir sehen das ja auch in der Psychologie, welche Krankheiten werden großgemacht, welche nicht, wo sind definitorische Schwierigkeiten, die aber dann aufgrund von Interessenkonflikten so oder so gelöst werden. Das heißt, das ist ein hart umkämpftes Feld. Baudieu hat es auch so immer beschrieben. Also, das ist schon ganz interessant. Er hat ja auch die Soziologie als Kampfplatz beschrieben. Und das gilt aber auch für andere Wissenschaften. Das ist nicht einfach nur so ein Erkenntnisinteresse geleitetes, völlig neutrales. Naja, und jetzt sagt Almberger aber, wenn man immer sagt, ja, das können wir mal beweisen. Jetzt könnten wir ja beweisen, mit einem wissenschaftlichen Experiment, wenn wir uns auskennen würden, wie viel Aspirin gut sind. Wie viel sollte man davon maximal am Tag zu sich nehmen. Das haben Gott sei Dank die Leute dann schon für uns gemacht. Und dann können wir das in der Verpackungsbeilage nochmal nachlesen, wenn wir wollen. Aber das gilt ja nicht für alles.
Aber es gibt ja zum Beispiel, sagen wir die Topologie, einen Teilbereich der Mathematik. Sehr wichtiger. Da würde man sagen, mit Falsifizierbarkeit ist da nicht viel. Man kann ja da keine Studien machen. Man kann keine Experimente machen. Das sind solche abstrakte Überlegungen, die sehr, sehr wichtig sind im Fundament der Wissenschaft. Dass man nicht sagen würde, da wird jetzt falsifiziert. Und wenn sie in ein mathematisches Institut gehen, da würden sie sagen, ja falsifizier mir das mal. Da würden die wahrscheinlich sagen, ja so geht das hier nicht.
Also da kenne ich mich mit Topologie und Mathe nicht genug aus. Aber ich fühle es schon überhaupt, dass man zum Beispiel Berechnungen mit Messungen immer wieder abgleichen kann. Das wäre bei Topologie, glaube ich, naheliegend. Ich weiß es jetzt nicht, aber...
Ja, ihr sagt ja gerade, dass die nicht messen können.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Und das wissen wir ja schon bei Platon, dass die Mathematik in der Reihenabstraktion auch verweilen kann. Und die Linie, die ich dir hier aufmale, oder dass Treiberg so exaktes gezogen ist, ist ja nur ein läppisches Modell für die eigentliche Sache, die man vielleicht veranschaulichen will. Aber gerade da sagt man nicht, ach so, dann nehmen wir doch hier mal einen Dreieck und gucken wirklich mal nach. Nein, das Dreieck kann gar nie so genau sein, wie das, was die Mathematik ausdrückt.
Ja, also wenn sie jetzt sagt, messen. Klar, es ist jetzt so Spontanität und Gespräch, aber sie nennt ja so als erstes das Messen. Und damit ja auch Wiederholbarkeit und darüber dann die Falsifizierbarkeit und so. Das haben wir fast nirgendwo, diese Laborsituation. Also in den ganzen Sozialwissenschaften schon mal gar nicht. Und auch in der Naturwissenschaft nicht allzu häufig. Also in der Biologie, klar, man kann jetzt die Tierarten usw. alle mal ins Labor ziehen, aber wir haben es doch sehr viel mit Beobachtungen in Realität zu tun. Ja, da haben wir halt eine und da haben wir keine Kontrollgruppe oder so, sondern da sieht man halt Schlüsse aus Beobachtungen, die man so hat. Wie viel Vögel leben auf Föhr? Also das ist keine Laborsituation, in der wir irgendwie, sondern da muss man sie halt zählen und da gibt es so Methoden und dann überschlägt man so grob. Aber das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, dass sie auf der Ebene da schon, also es versucht noch über Widerspruch zu klären.
Wo sie selbst ein Buch schreibt über Wissenschaft, wie wichtig die eigentlich ist. Und ich hatte dann gleich gedacht, Moment, Topologie, also es geht natürlich um, da klingt es schon mit, Orte, Räume, was ist da? Und hatte dann gedacht, jetzt bräuchte ich noch mal so ein kurzes Erklärvideo, das noch mal so zeigt, was ist eigentlich da besonders wichtig in der Topologie. Und bei Arte findet man es dann, Arte-Matte-Welten ist ein tolles Format. Das ist ja wunderbar. Da wird das kurz erklärt. Und da hab ich dann auch wieder, war mir plötzlich diese Verbindung klar, Topologie. Denn, naja, ich will es mal noch nicht verraten. Wir hören jetzt erst mal hier rein, diesen Beitrag.
Mitten in der Welt der Mathematik, nicht weit entfernt vom vertrauten Landstrich der Geometrie, liegt eine besonders befremdliche Gegend, in der die grundlegenden Eigenschaften von Räumen untersucht werden. Diese merkwürdige Gegend heißt Topologie. Hier stellte der französische Mathematiker Henri Poincaré 1904 eine Vermutung auf, die seinen Namen trägt, die Poincaré-Vermutung. Generationen von Mathematikern und Mathematikerinnen haben vergeblich versucht, sie zu beweisen. Was also hat es mit dieser berühmten Vermutung auf sich? Sie behauptet, jede kompakte, unberandete, einfach zusammenhängende dreidimensionale Mannigfaltigkeit ist Homöomorph zur Dreisphäre.
Na, kannst du uns erklären, ob das stimmt? Zur Dreisphäre. Ja, man arbeitet da mit Mannigfaltigkeiten. Ich will jetzt hier nicht dilettieren, wahrscheinlich hören uns Mathematiker zu, die das sehr gut auf den Punkt bringen könnten. Aber...
Die das aber alle auch nicht verstehen.
Die erzählen das irgendwas. Diese Poincaré-Vermutung ist schon ganz interessant.
Kann man das mit dem Visualisieren oder so?
Ja, es wird da ein bisschen versucht. Also es gibt da Grenzen. Das ist das Traurige für mich immer. Eigentlich fasziniert mich das unheimlich. Aber es ist einfach nicht möglich nachzuvollziehen. Es ist auch nicht wie, ja, es ist ein schwieriger Autor, aber wenn du dich mal reinbegibst, dann geht's schon. Es ist einfach für gewisse Gehirne und ich sag mal für die meisten Gehirne nicht erschließbar.
Aber sie haben ja zumindest gesagt dreidimensional. Also irgendein Versuch der Visualisierung sollte es ja auch bei Arten gehen.
Ja, es gibt Versuche natürlich der Visualisierung und diese Poincaré-Vermutung, 100 Jahre hat man da also nicht gewusst, was ist das überhaupt, ist das doch einfach Unsinn? Könnte ja Unsinn sein. Und dann in diesem Beitrag geht das dann noch weiter, ich erzähle es aber jetzt mal, und das war dann meine starke Verbindung zur Topologie. Dieses Rätsel wurde ja gelöst von Perlmann, einem russischen Mathematiker, der mit seiner Mutter zusammenlebt, der völlig abgeschieden ist, der nichts mit dem akademischen Leben zu tun hat, der vor einigen Jahren hat er das gelöst, der auch den Preis, der damit verbunden war, alles abgelehnt hat. Und Mascha Gessen, die wir kennen als diejenige, die auch das Putin-Regime originell betrachtet, hat ja dieses herausragende Buch über Perlmann geschrieben. Und auch über diese russischen Mathematiker und all das. Und das ist so interessant, weil man hier schon mal etwas sehen kann. Wir haben es mit jemandem zu tun, der außerhalb des wissenschaftlichen Betriebs agiert und der dann auch noch so weit gegangen ist, das gar nicht über peer-reviewed und so weiter diese Verfahren zu machen. Also wo man dann Konsens herstellen will, also das, was jetzt MyTea stark macht. Sondern der hat das einfach hochgeladen auf so einem Uni-Server. Er hat gesagt, ja, ich habe das hier gelöst, das Rätsel. Daraufhin mussten die dann erst mal zwei Jahre wieder rechnen, ob das überhaupt stimmt, was der da gemacht hat. Und bis auf ein paar kleine Fehler hatte er das dann tatsächlich gelöst. Und da kann man also genau das, was du jetzt gerade schon angesprochen hast, ja, aber was ist, wenn man da den großen Einfall hat, aber erst mal glaubt einem auch niemand und so. Also da sind wir schon da ganz heikelnd gefilmt. Deswegen war Topologie eigentlich genau das Richtige von Allemberger, das zu nennen. Wir hören jetzt aber weiter, Maiti, sie kommt wieder mit diesem kritisch gedacht.
Also ich sag nicht, dass Falsifizierung immer dabei sein muss. Das war nur in der Sendung, um es ein bisschen greifbar zu machen. Weil sonst sagt man den Leuten, kritisches Denken, was soll das bedeuten? Kritisches Denken würde ich schon sagen, ja. Also zur Wissenschaft gehört kritisches Denken. Da gibt es ja viel. Ich sag nicht, dass es die Checkliste vollständig abgehakt sein muss. Aber ich denke schon, dass man halt sagen kann, entweder ist es kritisch gedacht und wenn nicht, es gibt ja auch nicht Wissenschaft, die relevant ist. Es muss ja nicht alles Wissenschaft sein.
Also ich hör sie glaube ich das erste Mal überhaupt in der freien Rede. Ist denn ihr ganzer Fame in diesen kleinen YouTube-Videos auf Verskriptung basierend?
Ich hab mich ja auch nie mit ihr so beschäftigt.
Ihr macht ja auch extrem viel Arbeit, die ganzen Videos immer so krass vorzuschreiben. Ich meine, die ist ja über diese YouTube-Videos.
Ja, aber ich glaube das sind schon Teleprompter-Angelegenheiten, oder?
Aber die hätte auch so krass ausgearbeitet werden müssen.
Na gut, mit einer Redaktion.
Hat die das nicht so auf eigene Faust gemacht? Ist die da nicht so reingewachsen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das von Anfang an so war.
Erstaunlich jedenfalls.
Ich mache ja die Filmanalyse auch auf Englisch. Wer mich mal Englisch sprechen will, kann das machen unter der Filmanalysis. Aber da spreche ich ja auch mit dem Teleprompter. Also es geht schon.
Und macht halt Arbeit, Vorbereitungen und so.
Ja, aber ist vielleicht dann besser als frei. Man weiß es nicht. Wir hören nochmal Eilenberger.
Und was es in der Wissenschaft ja auch gibt, gerade wenn Wissenschaft sehr in Bewegung ist, dynamisch, da gibt es ziemlich viel Streit. Und sogar sehr großen Streit. Zum Beispiel auch Streit darüber, was Evidenzen überhaupt sind. Man kann sich ja zum Beispiel vorstellen, man geht jetzt ins Jahr, wir gehen zusammen ins Jahr 1602. Und da gibt es jemanden wie Galilei, der sagt, ich sehe da Dinge, ich habe eine gewisse Idee. Aber wenn jetzt ein Mailab aus dem Jahre 1602 es geben würde und die würde sagen, nehmt euch mal einen Tee, schauen wir uns mal an, was die Dinge sind, dann wüsste man sagen, ja, der hat eigentlich gar keine guten Evidenzen. Der hat auch keine guten Experimente. Der weiß nicht mal, wie sein Fernrohr funktioniert. Und im Moment können wir nicht sagen, dass der Recht hat.
Ja, es ist exakt das richtige Argument. Ich würde sogar überlegen, ob man das nochmal auf die Pandemie beziehen kann. Wir hatten wissenschaftliche Evidenz bei der Virologie und bei den daran angrenzenden Feldern. Aber wir hatten jetzt zum Beispiel keine Evidenzen. Wir hatten nicht eine solche Beweiskraft, bei dem inwiefern Lockdowns Kindern schaden. Das haben Eltern so erzählt. Du hast es ja auch immer mal wieder gesagt. Man konnte es vielleicht den Kindern am Gesicht ablesen. Aber man hatte da noch nicht eine Studie vorliegen. Konnte sie ja auch noch nicht haben. Und wenn man die aber dann nicht hat, dann findet es auch nicht statt. Jetzt wissen wir und dann geht auch Lauterbach vor die Kameras und sagt, das war ein Fehler, die Schulen zu schließen. Die waren nie der Treiber der Pandemie.
Und zwar nicht nur, weil sie Folgeprobleme haben, sondern weil es auch in der Sache selbst, für die man es gemacht hat, folgenlos war.
Richtig. Und da sehen wir ja schon, wie heikel das ist, wenn wir sagen, wir haben uns zwar da ganz auf die Wissenschaft gestützt, aber wir hatten diese andere Wissenschaft gar nicht parat. Beziehungsweise, eine Zeit lang war es ja auch so, dass man andere Studien schon hatte, die aber sehr stark ausgeblendet hat, weil man immer auf diese virologische Zahl, auf Infektionen und sowas geblickt hat.
Jetzt wo wir Eilenberger hier so als Compagnon sozusagen, für unsere schon anhaltende Kritik an dieser Art Wissenschaftskommunikation haben, ist es ja gut, nochmal darauf hinzuweisen oder überhaupt erst mal darüber zu reden, Mailab oder auch das, was sie in der CDF-Sendung so macht, ist ja im Grunde Darstellung von wissenschaftlichem Wissen, das so erhärtet und beständig, aber eben deswegen auch schon seit Jahrzehnten vorliegt, dass es eigentlich irrelevant ist. Klar, wir stehen alle auf Schultern von Riesen und in der aktuellen Forschung spielt auch eine Rolle, was vor 100 Jahren entdeckt wurde.
Aber das ist wie der Beipackzettel für das Aspirin, das ist halt alles durch.
Genau, für diese Art der Kommunikation, also sie redet ja über Sachen, die von der Bedeutung her, wie diese Supernova vor drei Milliarden Jahren, der Licht wir noch so ein bisschen sehen, aber eigentlich ist es Geschichte, so antike Geschichte. So im Sinne von Mailab zum Thema, ja wie faltet denn jetzt Google die Proteine? Und wir haben einen sehr guten geschriftlichen Kommentar bekommen zum Thema, dass es eben bei den Proteinen nicht nur auf die Aminosäurefolge ankommt, sondern auch auf die Art der Faltung. Weshalb Google eben mit dieser Simulationssache sehr weit kommt in der Vorhersage, wie sich ein Protein im menschlichen Körper verhält, weil am Ende, man weiß nicht genau, nach welchen Kategorien man das macht, es ist jedenfalls nicht nur die Aminosäurefolge, sondern auch die Faltung. Und die Faltung kann absolut belebig sein und da teilt man so in 4000 verschiedene Proteinarten. So und jetzt kommt Google einfach mit dem Anspruch, ja wir sagen euch vorher, wie sich dieses oder jenes Protein verhält im Körper, weil wir vorhersagen können, wie sich das verhält. Das konnte vorher noch nie gemacht werden. Jetzt mit dieser Software von dieser Englischer Dame, mit der sie auch Disco-Spiele und so weiter da alle abgezockt haben, mit der können sie es jetzt. Nur evidenzbasiert, also du kannst die Google-Ingenieure fragen, wie macht das denn der Computer? Dann sagen die, ja, wissen es nicht so ganz genau. Wir haben halt so einen Trainingsalgorithmus und am Ende hat er so hingehauen und wir konnten das so experimentell überprüfen. Aber wenn jetzt eine neue Vorhersage, also so eine neue Prognose für ein Protein kommt, sagen wir halt, aufgrund des Erfahrungswissens, dass das bisher mal hingehauen hat, haut es auch wenn. Und da haben wir wieder so einen Galileo-Moment. Wenn dann MyTea mit ihrem, ja, können Sie das denn messen? Haben Sie es mal falsifizieren zu versuchen? Da kommst du nicht weiter mit dieser Art von Kategorien.
Und ich finde auch, man muss ja hier sehen, es ist eine Philosophiesendung. Es ist, was sie macht, dann eine Wissenschaftssendung. Aber mir geht es ja jetzt gar nicht um sie als Protagonistin, sondern darum, dass wir eigentlich das sehr stark jetzt vertreten haben, also dass das unser Jahrzehnt auch, glaube ich, sehr stark prägen würde, ist dieser doch sehr platte Positivismus. Jetzt müssen wir das mal falsifizieren. Und wenn das geht, dann ist damit auch alles schon geklärt. Und so hat man ja die Pandemiepolitik betrieben und dann sehr reduktionistisch nur auf Einzelzahlen gepflegt und vieles andere ausgeblendet. Und man macht das ja jetzt bei vielen anderen Dingen auch wieder. Und das finde ich, also wir haben das ja auch schon vorher gesehen. Wir haben ja auch schon über diese Rezo-Videos gesprochen, wo er den Zeitungen vorwarf, dass sie ihn nicht richtig beschrieben haben. Und er hat einfach für tonistische Formulierungen genommen und die positivistisch betrachtet und sagt, ja bin ich gar nicht. Also wenn jetzt einer sagen würde, Stefan ist der öffentliche Intellektuelle, der Podcaster oder irgendwas. Genau, dann bist du gar kein Intellektueller, denn du hast ja gar keinen Doktortitel. Also was soll man denn da sagen? Und diese sehr, sehr positivistische Blickweise haben wir eigentlich jetzt dominierend. Und damit kann man natürlich auch sich immer gut immunisieren, wenn man sagt, ja das ist wissenschaftlich, aber nicht erwiesen. Ich hatte jetzt die Diskussion auch im privaten Freundeskreis mit einer Freundin, wo ich auch über Atomkriegsgefahr und so. Und dann hatte sie gesagt, ja aber welche Quellen ich dafür habe. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja ich habe natürlich nicht die Quelle, dass Putin mir eine E-Mail geschrieben hat, wo er sagt, also Folgendes habe ich nächste Woche vor. Ich kann jetzt irgendwelche Artikel anhängen, wo auch drin steht, könnte eine Gefahr sein. Aber natürlich habe ich keine Quelle dafür. Aber ich kann natürlich durch Abstraktion dahin kommen, wenn Atommächte sich gegenüberstehen, dass das mitunter eskalieren könnte.
Wer eine Studie hat, hat Recht. Das war die Logik der Corona-Pandemie. Und sozialwissenschaftliche Fragestellung. Sorry, wir haben hier anhand biologischer, wissenschaftlicher Operationalisierung etwas über das Virus herausgefunden. Alle Folgeprobleme auf anderen Feldern können wir dann betrachten, wenn Studien vorliegen. Und jetzt haben wir Studien zum Thema, wie es alles reingekrätscht hat in die Entwicklung von allem. Die Zahl der schwimmenden Grundschüler hat sich halbiert. Es werden viele Todesfälle geben, wenn im Sommer dann die große Reisewelle beginnt. All solche Sachen, es ist crazy. Also sehr gut, dass diese Sendung so stattfand. Und überraschend immer noch, die My-T so konzeptlos zu hören.
Wir hören noch mal ganz kurze Allenberger.
Oder anders gesagt, es gibt ja Bereiche der Normalwissenschaft, in der dieser Konsens besteht. Aber es gibt Bereiche der Innovationswissenschaft, die ja gerade dadurch, dass sie innovativ sind, überhaupt nicht in diesem Konsens liegen. Und mit denen man dann mit Studien nicht kommen kann, weil es die Studien noch gar nicht gibt.
Also ich behaupte einfach mal, dass wir jetzt über Galilée oder auch Einstein sprechen. Das sind zwei Herren, mit denen ich sehr oft konfrontiert werde. Wenn ich dann irgendwie so schimpfe mit Überimpfungen, also über Leute, die dann falsche Statistik über Impfungen vor sich her tragen. Und ich behaupte, wir reden heute noch so über die und wir haben Einstein-T-Shirts, nicht weil damals seine Ideen so revolutionär waren. Ich bin mir sicher, es gibt zu jedem Zeitpunkt der Geschichte Menschen mit revolutionären Ideen, die dem Konsens komplett widersprechen. Und die Interessanten sind doch die, die dann Recht behalten. Das zeigt sich vielleicht nicht unbedingt dann, aber wie oft wurde Einstein inzwischen nicht nur belegt, sondern er hatte ja auch interessanterweise, er hat ja gesagt, pass auf, guck jetzt in den Himmel, also jetzt nächste Woche, dann, wenn ich nicht Recht habe, passiert das und auch die Möglichkeit, widerlegt zu werden und dass das nicht passiert. Und das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Klar, nicht jeder, der ein einsamer Rufer in der Wüste ist, ist ein Einstein, das ist ja logisch. Nur weil man Unsinn redet und alle anderen sagen, das ist Quatsch, ist man nicht zugleich ein Genie. Aber was ja hier nochmal eigentlich deutlich werden sollte, ist, dass es Konsensbildung gibt. Und wenn diese Konsensbildung noch nicht erreicht ist, was ist dann? Das ist ja das Thema von Thomas Kuhn, von der wissenschaftlichen Revolution, wie die sich anbahnen, wie sie dann auch erst nicht anerkannt werden, nicht als seriös gesehen werden. Und wie lange das dann dauert, bis es institutionell einen Konsens über etwas gibt. Und dass das mit großen Machtkämpfen zusammenhängt. Und dass es nicht nur erst einmal Interesse geleitet ist. Man kann sagen, ja auf lange Sicht, das ist dann das Beispiel Einstein oder Galilée, setzt sich eine Wahrheit durch. Nur kann das dann entsprechend lange dauern. Giordano Bruno wäre ein weiteres Beispiel. Und ich musste bei dieser Sache, deswegen habe ich es wirklich jetzt mal rausgenommen, weil es ja auch noch darüber hinaus so bemerkenswert ist. Wir haben bei Precht und Wälzer dieses Kapitel zum Cursor-Journalismus gehabt. Und dass man immer versucht, zum Konsens herzustellen und auch so ganz nervös guckt. Wie sehen die das jetzt gerade? Ach so, ist noch Maske? Gut, wir sind noch für die Maske. Oder jetzt ist Panzer? Gut, Panzer. Und hier haben wir auch eine Wissenschaftsauffassung, die ganz stark auf dieses Konsensuale aus ist. Und man sieht aber noch gerade, dass dieser Konsens immer ein stark von Interessen durchzogener und zeitlich bedingter Konsens ist. Und dass man da doch sehr vorsichtig sein sollte, diese Konsensideologie so weit zu spinnen, dass das immer das hauptsächliche Kriterium ist.
Ja, vor allem, hier ging es ja auch um die Frage, können denn Laien überhaupt abschätzen? Oder sind sie auch einem Glauben ausgeliefert? Weil Wissenschaftler sagen, das glauben wir jetzt auch. Und ihr Beispiel mit Albert Einstein sagt irgendwie, ich schaue nächste Woche in den Himmel, und wenn das und das ist, dann hatte ich recht. Das ist ja nun der kategoriare Fehler auf mehreren Ebenen, den sie allen anderen vorwirft. Und da ist man echt wieder auf dieser Regentanznummer. Ich sag euch, wenn wir heute keinen Regentanz machen, wird es morgen regnen. Und dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit der 17 Prozent, dass es morgen regnet. Wenn es morgen regnet, hat der Typ Recht gehabt. Und das kann nicht die Erklärung sein. Vor allem nicht von ihr. Eigentlich würde sie so einen Ausschnitt nehmen und sich in ihrer Sendung darüber lustig machen, dass jemand so was im Fernsehen plötzlich als, ja, das ist die wissenschaftliche Methode. Albert Einstein hat gesagt das. Und deswegen stimmt dann auch die Kausalzusammenhänge, obwohl es nur eine Korrelation ist. Wo man wieder bei meinem Lieblingsthema ist, wer ankommt und sagt, aber ja, hast du auch Kausalität und Korrelation verwechselt. Also wer auf der Ebene argumentiert, der verschwendet wirklich nur sinnlose, semantische Diskurszeit. Weil da muss man sofort ins Thema rein und dann richtig darüber diskutieren. Dass sie das hier so sagt, ist wirklich erstaunlich, weil das eigentlich die prototypische Vorlage für eine Sendung bei ihr ist. Wo man richtig spürt, wie sie als Redaktion zusammensitzen. Habt ihr gestern diese Sternstunde Philosophie? Da war so eine Wissenschaftlerin, die hat einen Scheiß erzählt. Und dann würden die das aufgreifen. Aber jetzt war sie es halt selber. Es ist wirklich sehr schön, wie sie sich hier ins Feuer stellt.
Dann sage ich halt immer, ja, nur das Widersprechen. Allein macht dich noch nichts zu einsteigen.
Natürlich, die hat eine alternative Theorie. Aber zum Beispiel der Herr Galileo hatte das Problem, der hatte sein Fernrohr. Der wusste aber nicht genau zu erklären, wie sein Fernrohr funktioniert. Und die Leute sagen, das, was du als Evidenz siehst, da oben auf dem Mond, das ist keine Evidenz, weil du uns nicht sagen kannst, wie dein Fernrohr funktioniert. Was ja zumindest insofern ein Nachdenkproblem ist, dass man sagt, Evidenz als Evidenz gibt es ja gar nicht. Die Evidenz muss ja erst mal als Evidenz zugelassen werden.
Und wer lässt die zu und wann?
Genau, und das ist genau ihre Einflugsschneise. Klar hast du mir jetzt Ergebnisse gezeigt, tolles Informationsgewitter und wie auch immer, aber du musst mir auch deine Methode zeigen. Und wenn das alles nicht fertig ist, dann ist das alles nichts wert.
Das war ja auch der Vorwurf zum Teil dann an Streeck, ist ja noch gar nicht fertig. Ich bin ja auch niemand, der Streeck hier über alle Maßen feiern möchte, aber das war genau immer so dann dieser Vorwurf da. Und man muss sich auch mal fragen, diese ganzen Wissenschaftssendungen, es werden ja viele dieser Art jetzt produziert oder Funk macht da auch einiges. Das ist immer so eine komische Sache. Also wir haben jetzt hier einen Moderator, Eilenberger, der versucht, einen philosophischen Diskurs nicht nur zu führen, sondern uns ja eigentlich so richtig mit dem Eingemachten konfrontiert, dass wir alle aber auch nachvollziehen können. Also es ist ja ganz klar und einfach ausgedrückt. Und das sind ja eigentlich die Sachen, wo die Auseinandersetzung mit wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnis interessant wird. Denn sonst reden wir halt über Beipackzettel und sagen, ja, wurde gemacht, prima. Und auch da kann ich ja nur glauben. Also ich bin ja noch nie dem nachgegangen, sondern da steht Aspirin nicht mehr als, weiß ich nicht, wie viel, zwei Stück am Tag. Ah ja, glaube ich, fertig. Mehr weiß ich ja nicht darüber. Aber für wen macht man denn jetzt eigentlich so eine andere Sendung, also wie jetzt diese MyTea-Show, das ist doch eigentlich eine Sendung, mit der man keine Leute bekehren kann. Also die Leute, die glauben, von der Impfung stirbt man, die gucken ja nicht die Sendung und sagen, ach so ist ja doch anders. Also gucken die die Leute, die ohnehin Bescheid wissen, aber man gibt denen eigentlich so dieses gute Gefühl der Überheblichkeit. Wir sind ja so klug, dass wir wissen, dass Wissenschaft evidenzbasiert ist. Und dann schwelgt man in so einem simplen Positivismus und muss aber auch dann nicht über sich selbst hinausgehen bzw. sich eben mal mit dem konfrontieren, was man nicht wissen kann. Wir hören das jetzt nochmal weiter, weil sie das jetzt als eine akademische Diskussion abtut. Und ich finde das überhaupt nicht akademisch, was Aylenberger hier macht.
Also ich gehe bei allem mit. Ich komme mir oft in solchen Diskussionen so ein bisschen so super hemmsärmlich vor. Oder wie innerhalb der Wissenschaft und Wissenschaftstheorie so eine Handwerkerin, die das dann so pragmatisch sieht. Wo ich sage, ja stimmt, du hast alles recht, aber am Ende habe ich jetzt trotzdem gerade das Problem, dass ich versuche, den Menschen die Impfung zu erklären. Und da sind die, das ist das alles, das ist zwar schön theoretisch und so, aber am Ende bin ich dann doch irgendwie so weit drin, dass ich sage, ja, das ist irgendwie rein akademisch und theoretisch total interessant, sich über solche Sachen Gedanken zu machen. Ich müsste auch zustimmen.
Also die Argumentation hier soll ja lauten, naja, ich habe es damit Leuten zu tun. Wenn ich mit denen damit sowas ankomme, dann wird das eh für die überfordert. Ich soll denen ja nur erklären, dass die Impfung hilft. Und da würde ich sagen, diese Art der Erklärung kann sie gar nicht leisten, weil die nicht fruchtet bei den Leuten. Das geht dann über das persönliche Gespräch. Also derjenige, der mit, meinetwegen, einem Impfskeptiker befreundet ist und wenn man sagt, hör mal, ich hab jetzt auch schon zwei Impfungen, hab mir nichts ausgemacht, vertrau mal. So wie man irgendwie sagt, ja, bei mir hat diese Kopfschmerztablette geholfen, nimm die ruhig auch. Wenn du mir das sagen würdest, dann hätte ich das Vertrauen, dass ich die jetzt auch nehme. Und da lese ich gar keinen Beipackzettel oder sonst was mehr. Dann denke ich, der ist nicht umgefallen, dann werde ich das auch nicht. Auf dieser Ebene. Aber dann brauchen wir ja gar nicht Wissenschaftssendung oder irgendwas. Das ist eine völlig andere Kommunikation. Die ist außerwissenschaftlich. Das ist eine Frage der Vertrauensebene. Was sie jetzt macht, ist, dass sie jetzt diese wissenschaftstheoretisch hochinteressanten Überlegungen von Allenberger nimmt und jetzt eine solche Conclusio macht.
Aber das Problem ist, dass man dann nicht, vor allem wenn man in der Kommunikation mit Laien dann diesen Absolutstrich zieht, der leider oft gezogen wird, sagt, dann kann mehr Wissenschaft gar nichts mehr sagen.
Ich glaube, das ist der kritische Punkt.
Und das finde ich fast schon, wenn man das gut spielt, ist das fast schon eine Wissenschaftsleugnung 2.0.
Wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt angekommen, wo man sagt, die Thematisierung von Wissenschaftstheorie, die Grenzen des wissenschaftlichen Arbeitens aufzeigt, da müssen wir aufpassen, dass wir die jetzt nicht so spielen, dass die zur Wissenschaftsleugnung wird. Klar, ich kann auch den Poststrukturalismus so spielen, dass ich sage, genau, Trump hat ja auch immer die Wahrheit gesagt, selbst wenn er gelogen hat, weil es Wahr und Falsch gar nicht gibt. Und dann zitiere ich irgendwas Lustiges von Delös. Ja, kann ich irgendwie alles missbrauchen. Aber man muss doch eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass man Bürger hat, denen man mehr zutrauen kann, als jetzt einfach nur dieses ganz Profane. Aber sie geht dann so weit, das zu sagen, das ist jetzt der letzte Clip.
Ich bin, glaube ich, in meiner Ausbildung da auch so ein bisschen hemserblicher oder pragmatischer unterwegs und habe da sicherlich auch noch Bildungslücken. Aber ich glaube, gerade aus meiner Realität, für meinen Beruf, denke ich auch so, wir müssen schon verstehen, was davon auch bei den Menschen ankommt. Kommunikation ist nicht das, was man sagt, sondern das, was der andere versteht.
Damit, mit dieser Argumentationsweise, kann man eine Expertokratie etablieren und sagen, gut, liebe Experten, wir müssen das irgendwie nach draußen noch ganz gut kommunizieren. Und da müssen wir sehen, dass wir denen das noch ein bisschen verklickert bekommen. Worum es da eigentlich geht, das können wir gar nicht mehr so genau sagen. Also das ist wirklich ein... Der Vorwurf, der Einberger macht da akademisches Denken oder das so zu Rahmen, führt eigentlich nicht dazu, dass sie jetzt das demokratische Denken macht, sondern nein, sie hatte eigentlich jetzt hier so eine Idee von, naja, ich kann den meisten Menschen die Wahrheit oder die Komplexität der Welt nicht zumuten. Und das ist ja auch das, was Fernsehmacher immer so denken. Das hat ja schon Roger Wilmsen mit diesem tollen Satz gesagt, ja Fernsehen ist die Kultur der Unterforderung. Und alle Fernsehmacher sind immer klüger als ihre Zuschauer oder wählen sich zumindest darin, klüger zu sein. Und sagen ja, das können wir ihnen nicht zumuten. Und das führt aber eigentlich dazu, dass man mit dieser Argumentation es schaffen könnte. Ein Expertengremium, das entscheidet dann einfach, weil man das den anderen eh nicht zumuten kann.
Ja, ich habe mich gestern mit Mick sehr lustig gemacht darüber. Wir haben ein bisschen gerätselt. Der Masalla sitzt bei Illner in der Sendung und ihm gegenüber sitzt Kühnern. Kühnern als SPD-Generalsekretär behauptet, Deutschland hat ganz viel geliefert und so weiter. Und dann sagt der Masalla, wenn ich sie mal unterbrechen darf, das stimmt. Die Deutschen haben wirklich extrem viel geliefert. Woran es aber, und das ist jetzt Originalzitat, seit Anfang an mangelt ist an strategischer Kommunikation. Nämlich, dass man es den Leuten nicht erklärt. Und dann haben wir auch gerätselt, strategische Kommunikation in Sachen Krieg mit dem Publikum. Hier haben wir ja, also es ist sozusagen, es geht um alles, es ist eingemacht, Krieg und Frieden. Und wir wünschen uns eigentlich, dass alles richtig gemacht wird. Nur wir sind hier ganz weit weg von Laborsituationen. Wir haben also all diesen Kriterienkatalog nicht. Und dann ist ja wirklich die Frage, okay, also wäre eine Lösung jetzt eine strategische Kommunikation mit Oma Erna, um den Krieg zu einem besseren Ende zu führen. Also selbst auf der Ebene hat man ganz viel, wenn sie fragt, ja, was kann ich ihnen zumuten, was halte ich auch zurück und was nicht, dass wir es hier auf so vielen Ebenen, bei so vielen Themen mittlerweile so viel Streitbares haben. Also bei Corona wurde zu wenig kommuniziert, jetzt bei, obwohl es unendlich viele Studien gab. Also nichts ist ja so viel erforscht worden wie Covid-19 und so weiter und wie das mit dem Virus zusammenhängt. Da kann man natürlich nur teilweise drüber reden, schon an der Menge wegen. Dann hatten wir den Drosten-Podcast, bei dem es ja auch ins Glauben abgedriftet ist. Da hat es so ein bisschen Einblick gegeben und den Rest musste man halt glauben. Was ja auch sozusagen die Herangehensweise der, das ist ja nicht falsch oder so, sondern so funktioniert es halt. Das ist Wissenschaftskommunikation. Vertrauensvoll wendet man sich an jemanden und glaubt dann einfach, was man hört, damit man andere Sachen weitermachen kann. Und beim Krieg haben wir es halt dann wieder umgedreht, wo ich mir schon wieder denke, nee, der Scholz hat hier gar keine Erklärungsaufgabe, sondern da würde ich dann wieder sagen, dass man so mit je, die sollen das einfach intern klären. Das Militär soll halt ernsthaft den Politikern sagen, was die Optionen sind, wie man es im Film immer so sieht. Der Militär steht halt da und legt so drei Optionen auf den Tisch in der Hoffnung, dass er nicht noch eine Vierte verschleiert oder eben eine besonders protegiert, die er da durchziehen will und so.
Da geht es ja um innere Diplomatie, aber die Wissenschaft ist ja an sich offen. Und klar kann die Wissenschaft jetzt nicht beginnen, damit alles Mögliche aufzutröseln, weil es die meisten Leute ja auch gar nicht interessiert. Also die Wissenschaftler machen ihre wissenschaftliche Arbeit wie andere andere Arbeit machen. Nur, wenn man diese wissenschaftlich, wissenschaftstheoretischen Überlegungen, die Allenberger da formuliert, jetzt dann so hinstellt, ja, wenn man das gekonnt spielt, dann wird das wissenschaftsleugnen 2.0. Also zu sagen, nee, nee, lass mich mal lieber bei meinem simplen Positivismus bleiben, denn der tut auch den Leuten ganz gut, damit die sich impfen lassen, aber mehr sollen die brauchen, die auch gar nicht wissen. Dann kommt man eigentlich in so ein Gefilde, wo man eigentlich die Normalbevölkerung abtrennt und sagt, gut, das machen wir hier mal unter uns aus. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht nochmal da weiter sagen. Und das kann man bei der Geheimdiplomatie vielleicht noch so sehen. Aber wenn das übertragen wird auf Gesellschaft, dann ergibt das dann so etwas, dass plötzlich ein Gremium über Schulschließungen entscheidet, bei dem kein Kinderpsychologe oder so anwesend ist, weil man sich einfach entschieden hat, das ist nicht so wichtig und wir haben doch Evidenz für Fallzahlen. Und das muss reichen, um alles andere einzuschützen.
Ich würde die Ebenenunterscheidung nicht zu groß machen, denn in dieser Art Wissenschaftskommunikation, das Ziel hat die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren. Beispielsweise, das würde ja MIT auch nicht abstreiten, damit die Leute mitziehen. Das ist ja genau die gleiche Fragestellung wie beim Krieg auch. Und es ist zum einen, klar, Diplomatie, die nicht funktioniert, wenn sie transparent ausgetragen wird, was aber eben auch bedeutet, wir wollen ja eine evidenzbasierte kriegerische Taktik. Also so, wie wir es vorhin auch beschrieben haben, man liefert halt erst mal nur Marder und dann guckt man mal. Und dann gibt es eine neue Diskussion zum Thema Leopard aufgrund der Marder-Erfahrung und dann guckt man mal. Also das ist klar jetzt keine Laborsituation, aber es ist sozialwissenschaftliche, evidenzbasierte, mit Abproximationshoffnung. Also man nähert sich so dem an, was man glaubt, was Realität und Wirklichkeit sei. Und dann versucht man halt so den Leuten in den Kopf zu gucken, weil am Ende läuft ja immer alles auf Entscheidungen hinaus. Und da finde ich schon crazy, wie sie so drüber hinwegschwebt, dass es manchmal vielleicht auch gar nichts zu erklären gibt. Oder dass es manchmal auch, selbst wenn es was zu erklären gäbe, es zu aufwendig wäre oder wie auch immer. Es ist zu komplex, also zu viele Möglichkeiten wären möglich. Es gibt gar nicht die eine. Das gibt es dann nur in der Geschichtsschreibung. Wenn alles schon Geschichte ist, dann kann man den einfahren. Aber selbst da gibt es ja wieder Streit.
Und dieses Occupasier-Messer ist halt auch nicht überall anzutreffen.
Genau, und jetzt dachte ich mir, für die ganze Ernährungssache haben wir keine Zeit mehr. Aber für drei Clips doch. Denn die Ernährungs-Docs... Das überprüfen wir jetzt mal. Herausfordert für die einen, lustig für die anderen. Die Ernährungs-Docs, also eine sehr etablierte, sehr beliebte Sendung zum Thema Ernährung, die vor allem für die Altenrepublik gemacht ist.
Kenn ich gar nicht.
Ja, das sind so, die schreiben auch wirklich viele Bücher. Also, jeder hat da nochmal so seinen... Also, das sind alles mittlerweile sehr ausgesorgte Menschen. Also, es sind einfach echte Ärzte, die halt echte Bücher schreiben. Aber medial, wir kennen sie nicht. Das ist super interessant, weil in der Altenrepublik, in dem dritten Programm, ist das das Programm. Also, die Ernährungs-Docs. Das ist deutschlandweit bekannt. Ist glaube ich so ein Abendsding. Es ist glaube ich ein Abendsding. Würde mich wundern. Also, kann auch sein, dass es Nachmittag ist. Aber es ist jedenfalls, frag deine Eltern, frag deine Großeltern. Also, die Ernährungs-Docs sind auf jeden Fall bekannt und Thema. Und wir haben es hier mit Protagonisten zu tun, die streng wissenschaftlich arbeiten, aber es populär wissenschaftlich runterbrechen, weil es Thema jeden betrifft. Und die Ernährung und die extreme Prominenz und Reputation haben bei ihrem Publikum. Nämlich Menschen, die einfach gar nichts damit zu tun haben, sondern sich einfach informieren wollen. Und die haben sich jetzt als Thema, zum Beispiel am 18. Januar, Longcovid genommen. Und sie stellen uns eine Protagonistin vor, und Longcovid ist ja mittlerweile eine Krankheit, die auch in den Krankheitskatalogen mit 15 Symptomen oder so soweit katalogisiert ist. Also die kann man auch echt diagnostizieren und dann Therapieverfahren einleiten und so weiter. Das ist alles geregelt. Und jetzt treffen die auf eine Protagonistin, die sagt, ich habe Longcovid. Und die selber hantieren aber nicht mit Medizin, sondern nur mit Ernährung. Woher für viele schon wieder so Voodoo ist. Kann man jetzt wirklich eine echte Krankheit mit nur Ernährung, müsste man nicht in Medizin und so weiter. Und ich fand das mega skurril, wie wir jetzt, nachdem Corona ja noch nicht lange rum ist, so einen ganz hypernormalisierten Umgang mit Corona haben, wo man auch ganz normal jetzt einfach mal über Ernährung als Thema sprechen kann. Ich habe mir ja auch schon mal Ärger eingehandelt, als ich meinte, eine gesunde Ernährung hilft genauso gut gegen Corona wie die erste AstraZeneca-Impfung, weil ein gesunder Lebensstil eben alle möglichen Zivilisationskrankheiten wenn man mal runterdimmt und so. Also dass man da auch gleich auf mit Vorbeugung durch die Impfung ist. Und wir hören uns das mal in drei Clips an.
Ich bin einfach nicht mehr die, die ich vorher war. Mein Name ist Jennifer Helms, ich bin 35 Jahre alt und ich leide an Longcovid.
Folgen einer Corona-Infektion. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO definiert, wer 12 Wochen nach Corona-Infektion an Erschöpfung, Kurzatmigkeit und kognitiven Störungen leidet, hat Longcovid.
So, sie hat also Longcovid und geht damit zu den Ernährungs-Docs. Kann man sagen, das ist aber unkonventionell. Immerhin ist es ja eine diagnostizierte Krankheit, will sie nicht richtige Medizin nehmen. Und der Ernährungs-Doc, der eine, seinen Namen habe ich vergessen, aber ich habe auch schon mal ein Buch von ihm gelesen, rät ihr zu einer Ernährungsumstellung.
Das hier ist Jenny hauptsächlich. Weißmehlprodukte, Wurst, Zucker, leere Kalorien, die ihr Immunsystem belasten.
Ein beschäftigtes Immunsystem, das die ganze Zeit auf Hochturn arbeitet, das macht müde.
Wahnsinn.
Das ist schon erschreckend, das alles so auf einem Haufen zu sehen.
Einmal, was sie in der Woche so isst, die Süßigkeiten, die weißen Brötchen und so, alles mal aufgetischt.
Sie brauchen das hier.
Pflanzenpunkte. Die bekommt Jenny für unverarbeitetes, vollwertiges Essen auf Pflanzenbasis. Dazu zählen alle Obst- und Gemüsesorten, Vollkornprodukte, Hülsenfrüchte, Nüsse, Kerne und Samen, Kräuter und Gewürze. Pro Portion etwa eine Handvoll gibt es einen Punkt. Kräuter und Gewürze liefern einen Viertelpunkt.
Vielfalt ist das Ziel. Ab sofort sammeln Sie 30 verschiedene Pflanzenpunkte pro Woche.
Okay, so, dann springen wir zum Ende der Sendung. Sie hat das also durchgezogen. Am Anfang hatte sie 14 der 15 Symptome, die bei ihr festgestellt wurden. Und am Ende blieben nur noch drei übrig.
Jenny hat nur noch drei von 14 Symptomen.
So, und das wird dann so symbolisiert in verschiedenen Sachen. Also übrig geblieben ist dann, keine Ahnung, was auf diesen so kleinen Zettelchen, die sie da visualisieren, illustrieren, darstellen. Hat aber, das meiste ist halt weg. So, und das wäre natürlich vor zwei Jahren undenkbar gewesen.
So ein Beitrag, ja.
Man hätte den NDR in dem Falle geschlachtet, alle vorgeführt, alle gecancelt, mit so einem Hinweis auf, ja klar, trifft dich Corona besonders schwer, aber Coronas Beuteschema sind die Zivilisationskrankheiten und du hast leider alle davon. Du bist übergewichtig, du ernährst dich falsch, du hast alles, was eine falsche Ernährung mit sich bringt und man isst nun mal, was man isst. So, und das geht mittlerweile aber durch als öffentliche Kommunikation. Es ist im Maße, wie MIT sich das vorstellt, eine wissenschaftlich basierte Kommunikation, die vorgestellt wird als evidenzbasiert. Wir haben sogar einen Fall, der stellvertretend für viele gilt, also auch wahrscheinlich für dich und so. Also das hakt alle Kriterien ab, die MIT kann man zumuten, so sollte man es kommunizieren.
Trotzdem konnte es jetzt erst sein und nicht schon früher sein.
Ja, weil man das halt nicht verifizieren kann im Sinne von, nee, Corona tötet die halbe Welt, du kannst doch nicht hier mit Norbertes Brötchen austauschen und so weiter. Hier gibt es nichts zu verifizieren. Ernährung ist so ein super komplexer Zusammenhang und so super individuell, dass du halt einfach nur eine Korrelation beobachten kannst, aber eben keine Kausalität.
Und bevor jetzt nochmal welche schon in ihr E-Mail-Programm gerade öffnen, ja, es gibt auch Formen von Longcovid, das trifft ganz gesunde sportliche Leute. Und die haben dann andere Probleme. Ich habe auch einen Bekannten, der ein Herzproblem davongetragen hat und der mega sportlich ist und sich sehr gesund ernährt. Und ja, es ist auch nicht alles mit Ernährungswahn, aber in diesem Fall ist es so. Und es ist auch in vielen anderen Fällen so. Und ich muss aber trotzdem sagen, dass wir jetzt Schnitzel essen gehen.
Und du auch noch ohne Gemüse.
Aber wir laden es nicht politisch auf. Es ist kein Akt gegen die Wissenschaften. Wir machen auch keine Kulturalisierung. Wir verteidigen mit dem Schnitzel uns wieder.
Das Tier ist auch schon lange tot, bevor wir es jetzt bestellen.
Ja, gut, also das ist natürlich ein tierethisches Problem. Das ist ein Dilemma, das wir uns jetzt bewusst reinbegeben. Aus Hedonismus heraus. Aber wir kulturalisieren es nicht. Wir verteidigen damit nicht das Abendland. Es ist auch kein Statement gegen die Klimaaktivisten. Wir wissen, wir wollen jetzt gleich mal essen gehen. Mehr ist es nicht.
Schauen wir noch zwei Clips, was meinst du?
Ja, ich hab schon abmoderiert, aber mach mal weiter.
Machen wir mal ein minimales Thema. Ich denke mir, weil es auch gerade passt zum Thema, wie werden wir eigentlich künftig diskutieren? In Florida und in Kalifornien gibt es zwei Gouverneure, die echt antreten. Einer von beiden wird nächster Präsident. Beiden wird irgendwie rausgekegelt. Und Donald Trump hat sich schon selber disqualifiziert. Oder ist dann wirklich so strafrechtlich in der Pyrdole, dass er gar nicht groß antreten kann, auch wenn er seine Kandidatur schon erklärt hat. Und wir hören jetzt mal nur an Beispielen und jeweils weniger als eine Minute, wie künftig diskutiert wird. Und wir sind jetzt, und da kann man ja eine Klammer heute drüber machen, jenseits allem Evidenzbasierten oder irgendwas. Wir sind nur noch auf der Ebene der Semantik. Das hat hier kaum noch irgendwas mit Realität. Das hat nur noch mit Gefühl zu tun.
Und das meint jetzt natürlich Mathias, um sie da zu verteidigen. Sie versucht natürlich auch klar zu machen, ich will die Leute, die sich da jenseits von Gutemöse befinden, die kann nicht, brauche ich gar nicht, mit Einstein und Topologie oder sonst was kommen. Aber da würde ich auch sagen, mit diesem simplen Positivismus kommt man bei denen auch nicht weiter.
Nee, also diese Tür ist verschlossen.
Von allem. Deswegen würde ich eher sagen, mal diese wissenschaftlichen Theorien und die Wissenschaftstheorie ernst nehmen und sich an die wenden, die man erreichen kann. Aber nicht nur in dem Sinne von, seht her, wie doof die anderen sind, sondern eher zeigen auch die eigene Fehleroffenheit anzuerkennen. Denn das war ja auch was, wir hatten auch einen Rezo gehabt, der ein Video zu Armin Laschet und Schulschließungen usw. machte, wo man dann auch im Nachhinein evidenzbasiert sagen kann, naja, Rezo, das war leider nicht richtig.
Genau, da lag es so einfach inhaltlich wirklich falsch. Aber es ging noch um Inhalte. Man konnte noch positiv, negativ darüber befinden oder die Zeit gewähren lassen, Studienwissen abwarten usw. Davon sind wir ganz weit weg, es ist wirklich erstaunlich. In Amerika gibt es nur noch Identitätspolitik auf bundespolitischer Ebene. Diese ganzen Ressort-Aufteilungen, irgendwas mit Verkehrspolitik, Sozialpolitik, Finanzpolitik, Außenpolitik, alles. Geschichte findet nicht mehr massenmedial statt. Es geht nur noch hier rum. Und wir fangen an bei Ron DeSantis, also dem Kommandeur von Florida, der einfach mal ins Blaue hinein, warum Florida, warum er und so überhaupt. Wir wissen, es gibt sehr viele Amerikaner, die nicht in Florida leben, aber dieses floridianische Lebensgefühl von ihm jetzt übergestillt bekommen möchten. Und im Gegensatz dazu Gavin Newsom, also der demokratische Gouverneur von Kalifornien, der im Grunde das einfach spiegelt.
Er hat das jetzt schon seit den letzten Monaten gemacht, dass Kalifornien die letzte Linie in der Gefahr der Werte der blühen Staaten ist, insbesondere bei Problemen wie Abortionen. Oder in den Fällen, die er in seinem Ingenieur hat, wartet er gegen die rote Staaten, und was er nennt, die Medien, die die Staaten und die Menschen, die in diesen Staaten beteiligt sind.
Wieder, es fühlt sich sehr ähnlich an, wie DeSantis in dem Sinne, wenn du in die Kalifornien kommst.
Also die reagieren beide schon in Staaten, die auch ohne amerikanische Anbindung zu den Top 20 der größten Länder der Welt gehören würden, Kalifornien, Florida und so. Die haben die echte Macht dort, die machen die echte Politik und die geben sich öffentlich nicht mehr mit politischen Inhalten, sondern nur noch das hier. Und so wird auch der amerikanische Wahlkampf in einem Herbst losgehen. Ja, also das sind Sehgewohnheiten, an die man anschließen kann. Und so insgesamt, also dass man einfach so mediale Figuren hat, wo man sieht, die laufen nicht so normal auf der Straße rum. Also wir sind hier im Metier der Ästhetik und so weiter. Da kümmert man sich darum, wie man aussieht und wie man spricht und überhaupt.
Der ist ja drei Stunden zurechtgemacht, bevor er da so steht.
Und das ist maßgebend wahrscheinlich für jede politische Debatte. Wir haben ja schon gesehen, wie der Trumpismus als Methode sozusagen in die ganzen Leopard-Corona-Diskussionen einspricht.
Deswegen sage ich ja Vorsicht vor diesen Kulturalisierungen. Nicht fragen, welche Vornamen haben Leute, die Böller schmeißen. Und zwar im Dezember nicht. Wenn es um das Böllerverbot geht, dann ist es Uwe. Und im Januar, wenn die Rechten kommen, dann sagen die ja, ne, das war ja gar nicht Uwe, das war jemand anders.
Also in deren Sicht das Jahrzehnt wird noch spannend. Was das angeht. Und für MyT sehr schwer. Denn diesen Kriterienkatalog, klar, kann man noch aufrechterhalten, aber es wird immer weniger funktionieren.
Wir sehen uns dann im Salon und sprechen über das Buch von Prince Harry. Wir nehmen noch das neue Buch von Cory Doctorow dazu. Hast du einen Titel für uns? Das wäre doch noch interessant. Dann sage ich so lange, was ich noch auf jeden Fall mitbringen werde. Ich habe einmal das kleine Büchlein von Annie Arnault gelesen, wo sie davon erzählt, wie sie eine Affäre mit einem jungen Mann hatte. Darüber sprechen wir nur kurz, worüber ich gerne ein bisschen größer sprechen will. Ist der neue Roman von Fred Easton Ellis The Shards. Ich bin völlig umgehauen davon. Es ist so ein hochinteressantes Buch. Und da gibt es einiges zu sagen. Das ist das, was ich auf jeden Fall schon mal vorab sagen kann. Und die kürzeren Texte, da ist eine Auswahl, die ich noch nicht getroffen habe.
Sehr gut. Ich sehe es jetzt gerade noch nicht gelistet bei Amazon. Warum eigentlich?
Vielleicht ist es noch gar nicht erschienen.
Doch es ist schon erschienen. Er hat es auf seiner Seite. Moment.
Wir warten jetzt noch. Stefan sucht jetzt hier live das Buch, das wir besprechen sollen.
Also er hat es auf seiner Webseite groß rauf. Ich musste mal die Webseite aufrufen, was ich jetzt hiermit tue. Nachdem erstmal die ganzen Wikipedia-Seiten. Da ich ja weiß, seine Seite heißt Grabhound. JokePoint Capitalism zusammen mit Rebecca Giblin hat es geschrieben. Ich habe ihn bei Pivot gehört im Gespräch mit Karas Wischer. Ich fand das sehr gut. Es schließt an einiges an, was wir schon besprochen haben. Es geht um die How Big Tech and Big Content, Captured Creative Labor Markets und How We Will Win Them Back. Eine Rückeroberung der kreativen Sphäre, die einmal komplett der digitalen Kapitalismus-Logik unterworfen wurde mit allen Monopolisierungen und sonstigen Fallstrichen, die da zusammenhängen. Ergänzend wahrscheinlich sehr durch diesen Atlantic Oxytocin-Artikel. Und beim Rest werde ich mal schauen.
Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Bis dahin alles Gute.